[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in the world four players have to show
their best chest in the elimination
bracket two will be knocked out it is
high stakes matches the app accessible
Masters today and the action Starts Now
[Music]
on Earth that we save this position well
Magnus just widening his eyes they're
shocked by this last decision he is
showing no fear whatsoever
we have winner
[Music]
this is Magnus carlsen's last tournament
as world champion and he is in the
elimination bracket it will be a
dramatic day of Chess and we'll make
sure you don't miss any of the action
we'll be calling it all out from our
studio Grandmaster David Howell
that's the James Conti we here
Grandma Sir Robert Hess
David what a roller coaster they want
that was was that the most intense day
one of the tour ever it might be the
most dramatic day of Chess I've ever
seen and uh yeah it had everything
really it had big upsets Magnus Carlson
falling to defeat it had time scrambles
Armageddon and yeah I'm just hoping for
more of the same today
we had three armor Gardens that very
well could have been for what a day of
Chess James what was the big highlight
for you well of course Magnus losing
he's in the losers bracket Magnuson
loser is not in the same sentence you
know what I mean right so that was a
huge upset there but also artemia is
playing out of his mind right now
probably play good too as well and of
course we got a lot of other tracks
coming up today so day two is gonna be
crazy yeah yeah can't wait we got a
taste of what a monstrous lineup it is
at the chessable Masters Robert you call
it artfest that we will not be seeing a
Magnus Hikaru Final in this one are you
sticking to that prediction I absolutely
am Magnus lost Hikaru was fortunate not
to lose so I feel like what we've seen
from day one is in this 2750 average
field not a single player is scared of
the magnuses or their cars and they may
be taken down
still getting over it here's what
happened
he's just taking too much time Vlad
still in a big thing tank whoa what is
that oh he about to take on uh he's
gonna take that yeah he's training
is nice it's time to go he walked into a
pin and I told you float like a
butterfly State and that one stings
because Magnus he moves again and had
the white pieces the booth that hurts
Magnus Carlton resigns it could be
dangerous like H5 H4 check and oh my God
oh my goodness what happened H2 he's
coming he's just Bishop he goes back
five and he takes the motion
look at our Timmy his face oh
just last
is he getting checkmated look at that
white king my goodness it's fighting
against a black Rooker Black Knight a
black king and if it's not Checkmate
Hikaru is going to win so the evaluation
Bar says yes but where is The Knockout
blue he's winning again unbelievable
this is an unbelievable streak I've
never seen anything like this from any
player on the planet to be able to beat
Hikaru in all of these games look at him
he said he's frustrated he's angry
everything under control easy win now
for FedEx but we've got to commend him
it looked so messy he kept a calm head
and uh Hikaru is just not at his best
today storm is away I won't be surprised
if that kind of meeting that occurs here
it's that straightforward White's piece
is not in position to stop that
Checkmate and a car has played perfect
chess you call that it's tutu we're
heading to Armageddon
he needs to win a nine seconds oh he's
not going to he's not got any any time
just oh now there's gonna be checkmates
did he find it
five seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was sick
so many twists sentence ended in a
Checkmate in the Armageddon for the
world champion and after a difficult day
Magnus graciously agreed to give us an
interview this is how he summed it up
it was a pretty
pretty uh bad
um
uh he generally you know uh played me in
the the third game
um first was yeah just
barrage of uh blunders really but I mean
the last game was was terrible this was
a really really awful day of uh chess
um like
I did everything to lose and then some
uh obviously you know it takes a strong
opponent to to exploit that but that was
really pretty poor so we'll see I'll um
um to do my best tomorrow but this yeah
this is unacceptable
wow a tough day there for Magnus Carlsen
he is in the elimination bracket on day
one it just looked like artemia was the
better player this is a bracket going
into day two of the adjustable Masters
David the Shocker has to be to see
Magnus Carlsen in the losers bracket
what is his mindset coming in today well
Magnus has to do something different he
also needs to start faster yesterday he
started with a loss with the white
pieces and his day just didn't get
better from there uh Magnus whether it's
a change of openings whether it's a
change of strategy he needs that far
start today yeah he sounded really angry
with himself in that interview very
upset with the way he played and to
cheer himself up one would expect he'd
be studying openings looking at some
more chess but that wasn't the case
instead Magnus is out skiing hope this
prep works better today Robert I'm gonna
call this the Avalanche opening a
trademark it right now I don't know if
that's a thing that's the Avalanche I
think he's gonna come and swing because
he's upset after yesterday's debacle
yeah I love it next course on chessable
by Robert Hess the Avalanche opening
James was day one a big wake-up call for
the big names yeah definitely a big
wake-up call of course if Nakamura
almost went down so this is like hey
wake up if you want to win you need to
win and you need to win cleanly of
course don't let this happen again
Magnus of course being a loser's bracket
he needs to of course clear his head
like he did when he was at the you know
playing the Avalanche opening out there
right so he's uh clearing his head and
coming back hopefully stronger today to
beat Liam yeah he
need all the fresh air
is a lot at stake two players it will be
the end of the road for two players they
will be knocked out it is a brutal
format the players are fighting to win
The chessable Masters they're fighting
for tour points and of course the big
ticket in to the CCD final so much on
the line This is the biggest ever season
of the Champions Chester
the 2023 Champions chess tour is the
biggest tour yet with a thrilling brand
new format and two million dollars in
prizes it's the richest online
tournament of all time
it begins with six elite events taking
place between February and September
each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
plans locking in 56 players to the main
events
there players are grouped into three
divisions and compete for 235 thousand
dollars in prizes each time
victory in division one in any of the
six events secures a spot directly to
the eight player Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate toward
leaderboard points across the six events
competing for another one hundred
thousand dollars in prize money and the
unsecured playoff spots will go directly
to the top leaderboard finishers at the
end of the year we have two weeks of
incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs from which just four players
will advance to the Champions chess tour
finals to a single elimination bracket
which will ultimately determine our
champion
together the playoffs and finals feature
a whopping 500 thousand dollars in
prizes
there could only be one
in December of 2023 an Undisputed tour
Champion will be crowned
let the games begin
five hundred thousand dollars
are critical yeah it's not all about the
money they say It's All About the
Benjamins but here the tour points mean
a lot because six players may make their
way through based on winning division
one that leaves at minimum two spots up
to Four Points yeah
yeah it's not just door points on stake
in division one but in the other
divisions well the players are fighting
for a qualification spot into the next
Champions chess store as well as those
critical top points there we see Robert
not about Abdul satrov and Vladimir
kramnik had big wins on day one and
we've got some spicy matchups today
keeps up his winning ways the 14th World
Champion he's doing great he loves this
rapid timing show but the two people I'm
gonna single out are Dennis lazovic and
Maxime vascher lagrove then last as he's
known on chess.com he's a teenager from
Belarus Maxima Sheila grab the former
World Blitz Champion they won day one
Dennis lesbian taking out dubov they're
not stopping here in day two wow I'm
looking at this Vladimir kramnik the
14th World Champion Maxine Russell the
2021 Blitz World Champion not the back
of the satro the youngest ever rapid
world champion was that really division
two we were looking at Robert how strong
it is it's no easy opponents no matter
where you look yeah I love it it's not
just division two check out the names in
division three and the action that is
today shock for your mama jorov he is a
super Grand Master amongst the world's
Elite for nearly two decades he's on his
back foot against the means having to
buy but there's also the FFL the famous
fun Legend got akovski he's having a lot
of fun in division three here at the
chessel Masters he's taking on super
Grandmaster Wei Yi so it's tough
sledding out there for the American GM
but he's hanging right in the thick of
things
famous fun Legend I love how you
talk about it of course we will be
keeping an eye out on division two and
three but it is a focus on division one
the big elimination bracket how
important will it be for Liam to get his
kind of openings Robert it's essential
because it gets Magnus Carlson you don't
want to be outplayed you need to get an
edge out of the early stage of the game
yeah he needs to keep that clock on the
check and get the kinds of positions
that he likes to play that is going to
be the task for Liam and David gives us
a little sneak peek into Liam Lee's
style of play
foreign
is one of the classiest players on the
circuit the Vietnamese Grandmaster is
now resident in St Louis where he works
as a coach for the very strong Webster
University team some of those players
also help Infuse him with new opening
ideas Liam is a solid player but he can
be creative when given the opportunity
with white he often starts with the
Catalan opening maybe the London system
and he often gets very decent advantages
even against the best players in the
world with black very solid with one E5
and the Queen's Gambit declined the
Staples of his repertoire this is one
example of his use of the London system
where he beat me a few years ago this
game took place in the 2017 World Blitz
championship in this position he shocked
me with an extremely strong move white
pushed the pawn to D5 cramping down on
the black position and this is a dream
London system for white white Bishop's a
fantastically placed white has more
space and black simply has no plan he
went on to smoothly outplay me watch out
for Liam in this tournament he might be
one of The Underdogs but he can beat
anyone on his day
[Music]
wow David that was a really fun great
video there yeah what can I say Liam is
a superstar in his own right and uh yeah
it was an honor to be able to paid that
off wow well he does have big task ahead
of him as in our losers bracket he will
be facing Magnus Carlsen with the other
matchup Vladimir photos you have taken
on Labon aronian James both these
players could very well have been in the
Winner's bracket today absolutely of
course you have big fish which is fair
to say if he's doing big things and he
almost took down Nakamura which is
absolutely insane of course in that last
match I've owned in the last five or six
games in the title Tuesday was crazy
that you know if a fellas was able to
win he almost took down Nakamura again
and then we got LeBron aronia here who
just does his thing he's a veteran
creative very attacking player that's
going to be a heavyweight matchup for
sure
is the
news match against Wesley Seoul drawing
first blood but eventually went down to
lose against Wesley Wesley making it
through to the winners bracket there for
the semi-finals will be facing Hikaru
Nakamura that's a matchup that we've
seen so many times in the Champions
Chester and we've got vladislav our
Tamia taking on Fabiano caruana and I
have to say Robert both are tamiab and
Fabi they convincingly won their matches
yesterday even though it was the
Armageddon yeah it went down to the wire
but they did have the upper hand it felt
like and that's a lot because artemio
was playing Carlson but Fabiano that's
another tough opponent for him it's
toss-up absolutely it wasn't just the
scoreline but also the style of play and
the dominating performance by these
players in the semi-finals bracket but
we will be starting the day with our
losers bracket the elimination bracket
and the big difference in this one is
that there are only two games there is
no margin forever error there's no time
to come back both players get only one
right so you've got to go all out you've
got to make the most of those whites
they will be playing with 15 minutes and
a three second increment in case there's
a tie we will once again head over to
the Armageddon wow it's going to be a
fun day David yeah it's going to be a
fun day and I can't wait to get started
I think those players in the elimination
bracket they're just getting ready
making those last minute preparations
and there we see empty Chair by Magnus
Carlson I saw something in the
background I think he's there at least
uh ready still he's not skiing right now
I hope he's back from
up in those mountains
wow we're waiting for Magnus Carlsen and
Liam Lee is ready to go what are the
openings that we're expecting here
Robert well I think David summarizes
quite well from when lay especially as
the white side but from magnets you
never know what to expect I can't even
tell you his first move I have no clue
could be one of 20 Robert I'll tell you
that 20 possible first moves he's played
them all at some point in his career
night night of three let's make a
catalog
another three James I'll say D4 Robert I
have to go into E4 then I'm picking C4
we've got it all covered what if he
plays one B three
okay what's the lottery ticket you know
you took all the other options so I just
went with the king's Pond Best Buy test
hey okay yeah and the Kingsport is met
by a sicilian from Liam lay he does have
more solid yeah
let me get this grub real quick all
right it's my move oh my bad long day of
skiing he needs the energy he needs to
replenish his uh his reserves that let
me just hold on I got you bro I'm gonna
give you a time spot really that's how
it is especially I'm even Carlson being
uh up minigame bro he's smashing he is
smashing his food right now you don't
care nothing about this game he's like I
got this in the bag right of course
their record actually I mean he's up a
lot of games against Liam so I guess
he's very comfortable right now yeah I
think the head to head in Rapid chest at
least there's 14 wins for Magnus and
three fullium so quite one-sided but uh
yeah Liam does have a score to settle
he's just playing the waiting game right
now that must be good what you eating
put it in the chat what do you think
Carlson is eating right now
I vote noodles yeah we've seen him do
that before historically that tends to
be his favorite Junior chess matches
nice so where's the move Magnus we want
a Magnus what are you doing D4 okay
there it is and uh it's an open Sicilian
Liam I've got to admire that just the
patience he didn't Flinch One slim he
was not disturbed by uh magnus's long
pause there and it's the four nights
variation of the Sicilian there we go
there we go that's what I'm talking
about right there that's exactly right
G4 foot of score baby yeah it's about to
get nasty wow Brad oh this is uh
impressive stuff Magnus going straight
on the attack straight with the kill
switching up his strategy yesterday the
slow approach didn't work
no one question for you Robert are you I
Rise to see Magnus
it's a G4 or
immediately played D5 yeah D5 seems
principled so I get why he would rush
that decision but now we see him deep in
thought because it's not easy there's
maximum pressure against that Knight
that is now pinned so them knows he
needs to deal with that he needs to
defend that night but how to do so it's
a not an easy question yeah and we're
about to also kick off our other game of
the loser's bracket as Vladimir fetusiv
gets ready to take on Lavon aronian with
the white pieces also starts with the
King spawn opening yeah better say if he
started with this opening plenty of
times yesterday against Hikaru Nakamura
eventually going down to defeat here but
uh this time it is level neronian with
black playing E5 just very solid
approach so these two games will be
ongoing and we'll keep everyone up to
date
with any big
kind of developments but uh meanwhile it
is federative I'm just waiting for the
move here right it's bit it's a bit of a
strange one to think or move three for
white especially if your opponent's
playing uh his main opening he goes for
the Spanish and it's the Berlin the
dreaded Berlin one of my favorite
openings because I'm a boring old man
but uh yeah just solid start for level
it shows how much respect he has for
Vladimir felicev the silly stage yeah I
mean you can go to sleep right here chat
if you like you want to get a nap that's
going to be right now of course the
Berlin okay Knight C3 there we go there
we go now we're gonna have some action
oh Knight D4 yeah no this is this is a
good way for white to avoid some of
these main lines we saw Vladimir
krummick use it with great success the
Berlin defense against Garrett Kasparov
in their world championship match when
krummick rested the title away from who
had been the greatest player of all time
now Magnus Carlson gives him a run for
his money in that category but here you
see white is a little bit ahead in
development Black's E5 Pawn the one in
front of the king is a bit vulnerable so
black has to deal with that well white
gets that first move Advantage yep so
this uh is called the four nights the
Spanish four nights and uh now this
actually this is a pawn sacrifice for
black white can get greedy if he wants
and capture this black e-pawn in the
center with his Knight but that does
lead to a variation that's actually
quite well known that has been studied
in depth and Whisper it quietly does
tend to lead to a fourth draw so
Vladimir fellas much more aggressive
player keeps the tension not getting
greedy and grabbing Pawns and now the
game will take a bit of a slower Pace
very symmetrical so far First Trade of
knights and this one the tension will be
pushed towards the middle game yeah
David you said it this is a slow paced
opening and will take its time to
develop into a rich middle game but I'm
just glad that we didn't see any of
those quick Berlin draws we still get
action on this one but the Sicilian in
the Magnus Liam game that is already
heating up so we're going to head
straight into that one what is this
position there have been trades in the
center White's King still on E1 take it
away David uh thank you Tanya for
bringing it to me this one is just crazy
at this early stage
um I must admit I know zero opening
theory in this position that needs to be
a chessable course there must be a chess
on this one
the walking encyclopedia I already knows
there's definitely of course Seth Dorman
if you guys want to know that's actually
the most aggressive uh aggressive
Sicilian course is actually bicep dormi
as a part one and part two this will be
in part two in the Sicilian bear
Creations right so he does go G4 and
mini lines in fact it had a game against
gamagami that I won GM U.S Masters first
round beat him with the G4 line it was a
seven engine but here you have G4 and H4
and you play G5 and you just literally
rip his head off that's all you're
trying to do in this in this opening and
Liam is going for what Liam is in he's
in Ford right now I I can pay attention
to the chest but you're like an
encyclopedia over here hey you know
every
course out
quoting authors and games that's right
who are you I mean I am a Jedi I am a
Jedi it's the way of the Jedi impressive
stuff and I think Liam was actually
terrified of his head being ripped off
as he said that James uh so he's just
trying to trade pieces that tends to be
a good strategy fight in the center when
your opponent's attacking on the flank
and here with this last move Liam's
captured in the center with a knight
he's saying actually all of the knights
can come off the board I'm very happy
with that and then your G4 move with
white does look a bit odd it looks out
of place uh White's Pawn structure on
the king side might just be very weak
later on in the game so Magnus needs to
justify his early aggression right now
and uh he needs to figure out a way to
do that again I'm slightly surprised
magnus's paused because it was him who
chose the opening this must have been in
this preparation what do we think here
what is his next move going to be other
than just trading Knights and accepting
a very balanced position yeah usually
what we want to do is get the queen F3
but here he kind of it's difficult
because the Knight is under attack here
on D4 so if we can get Queen F3 and
Castle Queen side well then this is all
Justified this is usually what we do of
course we're not casting King side
because we already played G4 why would
we do this so you definitely want to
Castle Queen side but he's trying to
figure out what to do maybe I move the
Knight to B3 but if I trade on C6 I may
open the B file and give black an attack
especially if I'm going to move the
bishop and Castle Queen side so it is
problematic here he's trying to figure
out what to do you may see something
like Knight to B3 um and then bit Queen
F3 Bishop D2 and castle queenside Yeah
uh it is a very decent plan I agree
James but it does take a bit of time so
it feels like Liam uh before the white
king is able to jump over to the queen
side he will be able to strike or at
least cause some problems and uh yeah
Magnus dilemma he's in the tank yeah not
liking White's position already with
that pawn on G4 the king and the Santa
James you mentioned Queen side castling
but that doesn't feel feel very safe
either with the Sea Lion open already it
just looks like Liam has developed all
his pieces he's the one who's ahead on
the clock has this opening completely
backfired for Magnus Robert oh for sure
this is one of those do as he says not
as he does moments where Magnus can get
away with it he's the strongest player
in history he's the world champion but
he's doing some dangerous pretty bad
stuff so do not try this at home for all
those of you watching White's best move
is to take that G4 pawn and bring it
back bring it back to the second rank
like that would be okay for white and
even then I don't think black would have
problems but right now a white has huge
problems because your king will never
find true shelter yeah I mentioned that
Magnus needed to kind of switch things
up change his strategy change his
routine change something but I don't
think this was the right uh right way to
go okay David this is messy okay messy
let's go here so I'm this Messiah so I
need to see it so nine to five whoa big
time yeah of course I'm a Jedi and then
after Knight F5 Knight takes C3 of
course so engine doesn't like obviously
okay Knight G7 sure King f8 Bishop
H6 whoa Knight D1 96 98. check double
check all right 1988 now what's the
piece count here what's going on you
tell me James Black's a piece up
temporarily yeah right it's just I'm
just trying to figure out this was
something here Rook takes and then Rook
D1 I guess if we do a count black has
three miners white has two but uh at
least this one keeps the black king
trapped in a cage for now so we're still
on a piece some competition uh some
conversation but maybe not enough but I
think exactly what James is doing is how
we as players think we're often trying
to figure out is that a viable variation
and we just went through the emotions
there we're often doing that in our
heads and we saw it doesn't actually
quite pan out so very instructive line
in some variations that may work out for
white here it does not so we expect
Magnus I mean he did just take uh the
Knight on C6 instead of playing funny
business over there on the king side and
well he will temporarily ruin Black's
Pawn structure but white king that's
really what this position boils down to
is White's King will never find true
safety yeah and I like Liam's decision
not to actually trade off more pieces
but instead he takes back with the pawn
yes history structure is shattered but
he gains time he gains a very important
Tempo against this white bishop and when
the bishop Retreats I'm not sure exactly
where black will start attacking soon
maybe the queen will come out at some
point maybe The Rook just slides across
to the semi-open file now and uh okay
instead we've seen another trade of
knights but white is the one with
weaknesses look at these pawns they're
easy Targets later on for Black's Bishop
I still don't like magnus's position but
uh at least the game continues now the
middle game is where this one will be
decided I'm gonna tell you right now
this is not in the chessable course not
in the testable course Magnus okay this
is gross yeah Castle King side yeah this
is not in the course but we're off the
head now he's just taking a decision to
put his King on the king side with that
pawn on G4 do not try this at home or
maybe only try this at home what is
going on here this looks absolutely
dreadful for white and it is a best of
two match this is magnus's only white
this is a nightmare yeah but Magnus is
gonna do as Magnus does and he look at
the eval bar right now it's only
slightly better for black so it's not
like he's crying he's not too worried
but it just looks odd I think the
Aesthetics of the position are clearly
in Black's favor white has these doubled
isolated pawns his pawns sticking out in
front of the king we keep talking about
it we would love to bring that pawn
backwards help our King find some better
shelter but that's not gonna happen but
how does black actually punish white
that's the big question I really don't
have an answer for I like the look of it
but how to punish Magnus is more
difficult and going forward long term
that might be the Dilemma he has too
many tempting moves slim does he go for
those White Queen side pawns those
doubled isolated pawns does he go
immediately for the white king which
pieces does he want to exchange so many
questions that Liam has to answer so
he's spending his time wisely this is
the beginning of the next phase of the
game the middle game has begun and I do
expect Liam to maybe invest two three
minutes and then come with a sensible
plan I think as soon as the black queen
comes out the Rooks connects he will be
for choice but he's just weighing up his
options yeah but this is a dream outcome
for Liam to start the elimination match
with the black piece cases and to get
this position look at that pawn
structure that Magnus has on the king
side a glaring weakness on G4 on the
queen side you've got the double pawns
Black's the one who's making all these
Pleasant choices between where to place
that Bishop when to strike in the center
perhaps Advance the E Pawn uh further up
the board on E5 to open up that Bishop
on D7 start targeting that G4 Pawn so
some very pleasant ideas here for Liam
in a very critical moment this is the
elimination match between the players
and Liam chooses another path he wants
to try to put the bishop on the long
diagonal from 8 to H1 I like it David
The Rook can move to see it and already
start targeting the queen on F3 yeah
let's show that move Tanya right now
this does look uh very logical this Rook
is doing nothing in the corner why not
slide it across big threat potentially
if the bishop does Reach This diagonal
it's going to be game over you could
imagine the black queen the black Bishop
lining up on this line and uh that will
end in a Checkmate attack but maybe
Magnus can slow this down slow down plan
you can for example bring his Rook
across he can put his Bishop on the long
diagonal first himself preempt Black's
uh attempt to put this bishop on C6 and
suddenly it's not so easy these pieces
are still a bit cramped Liam has wasted
a bit of time his Queen is not active
yet I don't really like what he's done I
think he should have gone straight just
a couple of moves ago straight for the
white king he should have for example
pushed this Pawn as you mentioned as
well Tanya or maybe even push this one
play it on the side you're stronger
black has a four versus three majority
on the king side white is the one with
weaknesses on this side of the Bud he's
playing on the opposite flank and
actually this has all happened on the
board and suddenly it's Magnus
look at this with threats against the
black queen big tactic Bishop takes H7
check if White had a free turn would net
a pawn because you take the pawn over
there go Queen D3 check at the end rook
and queen line up against that Bishop on
D7 you have to block the check and move
your king and then white ends up a pawn
ahead so actually I feel like Magnus has
the upper hand suddenly and this is what
Magnus does it just doesn't make sense
right we all were talking about it's a
terrible position you shouldn't try this
and then Magnus like who cares what you
say I'm Magnus Carlson right I'm the
only player above 2800 In classical
chess and I will get the upper hand if
it's a neutral territory yeah big threat
Robert how does he actually defend
against this if you suddenly move your
Pawn for example you could go the other
way with another threat this is a pin
after all on the D file and maybe you
win some material here so Liam with a
real dilemma a real question to answer
and it's kind of self-inflicted he
played a bit too slowly and suddenly
rook and queen facing off on the D file
big problems ahead it turns around that
quickly when you're facing a magician
like Magnus Carlson that is crazy yeah
he actually what is the move here in
fact you have to figure it because you
are on Queen E8 but that means still
runs in the bishop H7 Queen E3 I guess
he's just saying hey you have double
pawns and you have some weaknesses but I
mean okay I have an extra Pawn as white
here Bishop H7 maybe he's there yeah
what a tricky move Robert
trapped if you grab that point on H7
with a check oh my goodness so you've
got to show that David what a trick set
up that volume yeah what a trick I saw
Robert smiling here I don't think Magnus
is gonna fall into it he hasn't in this
position he has brought his Bishop out
we'll mention this in a minute but if he
had been greedy here after Queen eight
and grabbed this Pawn this is a check
yes this is a double attack yes but when
you finally take this bishop you get
skewered the black Rook just slides
across hitting the queen hitting the
Rook behind it and after Queen takes
Queen what we call is Visions or an
Intermezzo an in-between move Rook takes
Rook is a nasty check and when the white
king moves only then you take the queen
back and you're a rook up so of course
Magnus wasn't going to fall into this
but uh kudos to Liam for setting that
trap it might have caught mere mortals
like me uh there but uh instead Magnus
Dodges that brings his Bishop out to a
nice diagonal and uh still control for
white very tricky stuff Valium that
loved that a trap that you just showed
and just how dangerous and alert the
players need to be and Magnus now ahead
on the clock continues to ask these
questions because Bishop 87 is now a
threat with the Rook on D1 defended he
is planning to go in for this trick of
capturing on 8-7 while Magnus is asking
questions to Liam chat you can send us
your questions on Twitter using the
hashtag chess Champs send us your
selfies send us your questions and we'll
feature them on our show
yep and I really like how Magnus has
plugged the holes on the king side with
his pieces I mentioned that Liam should
have gone straight for the kill straight
for the white king now Maxis is Queen
his Bishops they're all lined perfectly
it's really hard to imagine black
breaking through on that side and if you
can't break through against the white
king what is your plan Black's queen
super passive and the board is on open
files right now and the white Rook on D1
perfectly plays that Rook that's in the
corner it's gonna slide one square over
take over an open file because magnus's
dark Square Bishop covers the enemy
Square on the eighth rank so I really
like the way Magnus is playing this I'm
surprised I'm even saying this at this
point I was like oh Magnus position is
terrible he's playing just kind of this
far-fetched joke of an opening and I'm
sitting here like yeah wow this is
looking promising for white look how
active the Bishops are
I don't know if I would play G4 in the
opening and end up with this double Pawn
I would be lost in 20 more and here's
Magnus playing one of the best players
in the world and suddenly we're talking
about him being better already how does
he do this
I mean it's just magic it's the Magnus
touch uh it's hard for anyone to explain
that that's why he's so good but you
don't have to relax you don't have to
relax my guy what is this in between
what is that what a move what is going
on she's giving up a pawn
guys what is this speechless here in the
studio what is the idea here he just
gave a pawn and instead of capturing
back Liam has just said okay I'm gonna
play on as if nothing happened and uh
this is the current position let's do a
rewind a refresh Liam through his Pawn
forward to F5 very logical move and here
I was expecting at least for the pawn to
be captured maybe the white Bishop would
have slid in with a check but this isn't
at the end of the world the black king
could hide in the corner the game goes
on instead Liam says okay have my Pawn I
don't care Bishop C6 wow he's just
removing a strong piece in the center of
the board and if the white actually
captures her on E6 does black have to
move Queen G6 or am I losing my head oh
Queen G6 Tanya with a check oh it
doesn't matter though maybe it doesn't
quite work because white has a nasty
check himself just to block to plug the
f file but uh I think you're right there
are tactics in this position to do with
the pin along this line maybe just G5
maybe just take a chill attack a bishop
why not white weakened his King earlier
so black is fine with weakening his King
too and due to this pen you do snatch a
bishop I don't think white can get away
with this instead we've seen a trait of
the light squared Bishops on C6 and same
tactic in the air white has to be
careful of moving his Pawn off the F
line what a tactic what a trick there
from them gotta say James I'm not gonna
lie hey look when you if you get hit him
with a move like that you're like okay
look I'm hey man can we talk about this
like let's uh let's uh let's step back
and let's talk about this politely like
that was very strong Bishop C6 would
definitely frighten you a little bit and
let you know that hey he came to play
just like you did Magnus so that was a
very strong move the pin is still there
right there's problems now down the F
line and your king is super weak after
that g G4 and stuff like that question
go Bishop G3 maybe you have to do
something they said Rook B1 wow Rook B1
we work B8 is that what you're doing
right yeah I like the way both players
are kind of ignoring the tension there
right nem struck with F5 it was captured
he didn't capture back and now we're
seeing both players say there's going to
be a staring on pawns can you take me
can I take you the answer is up in the
air but what we see Magnus doing he's
controlling the open files both of his
Rooks are supremely placed on perfect
lines and that could cause problems for
the black king so watch out if your
Magnus your king is open but lands King
it might not be the safest either yeah
what a nice move I'm I'm carried away as
well by looking at the white Pawn
structure there's two sets of double
pawns two isolated pawns on the flank
that's why Magnus has to play
dynamically that's why his last move
getting a rook into the game potentially
zooming all the way up to the eighth
Rank and uh yeah often when you're kind
of struggling strategically positionally
with ugly pawns with bad pieces you have
to justify it with tactics with tricks
and suddenly I'm looking into the
position there must be something here
for white black has kind of abandoned
the eighth rank but there are so many
pins in the position so many tricks we
have to show something here uh Tanya I
see you're peering ahead you're really
interested in some tactics here for
white the first thing that comes to mind
is what happens if white steps up with
The Rook to be it but the good news for
black is that the bishop on F4 is spin
so you don't have to really care about
it you can go on to pick up that Rook on
be it so that's not a threat anymore but
you're absolutely right David that each
rank looks really extremely weak right
now Liam playing with fire but is there
an immediate blow here the evaluation
bar the computer thinks no I'm also
tempted to just bring it up to the
seventh rank they call this seventh
heaven when rook's on the seventh they
have all the targets they're just going
to grab all the material this looks very
tempting maybe setting up some tricks uh
along that rank what else could white
consider maybe just a sensible move
getting the queen out of Dodge getting
it out of the pin but uh either way
tactics are starting to make the uh
appearance in this position and Magnus
is the first to think what comes to mind
here James Robert definitely 57
definitely I love the rugby seven more
that's a 2700 move by David there Rook
B7 absolutely after Rook takes I mean
you're just certainly Rook E7 and you're
threatening to bring the other Rook down
there and then you know seventh heaven
they call the pigs on the seventh when
you have two Rooks down there so that's
gonna be pretty nasty I mean it's
definitely there and Rook takes E7 is
there too as well so I definitely like
that Rook B7 move it's like the best
defense is offense right so everybody
play Queen four check now and uh guys I
guess we
Bishop G3 Bishop G3 played on the board
and uh James you said Rook B7 was a 2700
move unfortunately Magnus is 28 2900 so
uh yeah
Queen yeah yeah you're right you're
right
what's wrong Liam what's wrong with him
today he plays a very good chess this
might be the game with like the worst
Pawn structure we'll see right
everyone's pawns are terrible nobody
wants to have a clean uncompromised Pawn
structure so if we see a queen trade
then black will have double isolated
Pawn so every single Pawn on the board
is about to be isolated yeah and I think
we will see Queen takes Queen what else
could Magnus consider here the tension
there it's just too much to bear you
don't really want to have to step back
with your queen yes you can throw in a
check for example whites Rook can still
go up to B8 hitting that black king but
I think that can simply either be
blocked or maybe the black king can poke
his head out start marching forward so
the Queens are coming off the board
we're heading into the end game and who
spawns are weaker that's the big
question it's level material but uh I
would slightly choose black I think I
would choose uh Liam's side just because
I feel that his pawns look fine for now
but white pawns are easily targeted
especially I'm looking at the A3 on the
side there Black's Bishop already
hitting it Liam meanwhile he's paused
because he's thinking about trading off
one set of Rooks before he takes back
White's Queen
oh yeah that's correct Rook takes if he
keeps uh you have hg6 I do like white
but then Rook if Rook D1 which is
definitely oh wow yeah now I like I
actually like white here a little bit
just because of exactly the initiative
I'm doing it first you had to capture
back which is why Rook D1 was probably a
little bit better because even A3 is
hanging in that line there yeah
different I agree and if black actually
takes only three white also has the
option of planting his own Bishop on E5
you could do it after capturing on A7 or
even before hitting that pawn on G7
so Magnus has got his own trumps in this
position yeah I think that white is
gonna have the more active pieces even
though Black's Poncho looks better it's
more difficult for black to get to
White's pawns because those C pawns you
have to bring your Rook all the way
around into the position and I feel like
the king Side Pawn structure is a
long-term weakness for black to deal
with white will take A7 where we'll
swing that Rook over to D7 next and put
pressure in the D5 pawn and I just feel
like white would be better in this
variation which is why Liam he's been
playing great chess throughout this game
and look what he has done he says don't
want that pawn don't want that flank
Pawn let me go for more Central Pawn and
I'm stopping White's active plan of
putting the bishop in the center this is
great decision making by the Vietnamese
Superstar yep always prioritize peace
activity in these end games even at the
cost of porn sometimes so now after Rook
takes A7 creating a passport for white
Leanne has grabbed this Pawn hoping to
much forward but Magnus is saying yes
I'm gonna run across and now be careful
if you push your opponent the white
Bishop will find its active post hitting
this point hitting this pawn and Magnus
will have have the advantage so still up
in the air this one yet to be decided
but both players playing really really
well so far I've got to say both very
creative especially in that middle game
full of tactics and they found a way to
kind of neutralize each other's
activity and uh Liam I think making a
good choice defending the pawn with his
rook and he's again ready to swing that
Rook over to the a file to go after
white isolated porn over there
also a sneaky idea of actually pushing
D4 next because that Rook from C5 it's
not only heading to attack that a pawn
but controls the E5 Square as well so a
Magnus there stopping the first threat
that you mentioned is it time for black
to push the Deep on or is Magnus being
very sneaky with threatening Bishop to
B6 as well yeah I think both sides are
trying to be sneaky here Tanya and Liam
has lots of options I wouldn't be
surprised if he just drops back the
black Bishop to a nice safe Square first
just anchor it safely on F6 keep
everything protected and then decide
what to do but like you say maybe you
push the pawn forward so many options
and activate the black rope it's one of
these positions though we've seen Magnus
win countless times because it's equal
it's an end gave it should be a draw
that's what everyone says and then
you're like Magnus Carlson doesn't just
agree to draw us he plays it out until
there are no pieces remaining and if
black is not careful you could fall
victim to this a pawn running up the
board but black has threats of his own
he's trying to bring his Rook back he
could bring it forward but he also bring
it back pin the bishop on the seventh
rank so both sides are playing excellent
chess right now and I would say both
sides have chances it's not just a dead
draw and the pawns are not in the same
flanks it's not symmetrical anyway both
players will have their shot
yeah both players will have their shot I
like this last move by Lim I've got to
say that black Rook Ed like it was doing
a decent job but it could be improved
this is where you always have to ask
which piece uh is happiest which pieces
need to kind of be repositioned and uh
he's talking to his pieces he's asking
them and he still has three minutes that
should be enough to keep the balance in
this game time scramble will happen but
this isn't the most uh kind of terminal
type of position if you are low on time
so uh yeah keeping things within
manageable Realms here indeed a very
high level game uh starting from the
opening the way Liam handled G4 and a
position that looked super dangerous for
Magnus suddenly felt like he was getting
into a good end game but now looks very
level with both sides having their own
Trump rugby seven the bishop spin but
the good news for white is that you can
step out of this pin by giving a check
it's still a hot end game even though
such few pieces David should we get a
quick peek onto the federacy of 11 game
and then jump straight back to this one
I think we do need to take a peek over
there there have been some developments
Queens are off in that one 2 it is an
end game in this clash between fedisev
and aronian also a bit of a strange Pawn
structure you would think it looks
symmetrical but both sides have
weaknesses both sides have potential
access to outposts and feather save he
is not one to sit back and relax he
never takes a chill he's going straight
forward and he's willing to accept an
isolated Pawn in order to get his Knight
active the White Knight is getting
active the white Rook on the third rank
watch out for it swinging across later
and we talked about seventh heaven James
that white Rook might be the most
important piece uh piece here on D7 I
mean absolutely I think uh I think for
the save actually has in the last few
weeks or even months here have uh some
very good Big Boost of confidence and
I'm saying that just because of me his
record Hikaru just speaks for herself
right now in the last five or six games
where he was able to take down Hikaru in
title Tuesday is one of the biggest
events right where the strongest players
play he was able to do to do that he
even had a monster performance in the
Pro chess league and in a protest League
Arena Battle Royale whatever it is so um
he played very he's playing very good
chess now these days so of course it's
very aggressive and aronia is going to
have to find something you know here but
it is LeBron errone and he's been around
a long time he does this he's creative
he's tactical too but definitely I mean
this one's up in the air for anyone I
like white though because of the Rook on
the seventh rank we do take on that four
play Rook F3 and uh and get our pieces
active tonight is pretty gross though on
E2 that is a disgusting Night on YouTube
right now for now yeah exactly it's
trying to become a good night with
White's last move but the Knight would
like to hop forward but I think the
nature of this position is one where
these high-level Grandmasters they would
take this position with the white side
even though the Evo bar is not so high
over one where the evaluation bar is
through the roof but it's complicated
this is one-sided you're playing for two
results either if Lavon plays the best
possible chess and makes a draw you're
like credit to him he played a great
defensive effort but it's very likely
that white wins this game because black
is shuffling back and forth you cannot
kick that Rook out of the seventh rank
that Rook is patrolling uh both
directions and that Brook on B3 it is
going to get active either to the D file
as well joining the party or the F3 as
David pointed out and going after the F7
Pawn I hate Black's position here yeah
and you can see in the body language
Levon is not comfortable at all it's not
his type of position just to show the
main line if you do take this Pawn for
example white will recapture James
called it a gross piece this night now
is maybe the MVP it's gonna just step
into the center to a beautiful square
and it's going to win the game for white
so Levon he's uh really caught between a
rock and a hard place here just what to
play I have no idea I would want to
maybe move this Rook into the game but
how and where and if you do Shuffle
across for example white will just move
across himself and uh whoops I think
it's going to be a Calamity on the F7
Square he brings his Knight into the
game and uh maybe hoping to jump in a
decent choice but what is the answer
after Pawn takes porn still huge threats
in the air going after F7 I don't like
it for Levon but the evaluation Bar says
he's doing okay maybe this was a good uh
resourceful move maybe he just needs to
trade off this beast on D7 for example
dropping his Rook back or bringing his
Rook across just get rid of this piece
and maybe you live to fight another day
I think it's a good choice and
oftentimes Grandmasters they will give
up material to make sure they get
activity for themselves and that's what
Lavon is doing a great illustration of
that giving up upon the center but white
extra pawn it won't be healthy it'll be
doubled and I said not able to be
protected by another Pawn great decision
by Lavon because he's giving up two
different pawns there's the pawn the
center and then there's a Pawn on A7 and
then white would get a pass Pawn of his
own so Levon I mean what a fighter he is
I agree with the featured chat there I
mean he is just playing some great
defense against a dedicated determined
Vladimir fellow save yeah dedicated and
determined and he's tanking here a bit
he spent one minute but he needs a
breakthrough at some point you just got
to make a decision just take one of the
pawns and if Levon proves that he finds
a solution fine it'll be a draw you move
on to the next game but uh okay I'm
getting worried for feder safe around
two minutes now he just needs to make
that decision just grab a pawn I don't
know which one but grab one all right
let's grab one yeah let's grab one yeah
maybe take on I mean you probably take
the E Pawn that just seems better it's a
center Pawn you still have A7 on tap and
Rick F3 there it is yeah Rook F3 is
there Rook d8 okay activity yeah why
it's got to be a little careful if you
grab the A7 Pawn black will actually
enter with his own Rook to the second
rank with Rook D2 and then there are so
many tactics that can happen uh David if
we can just bring that up and you know I
want to get my knight on D4 if you try
to defend your knight with the King I'm
gonna give up my Rook not even gonna
blink twice Rick takes Knight and nice
Fork there Tanya it's a double attack
you win some material as black so you
really need to avoid this type of trick
for feather save and wow I was gonna say
it would be more in his stuff to just
drop the Rook back and uh just leave it
there forever leave The Rook on this
square if it's ever captured even by a
knight uh you will establish a really
strong Pawn Center but okay he's doubled
up his Rooks we have seen a trade of
Rooks in the center you still have a
strong piece here sorry but uh live on a
ronin okay look at this he's
repositioned his army and he's going for
this weak Pawn this straggler in his
Camp that's indefensible and suddenly
this Black Knight is like a rock in the
center on E6 it's holding everything
together I think No One's Gonna Hold
this one it's one of these uh positions
where the evaluation bar does not tell
the whole story this is actually
unbelievable defense because I wasn't
even looking at this Rook A6 move
defending and attacking simultaneously
and levana Roni is one of the best Bug
House players in the world and the key
to bug house also known as doubles chess
is that you need to make moves the
simultaneously attack and defend and
this is one of those Lavon deserves a
lot of credit the Eva bar has stayed in
the middle and now it's like going down
in his favor because he is playing this
so excellently yeah and Magnus Carlsen
and Liam Leia also deserve a lot of
credit for their play in game one very
high class chess precise play there and
the game fairly ended in a draw in the
end game where we left it but this one
is it is all three results are possible
G3 played Black does have the option to
just pick up the pawn David yeah you
could pick up a pawn uh there's actually
no rush you could potentially try and
stop white snipe from jumping forward
this last Pawn push for uh Vladimir
ferisev is designed to bring his Knight
to the F4 Square to try and trade those
two knights off if the knights disappear
White's chances May improve Black's
night I think is far superior right now
so we'll live on try and take a time out
to try and prevent that I'm not sure how
you do it without weakening squares
yourself but uh he does have two extra
minutes on the clock that could be vital
and as Robert pointed out momentum is
slightly on black side it looked like
black was really struggling suddenly
there's no problems at all and you could
start hoping for more yourself
um I think I would just take that pawn
and start calculating later but uh Levon
is more creative what do we think I do
like that G5 move because their Knight
is gross like that Knight on E2 has no
moves my guy like what are you doing
with your life right so this Knight is
so bad so when you go G5 he might even
be tempted to go G4 and try to get the
Knight to G3 and then F5 but in that
case I mean when you move the Knight to
G3 then mine goes to F4 right so it's
very I mean this Knight is so bad and
you're just trying to fight for your
life to get the Knight active right so I
mean G5 definitely seems like a move um
that I would play just to stop and stop
prevent the knight from jumping into F4
that's what he wants he played G3 to put
the Knight on F4 you play G5 to stop it
then we take the pawn we go Rook A2 and
what do you do right you might be in
some trouble especially after we after
we push the a pawn the B Pawn is
connected to his well and we can take
the the pawn on B2 it's problems I
definitely I definitely see uh ronian
turning this one out and the time look
at the time I mean he's up time here
well it's getting closer now but
definitely up a little bit of time here
too yeah I think it's the Instinct right
most players they see G3 they want to
play G5 but that's how strong Levon is
he doesn't just play on impulse he has
enough time to calculate but James the
clock is getting even and that's a
problem because Federal save is a bullet
Maestro that's correct if you yeah if
you compare the skills here classical
chess maybe live on aronian rapid chess
it's unclear it's much closer but I had
to save definitely has the edge if it
gets down to a race and James you called
it you predict the future all of these
uh things have come to pass and suddenly
a check the idea is to drive whites King
forward onto the second rank so when you
go after this white B Pawn you take it
with a check a nice Tempo gaining
maneuver there by 11 irony this is what
he was calculating he spent a minute or
two but then the next four or five moves
came very very quickly the downside is
this white on uh White Knight NF Thrive
it's a f drive it will Thrive but it is
a beast and uh some meeting ideas
against the black king potentially and
are we going to see a repetition with 97
Knight F5 or do you think white is going
to go for the mid wow I mean to get
checkmate you need your work on the last
rank but it's very difficult the Black
Knight has been so strong ani6 since it
got there so I feel like white might not
have all the time in the world the time
you need to deliver that Checkmate so if
you see a draw perhaps it's time to make
the draw oh 10 seconds as well he's gone
for one check go King A7 you ain't got
no time yeah no checks now and the
Knight does drop back felicev is hoping
begging for the draw but Levon Orion
doesn't need to acquiesce to that one
yet he grabs a point with a check now
the big dilemma for black do you allow
white throat to go and take that F7 Pawn
if your king moves back you will get
checked is there a way to play for a win
Maybe not maybe you just have to admit
it's better to say I've found a good
defense
but Lavon with that King Retreat to
eight seven has made his intentions very
clear that he wants better safe to work
hard for that draw yeah no I mean
Federal saves the one on defense both
sides are showing good defense when
they've been on the back foot they're
saying some people crumble especially in
time travel but right now I think levana
Ronin he's the black pieces he should
just make the draw why take risk his
position isn't anywhere close to being
clear so make the draw now get the white
pieces in game two that way you have the
better chances yeah he's around 20
seconds himself yeah practical decision
wise decision take the draw get out of
here move to the next game but is he
gonna take a risk it's in his character
in his style he gotta move yeah and dude
when you say take a draw you mean just
come up with the King defend that F7
pawn and allow the repetition with the
checks with the Knight yeah exactly
bring the black king back keep
everything defended but no he goes for
the win there we go to drop in with
check though look at all the pawns that
the white Rook is gobbling up but black
here level running is banking everything
on that b point it's two squares away
from promotion
right just push it push it it's winning
push him baby and then there's a check
on each one and you're Queen yeah push
away King D1 how do you stop oh here
comes yeah because the king can't get
the C2 where it needs to if you trade
that Pawn's coming in oh my God Robert
yeah oh wow this is it he's got a yeah
he's got to take that Knight there were
checkmating ideas on the board white
spawns are running forward but Black's
pawns are going to be quicker this Pawn
is going to be dealt with by the black
king and I think black's winning this
race it's definitely a race right now
but black seems ahead Black's gonna make
a new Queen first it will cost white his
Rook levon's winning that's amazing
because white is actually up a pawn
suddenly waiters five black is four but
it's about the quality not the quantity
and I think Federal Sav he might just
tip his King over in a couple moves
looks so natural what was the move five
seconds you have a check first but we'll
check that later right now he picks up
the spot with the B2 Pawn Falls oh man
oh my God suddenly everything's
disappearing this game will likely end
in a draw actually it's Levon who has to
defend this he's going down three for
two now shaking his head could things
turn could win we will go back and uh
check out what should have happened
there Levon was winning but he went for
the most natural move and it backfired
oh yeah you're right Tanya's right let's
check first yeah check first king C2 D3
takes D2 yeah if King takes you Queen
Cheese that's it bro that's sick right
idea I think Levon but just the wrong
order and uh wow what a turnaround chess
is hard since James Kenny he's
absolutely right but I think for Lavon
you know he's able to stabilize here
because he is down one Pawn but
thankfully for him his King is nicely
centralized the white pawns are a bit
Loose as well so he should be able to
hold you should and uh just while this
game is going to take a slower Pace I
don't think Levon aronia ran out of time
the clocks were slightly wrong there for
a second he's very active with his King
now he'll give a check he'll pull him
back and this one will be a draw but I
think we have to show that critical
moment uh okay we might not it looks
like we might get a draw any second now
it's a Perpetual check and uh there's no
way for White's King to hide no shelter
and finally after all those twists and
turns after that roller coaster it is a
draw
wow what a game and love on our onion
really did create his chances gambling
in very little time but just saying I
want to fight for a win and David the
critical moment was really that pawn
push where he missed we saw the eval bar
say and it was a decision a toss-up
between giving a check or pushing the D3
Pawn there yeah and he just chose wrong
that coin toss and he flipped wrong it
was in this position he pushed his Pawn
but as we saw White's Pawn was able to
step ahead and white was able to catch
up in the race instead a check would
have won the game for level neroni and
forcing the white king forward to
prevent this Pawn from promoting but now
another check deflecting the white king
no matter which Pawn you take the other
one will run through and black would
have won this game wow that is the
difference between a win and a draw and
David just to point out a very I want to
point out one more crucial line David if
we can just bring up because it was so
important that moment that instead after
what was played the key point was if we
can just back up to this uh to this
moment after D3 white can go C6 here
because you give a check oh sorry you
give a check the King goes up you Queen
and you don't have a way to fight
against C7 you pick up the Rook but then
this would end in a draw with checks or
White's the one that might win and with
that what a big Miss but this is what
Blitz this is what fast play is about
with this we end our round one off the
elimination bracket and this is our
score line Magnus Carlson Liam Lee had a
peaceful drop with chances to both sides
coming out in the opening in the middle
game fattest you have aronian what a
game Levon really creating his chances
could have wanted a slip in the move
order and this ended in a tie as well
well we've got game two action coming up
but before that for our non-subscribers
you've got a twitch break and for those
of you who have subscribed there's a
very special segment on a special player
foreign
[Music]
what would you say was the biggest
adjustment that you had to make from
going full professional to combining
your academics as well as your
professional chess career of course it's
very hard to combine chess and and
academics but during the years that I
was here managed to do my best at school
and also got a chance to work with many
great players so that's helped me to
improve my chance as well I think it
always comes down to your time
management and your dedication to chess
and academics if you really want to do
well with both you can do it how do you
combine such a hectic life yeah you have
the coaching job but you also are very
much a trust professional I was offered
a job to take over and I couldn't say no
because
first of all I'm an alumni of the
program and I know the program really
well I feel like it's my responsibility
to keep the program I'm going and also I
wanted to to work with the students here
they are very talented and I believe
that I can help them get to the next
level last year we actually started the
chest in the chess in education minor
degree and that's the first time I
believe a university in America had a
chest with green for students that's a
perfect fit for what's the University
because we are a global University and
chess has been a big part of Webster
is not only about chest but also about
the team culture about the team spirit
The Chemistry Between the players and so
on the friendships also a lot of things
that we have to consider but when you
look at the big bigger picture I think
as a coach you understand that more than
as a player and I think it's very
important to grow as a coach to
understand this sometimes almost like a
broader pattern too right you have to
guide them to help them do well in
school and academic in life in general
so they would feel better they would be
ready for purchase so I see myself as
mainly a coach nowadays I still play
chess professionally sometimes but not
as much as I used to whenever I apply I
try to prepare the best I can and also
because I work with my students on a
regular basis I also have some new ideas
that I can use in my own games I think
it's not too difficult to combine
between being a just and a chess player
if you get the if you get good students
and you are motivated and you keep
looking on it my favorite part of the
tour is that it's growing so much and
now it's more open to everyone I don't
really set a goal like
finishing 10 Place overall top three or
something because I think it's
impossible to do that in Alessia but
there's a Canada but for other players
like myself I just enjoy every
tournaments that I apply and hopefully
I'll do well
this is it the moment has come for the
players to give it at all only one more
game remains in the elimination bracket
we saw both matches end in draw but big
fights in both these games with just two
games it is the best of two match if
tight we will have an Armageddon Magnus
Carlsen Liam both players played
fantastic chess Robert in game one and
it is Liam who starts with the white
pieces now yeah expect a more solid
opening from Liam he's not going to be
pushing his g-pawn two squares not in
the opening stage at least and I feel
like for Magnus he should be happy that
he wasn't any trouble in game one
because that could have gone a different
way absolutely with that pawn on G4 but
now we're not gonna have any of that
Robert you called out a solid opening
David we've got a Queen spawn yeah and
the Catalan opening one of magnus's
favorites and now Liam is using it
against him Liam has had a lot of
success with this opening in the
play-ins for this tournament he actually
did phenomenally well because he scored
some great upsets some great wins in the
cat Clan and Magnus of course will have
studied this for World Championship
matches in his training camps there and
he's happy to transpose into the tarash
and uh he will most likely accept an
isolated Pawn here Magnus uh clearly
maybe learning from some of his seconds
like Nils Cornelius I think he's done a
chessboard course on this one and uh
yeah solid start as you said Robert much
more solid than the last game at least
James Chasm of course news grindelius
yeah Neil has one actually there's just
a Catalan course that just dropped there
is many courses that actually cover on
what to do against the Catalan actually
but this one actually is a rare one that
he's playing there's not many tarash
courses on adjustable there's only one
it's called the dewbots harass but they
don't really cover this part he's
keeping those Secrets because dubov was
a second from Magnus Carlson he'll show
you you know help Magnus get it done but
not how to stop Magnus yeah how to stop
Magnus that should be a course in itself
and uh meanwhile Magnus has taken the
opportunity after white just pushed his
Pawn to B3 better late than ever to
plant that black knight in the center
and now there's a bit of tension there
is a pin on that white Central Pawn uh
that black dark Square Bishop I like
where it's placed a lot of tension here
Liam I'm not sure whether he's planned
this position whether he's prepared this
but he's slowed down at least slightly
and uh yeah solid start it's hard to
imagine too much going wrong for either
side right right now right well but this
one heats up we're going to do a little
panel wood here guys are we expecting an
Armageddon in Magnus versus Liam David
yeah
oh so you think it's going to be a draw
what about you James nope I want some
action and I know Magnus does too as
well oh are you hinting who
are you yeah I think we're going
Armageddon Lim
BS going to do anything risky and
beating Liam with the black Pieces good
luck to you yeah
yeah I love an Armageddon so I'm hoping
for one for sure tell us what do you
think how that one's going to go
meanwhile action is also on and our
second matchup Levon aronians so close
to taking that first game now has to do
it all over again but he does have the
white pieces Queens have been traded
David yeah early days it's the caracon
it's crazy man this is the weird Carroll
Khan you actually can't play for winning
Chances with this this is actually more
of like a reverse filler door in a way
especially when you put the pawn on C3
you go King C2 you play F3 this is
boring what is this Robert why are we
playing this man David I do love my
endgame grind so I'm gonna say it's all
about the intricacies it's all about the
nuances I love the uh sophistication
behind both sides play but yeah maybe
for the fans Not So Exciting uh this one
will get a bit uh spicier I'm hoping
later on so uh maybe we'll focus on the
Magnus game first of all but yeah this
one's an end game in Levon it's not
maybe his style to go into something
like this normally we see a more Dynamic
approach especially with the white
pieces but maybe he's playing the
opponent here it's not fair to save
style either I was going to say that
this is more Lavon style than it is
federal sales it's not really either of
theirs but it's less so Federal saves he
loves attacking chess he always has
interesting battles uh but here we see
the position without Queens on the board
no easy target it's but white does have
a little bit better control and some odd
piece placement that move Knight D7 you
expected the Knight that was undeveloped
to go forward but said it goes back but
when he wants to is clear the long
diagonal he sees that white wants to Fan
Kettle that Bishop he says well you're
not going to pin me you're not going to
attack my knight over there so I don't
know how to judge this position balance
sounds like a cop-out I think both sides
will have their chances because they're
playing for different things yeah and
that we see Levon aronia's chessable
Court uh course mentioned on the beauty
of Chess I'm not sure he would have
featured this position in the beat of
Chess course not in there but either way
he will be trying to create something a
bit later on I think I would choose
white just because if you look in the
center White's Pawn formation there is
really really nice black yet to really
stake his claim for those Central
squares so uh yeah right now it feels
like fair to say have maybe an open
opening preparation he's still got
almost 15 minutes left but not too
exciting what do we think should we
stick with this one we'll move back to
Magnus against uh uh against Liam let's
have another vote yeah we definitely can
go back to the Magnus game yeah that's
not even a question
let's do it this one will take a while
to heat up we will keep our eyes out on
this Magnus versus Liam a queen's fun
opening by Liam and wow at least the
Queens are on so James you can breathe
here and I see quite a lot of questions
for that D4 pawns to be answered here
Robert yeah and I'm also Lam has spent
quite a lot of time so in the first game
Magnus was doing The Lunchbox variation
where he was just eating his food
spending a minute here or there now it
seems like Lem just is a bit
uncomfortable because there is a ton of
pressure at White's Center D4 was
White's first move now that pawn is
threatened by three different black
pieces and you can't even take the pawn
on C5 it's attacking you because there's
a pin behind it the dark Square Bishop
for black is in a perfect situation it
is hitting the Knight on C3 what
just showing what would happen if white
blunders and takes this Pawn there is a
pin on the long diagonal so Liam needs
to do something about it and whoa he's
taken the knights off the board this
surprised me I thought he needed to just
defend his Central Pawn but he drops
back now and this is fine yes you'll
lose your Central Pawn on D4 but you now
gain Black's Pawn on the E4 Square I'm
not sure if there any tricks any tactics
here uh for example if black does take
in the center then things will just get
hoovered off the board and this position
looks pretty balanced actually I would
maybe choose white unless there's
something immediate here for black just
because of the Catalan Bishop the bishop
so strong on this long diagonal but of
course Magnus Super Active and he will
work things out it would also be a
Magnuson style I should mention to take
this Pawn just to imbalance things uh
yes it gives you an isolated Pawn in the
center of the board but black will have
more space Magnus loves his space and
for example A variation like this one
moving the black Bishop I'm not sure
where which direction but uh for example
here Magnus having worked with players
like dubov loves this type of Pawn
structure loves the space involved and
it does give winning chances for both
sides but uh he will if he wants to win
this game he will go for this option so
looking balanced so far but uh yeah
James at least the Queens are on this
one you know we can breathe guys we can
you know chat out there at home you're
not going to sleep on this one okay this
is gonna be some action steel right of
course we do have I was even thinking of
e32 as well but there may be some
problems there around the long diagonal
really the problem in the Catalan is
that Catalan Bishop if it gets
aggressive and it's just it's open then
of course you have problems around uh on
the long diagonal you have to play stuff
like work to B8 and like how do you even
develop that side of the board and a lot
of times if that Catalan Bishop gets
loose it's going to be a problem for
black on that side with board especially
even with Rook to C1 and Etc so I mean
Magnus is taking a thing here as he
should right to figure out how he should
deal with this maybe not even take it
too I mean the bishop on B2 is pin maybe
we have an in-between move but it's
something to think about such a classic
slight nag with that Bishop on G2 for
Liam the Catalan Bishop it's a good
thing that Magnus went up to the
mountains uh David to get some fresh air
because I also see that he's got good
air quality where he's playing from a
big shout out to our partners as thanks
for providing us that because at least
we know that Magnus is playing in Fresh
Air with good air we saw his game in we
saw his game one some good moves there
so definitely a good environment yeah
feel good play good that tends to be the
motto and if your air quality is good
that's just a bone we do see as well
what the air is like over there in St
Louis in the US uh for Liam and the
temperature may be a bit warmer uh
hopefully it won't affect his uh
cognitive abilities too much but in
general good air quality as well there
too I know Liam is a perfectionist both
on the chessboard and off anything he
can do to be fully prepared he'll uh
take those steps take those measures and
actually what we predicted on the board
rather than capture that Central Pawn
first though uh Liam is kicking back the
Black Knight I like this one maybe there
were some tricks with the black light
Square Bishop coming out to attack uh if
white hadn't taken this first step this
precautionary measure and uh Magnus he
needs to retreat or does he he doesn't
he jumps in trading even more pieces off
yeah this is more of a it's just like
initiative right if you can if I can
make you do it and then I get an extra
move this is why native three was so
nice if I go 96 then that gives you a
chance to do something if I go nice C6
Knight anything you get an extra move
but Knight F3 you're forced to take it
back then you're going to take the pawn
and then I get an extra move right which
is pretty nice so I do like this
decision for Magnus here but again I
mean it's the Catalan bishop and that is
so annoying in the Catalan is the bishop
I mean it's just so and it actually have
it on the board here and Rook to B8
after it and I mean I like white in
these positions because it's the bishop
maybe he goes B6 now so it's just kind
of I guess we will get a draw here I
guess we have a draw here yeah you're a
very solid play and that's the nature of
uh Liam Lake he does not want to take
undue risk he's not going to play like
Magnus did in game one and for Magnus he
found a way out this bishop on F3 now is
your fin Kettle Bishop the Catalan
Bishop it can be really frustrating for
black to deal with and I'm not actually
calling this game a draw just yet it's
not a symmetrical Pawn structure black
actually has an extra Pawn if you look
towards the queen side the left hand
side of the board white has that extra
Pawn the center so you're playing for
different ideas in end games past pawns
start to appear you get a little bit
scared but it is balance so we want to
be clear about that but I just think
that if this game goes on Magnus
sometimes he makes miracles happen here
but Liam I mean he's not going to go
down I do think we're gonna see him
again yeah actually she's going to be my
next question Robert you know you
mentioned this bishop
coupon structure if it is Liam really
going to try to push this one or will he
be happy to take it to the Armageddon
where it's really just anyone's game
yeah there's nothing to push yeah just
being honest I don't think there's
anything that white is going to be
pushing I think that this one is very
very balanced I think we'll see some
trades the light Square Bishops will
come off and then the players are like
okay we're in an even end game yeah we'd
love to see it come down to the
Armageddon well while this one goes
ahead let's take a look on the other
matchup because that is heating up with
Levon aronia and taking on set a sieve
and wow you the Queens have been traded
off but this looks like a queenless
middle game all minor pieces on the
board just one set of Pawns off and look
at that King on E2 it feels like a
Fisher random position right now yeah
you're right Tanya it looks as if the
pieces have just been randomly thrown
onto the board and uh black has spent so
much time look at that Black Knight on
G4 intruding in the white camp but it's
gonna get kicked back it's already moved
three or four times in the game Black's
dark Squad Bishop has moved a couple of
times but what has black been doing he's
wasted so much time he hasn't staked a
claim with his Pawns in the center and
here Levon once he starts the kick back
once he starts pushing Black's pieces
back even further I think he's gonna
have a great position I think he might
even have a nice Advantage just because
white has all the space in the center
and Black's pieces will lack squares
like outposts and uh yeah it does feel
like this is not the type of position
that suits fed a safe style he wants
more activity he wants threats on the
board he wants tricks but without Queens
it's not easy to achieve that and look
at our players on the camera
foreigns on the head and this is such a
classic chest pose David which one is
yours uh it was more levons a moment ago
before the head scratched it was more
like heading hands just hiding from the
world hating my position hating my life
yeah we see the players I'll often adopt
this pose when they're calculating when
they're trying to work out difficult
questions and uh meanwhile if I had to
say I've maybe slightly more chilled out
of the two that's a good move that's
actually a very annoying move
where is he he's going Knight F2 or
Knight E3 jumping in Knight f29
0 The Rook on H1 doesn't have so many
squares is that something that white has
to worry about right now yeah yeah quite
possibly for example if you do nothing
what would be a nothing move here let's
move my Bishop back to a rubbish Square
the Knight would jump in now hitting the
rook and as Tanya mentions if you move
your Rook out the way Knight takes pawn
and it's a discovered attack hitting
this Rook so you will win material no
matter what so that is the threat I'm
thinking that one of the white Knights
has to jump forward to this Square I'm
not sure which one uh to hit this bishop
to try and gain some time uh against
this piece but no Levon solves it more
creatively he brings his Bishop to the
side of the board this is asking for the
Knight to jump in but now after Bishop
takes Bishop there's no time to take
this Rook well at least I don't think so
because now after you take this note
with check the Knight jumps forward and
this piece is trapped in the corner
white will end up with two pieces for a
rook and material advantage if this
happens so uh holding things together
with tricks level Iranian although the
problem with putting your Bishop out on
H3 is that your Pawn really wanted to be
there because the Knight on G4 is
defended by black Bishop on E6 so you're
actually not creating a threat and black
could also consider putting the H Pawn
forward protect the ignite and mainly H4
next just trying to Barrel through on
that flank so I feel like this is a kind
of strange decision from Lavon his
pieces are not harmonious neither are
blacks but I think I neither side really
has a good footing in this position
you're kind of just trying to figure out
what to do move by move yeah it feels
superficial for both sides you're right
it feels as if all the pieces are just
floating in the air this bishop
unprotected undefended it's going to be
kicked back anytime soon uh maybe white
could kind of prepare a pawn push later
on this bishop looks nice and pretty but
it could be a Target later on it's uh
yeah definitely all to play for in this
position I would choose white I've got
to say but I agree White's last move
maybe not the most consistent with his
previous play
and uh yep for the staff now in the tank
two minutes down trying to find a
solution for black yeah I feel like Wade
just has the the moves like Knight F3 I
mean you have F5 sometimes brick F1 like
Knight D3 just got there's tricks here I
mean you can't even move the king really
because Bishop E7 so I feel like he's
gonna have to spend a lot of time here
really trying to figure out this
position which is going to be Advantage
for aronian there uh having you know a
little bit extra time having some
creativity he's creative himself and
having piece play and activity and and
tricks I mean I feel like white
definitely is for Choice yeah and one
thing I will say I've played feather
save a few times quite a few times
actually over the board and my strategy
has always been to make it as boring as
possible and it's tended to work quite
well uh once the Queens come off yeah
you're pretty the sigh of relief because
uh he's so good in these Dynamic
positions where there's just chaos going
on and he sees things so fast that's why
he's so good at Blitz at bullet but uh
here without the Queens it feels like
he's playing for those tricks he's
trying to kind of make magic happen out
of nothing and if white is careful it
feels like you shouldn't have too much
to worry about meanwhile all of the
black pieces are gravitating towards the
center uh they're all I don't see any
threats right now but they're all kind
of holding each other together attacking
those white pawns white king is it
sweating here uh is it really a Target
love on Iranian I'm expecting him to get
his Knights into the game now especially
that White Knight on E1 nights in the
room are dim at the best of times but
that night on the bottom of the bud
needs to join the action join The Fray
yeah this position does not look that
easy to play for either side and I'm
just not liking the look of some of the
pieces right the bishop on D4 is a bit
loose so white will be able to kick it
with the tempo uh the bishop on H3 for
white a little bit awkward especially
with the stare down of the bishop so you
have to be very very careful when pieces
are in the same diagonal or in the same
file you have to watch out when the
piece in between them hops out of the
way here there's nothing for black but
there could be a moment where that
Knight jumps away and that Bishop on H3
is loose so I think Knight D3 sensible
move by Levon aronian he is just
coordinating his pieces playing in the
center and both sides have their chances
here and it's a very messy position and
James you made a really good point about
how because the east seven Pawn is weak
for black it's hard for black to connect
the Rooks the way white the way Lavon
just did by moving the Knight out of the
way and that's going to be a bit of a
trouble for feather save just getting
Harmony for those Rooks where are they
playing are you going to go shark Castle
are you going to go long Castle or maybe
the king just steps up is that something
James that black can think about move up
with the King to D7 and then start
getting your getting the Rooks in the
game I think after King D7 I hit him
with Knight F31 Tempo and then go with
the and then bring one of the Rooks to
D1 and then we have some nasty tricks
they're nice C5 and we live Knight E5
night everything five and you're in some
trouble here I mean it looks pretty
pretty nice they even have maybe an F5
Knight F4 take on E6 Knight G5 oh my
goodness right just so many moves that
you can play here there's so much
activity for White and the thing about
LeBron aronia here is that when you see
him sometimes like when he does this you
know he stretches and he do that like
that that's body language that lets you
know you might be in a little bit of
trouble every time he does that he's
feeling look at him yeah he's doing a
little head thing and like he stretches
he's come comfortable he usually always
does that when he's comfortable I've
noticed so he's comfortable he feels
good about the position yeah some body
language reading that by James well we
will come back to this but let's head
over to Liam versus Magnus because this
looks like it is about to end soon which
means we will have an Armageddon yeah
and Magnus smiling laughing to himself a
moment ago he looks pretty happy with
this play maybe he's happy about the
Armageddon that's imminent at this point
are the good air quality he's got going
or the food he just ate whatever you
know he's just happy like we like it's
good to see a happy Magnus yeah that is
true and he should be happy about this
game because with the black pieces it
may have looked iffy for a couple moves
but he was able to neutralize whatever
Advantage Liam hoped to get and we see
it's an even end game it's rook and
three pawns against rook in three pawns
both sides have a pass Pawn uh with a
white king can't venture over to get the
pawn it's needed where it is protecting
this Pawn on G3 the black king will have
to stop this past Pawn but neither side
will be able to make progress this is a
pretty Elementary draw for these players
yeah and just good strategy with the
Rooks Rooks belong behind past pawns
whites Rook is perfectly placed uh what
blackstroke is if anything is the more
passive of the two and there we go black
now with this last move he's tied down
his own Rook the black Rook can't move
without giving away his Pawn but he's
also set to wait if your king ever pokes
its head out kind of to the side the
Black Rock will move move with the check
and black will make a new Queen with his
Pawn so this one is very much just
maintaining the status quo neither side
can make progress I'm expecting a draw
offer or a draw agreement anytime now
the last game ended pretty much King
versus King maybe this will end in the
same way just uh two great players
canceling each other out in the early
games straight to Armageddon both of
them lost in our beginning yesterday who
do we think is the favorite
this one I'm definitely going with
magnets in the Armageddon gotta go with
Magnus the Army fresh off I think it's
just more magnets because of uh their
score and their record already now that
doesn't mean that anything happens in
Armageddon but just from being who he is
and also what the score is right now he
usually has this number but I mean
faster time controls too as well I'm
definitely gonna take Magnus what about
you rubber
first about how low he'll go because he
went to seven minutes and 58 seconds
yesterday if I'm remembering correctly
so will he go less than that I don't
think he needs to because Liam can't get
himself in the time show we are about to
see all the pieces come off the board
but I think that if you're Magnus you
just want the black pieces and for limb
you need enough time and that we have it
nothing left on the board but we've got
a lot of action left in this match as
we're heading towards the Armageddon it
is time for the inner game for the Mind
Games to come forward with the bid for
the Armageddon we will keep you updated
once we hear it from our players that is
exciting do you think they're gonna
really want the black pieces at this
time Robert yeah but I think Magnus for
sure is going to get the black pieces
because he can bid less time he's the
faster player between the two we saw
what happened to Liam yesterday he had
the black piece against five minute
carwana he did not have enough time and
car one was able to Blitz him down and
Checkmate the king so I think that match
will be interesting to see the bidding
but this match might not even get to arm
again yeah actually both Armageddon is
four Liam and from magnets were
absolutely disastrous yesterday on day
one so this is going to be an exciting
one but action is still on here and wow
what is happening Rook to C2 played the
bishop is attacked it doesn't have too
many squares it's got to fall back to
the center David yep and there we go the
bishop now centralized but White's
Knights do have a lot of Mobility the
position isn't fully open Black's Bishop
kind of hits thin air they did find a
really weird kind of convoluted way to
trade pawns earlier we saw lots of
tension lots of pieces white Seaport
disappeared but Black's F Pawn
disappeared and if we look at the
structure white has two porn Islands the
king side although the pawns connected
the queen side those two pawns connected
black has three porn islands and that's
because the E7 Pawn next to the black
king is isolated long term that could be
a Target that could be a weakness but uh
yeah I would choose the white uh side
here the white Knights just because they
look like they can leap forward to some
great squares that being said I do
usually prefer Bishops so I'm kind of
going against my instinct here but I
just do believe in white structure I
think that's a small thing but it could
be a key thing later on and uh Levon
he's not one to sit there and slowly
maneuver that would have been my uh
first call instead he's going straight
for the kill pushing his Pawn forward
that white Rook on B1 maybe opening up
some clear Targets on the queen side uh
what do we think here who would you pick
and why let me see that time seven of
five
yeah I do like white because I'm I feel
like I have initiative here I feel like
I have some better squares I have a
nicer Center than you do I have uh the
knights are tricky so if I get a knight
to G5 I can go into E6 and maybe do some
things I don't want to really push my
e-pawn just yet
um because you allows Knight D5 so I do
like white but it's just hard to
maneuver in pieces right now we have to
figure out what we want before I
definitely like if Pawn takes work
before obviously we're hitting B7 and we
can maybe go work to C4 and try to you
know attack the bishop if the bishop
moves then maybe we could move the
Knight on D2 because right now we can't
obviously because the final E4 hangs so
it's it's kind of cramped it feels a
little a little bit but I actually feel
like White's just a tad bit better a
little bit a little bit more active yeah
Robert do you see any way for black to
actually keep things together now I'm
struggling to see a way to uh kind of
stay active as black but uh keep
defending it looks like a big threat
simply Pawn takes Pawn opening up this
Rook all the active moves I see are bad
like I'm looking at ideas like can I for
blackplay B5 and if you take my Pawn on
B5 I play A4 and I want to go get a new
Queen but I understand that I'm giving
White Pass pawns but this is the type of
thought that Federal save is having he
knows if he sits passively that Levon
aronia might just grind him down in this
position it's not fun to play from the
black side so I'm getting a little bit
desperate Federal save should not his
position isn't that bad we see the
evaluation bar for the side of the
screen so if I'm Federal save I know I
want to lash out but maybe calm is
better here you're gonna have to pass
through defend it's not going to be fun
but maybe federal staff can get the job
done yeah for example if he takes this
Pawn off yes you allow the white Rook
for it but maybe you can just hold
things together here I'm hesitant to
suggest it but just move your Rook the
evaluation was heading up in White's
favor this is uh scary stuff I'm not
sure exactly why maybe it says James
mentioned suddenly this bishop is a bit
loose wow is this bishop trapped maybe
the other one oh the nice wood that's a
big boy move wow you got to play C5
suddenly black has to give things up
push this Pawn maybe give up this Pawn
just to keep the bishop alive so
actually there are hidden threats all
over the board not just is the white
Rook getting active on this Square uh on
the B7 square but this black Bishop
talking an Escape Route so nice move
there from leonoronian and definitely on
the board and on the clock
you know I've commentated enough games
he wants a last word and it actually
might not be a terrible move because he
will not push his a pawn if the pawn
takes he'll probably just take back but
he's figuring let me trade more of the
pawns because if I'm down only one Pawn
a few pawns remain maybe that optimizes
his drawing chances you see the eval bar
after levon's move a very natural one
it's actually saying that black is right
back in this yeah I'm really surprised
Levon his last move requires a lot of
calculation yes he's threatening to
maybe jump in with some night checks but
he all of that tension on the queen side
look at those four pawns staring off
against each other the white BNA pawns
the black BNA pawns that was so much to
work out he could have taken either one
of them maybe the pros and cons for both
but he rushed his decision and when you
make Rush decisions in such critical
positions
to backfire calculation over everything
like James says and there was so much to
calculate but you didn't that's right a
calculation over Everything Chad okay
you heard it from David first right he
said it not me okay right calculation so
you got to calculate here but it is and
he has a time to do it too as well I
mean I'm up three minutes here um LeBron
so I'm feeling good about the position
but man there's some definitely some
crazy stuff like you very rarely do you
have four pawns like this right in this
little you know Pond box right where you
have to actually figure out do I take
this weight and you take that way but if
I take that way he takes this way if you
take this way we take every weight right
so it's lots of captures and he takes on
B4 and the engine going crazy whoa is
that a blunder the White Knight can jump
in now with the check I'm not sure which
Knight but Knight to E5 and suddenly
there are all sorts of threats in the
air
white can simply take one of the two
pawns as you mentioned there or that
little box that cluster of Pawns but
there must be a knockout blower if the
engine's reacted maybe we can see the uh
stockfish suggestions here which is the
computer thing is there just one move to
win here for Lavon or is there uh are
there more options simply and wow the
best move by far wow according to the
computer is to just take this Pawn back
calmly with the Knight this is not easy
because there are so many tempting other
options but uh maybe we can show this
after Pawn takes Pawn in the current
position uh Knight takes Pawn is by far
the best move really really calm maybe
five though yeah C5 and I guess the
White Knight jumps in uh with a nasty
double attack on the next move
Pawn drops well wow really calm yeah not
obvious James right yeah wow not obvious
at all and FedEx okay Levon didn't find
that he took this Pawn instead the wrong
Pawn there and feather save now has had
a chance to jump in with his Knight
there's a nasty nasty threat on the
board with a night check hitting the
king hitting the Rook but Levon first
has a move to get out of this fork and
I'm expecting him to drop one of the two
white Knights into this Square I'm not
sure which one but uh he can jump in
with either of these two knights that's
a check it's a race it's messy but uh it
feels like it's slightly in White's
favor you give the first check and again
I called it wrong we're getting all of
the moves wrong here because it is so
messy it is so complicated but same idea
Levon aronian next move will jump in
with his Knight to the square with a
check wow we see the eval bar saying
that Lavon is doing well but we remember
what happened in the in game one
completely winning position for love and
you can't call it till it is done there
are still threats for black black is
also threatening a fork on C3 currently
but ferocyv his biggest problem in this
position James is the clock he's down by
more than three minutes how critical is
that going to be 100 critical but of
course a fair to save is actually very
very strong big fish on chess.com he's a
really big fish especially with that big
rating he has in Blitz and bullet so of
course uh Lebron aronia doesn't play
that much bullet as much but he is very
strong and he's up time right now he
doesn't have to play bullet chess he has
an extra four minutes right now coming
up on four minutes so he can use this
time as he did in the last game too as
well and try to convert this uh this
slight Advantage he has right now
yeah and uh I'm really worried about the
clock time feder safe if he doesn't
calculate correctly right now as well
it'll be an immediate knockout uh so one
minute is bad but uh he's investing it
because he needs to find something
magical he's not even going for the
obvious move most would just take that
Knight back with the black rook and then
think later but what else could he be
considering I think the problem is he
thinks Rook takes Knight which is the
obvious recaption he's finally played he
thinks he's losing because the white
king up he played it before I could say
it slides up the board hitting two
pieces at the same time The Rook is
under attack and that Rook is needed
there to protect the Knight so Federal
said recognize his position as falling
apart and there's nothing he can do to
hold it he usually it's like to stare
with each other right there's the
stretch and it's not a stretch to say
the levonne ruin is winning this game
because if the Rook protects the other
Rook the Knight Will hop in with check
at long last and this is big problem for
federal Sev yeah huge problem maybe we
can show this uh Robert because that is
the key variation it's a double attack
hitting the Rook hitting the Knight you
can't hold both together but if you
defend your fellow Rook then this Knight
check finally does arrive and at the end
it is a fork you hit both Rooks and if
the Black Brook moves with a check you
can step safely forward to take this
Black Knight something's dropping and uh
it looks like with the loss of material
will be the loss of the game for feather
save well the clock is dropping right
now he needs to make a move he's down to
30 seconds 35 seconds on the clock big
questions to be answered this could be
game over this very second he takes a
very drastic decision he sacrifices
material gives up an exchange
pure desperation he had to do something
and it was better to lose the exchange a
rook for night rather than lose a whole
piece wow so yeah I don't see anything
in the game David
um
I actually like it because what he's
doing is he's trying to treat everything
on the queen side and he said you may
have a rook I'll have a knight but if we
have two Rooks and three pawns against
Rook Knight and three pawns that does
give legitimate chance of knights they
are better pieces when pawns are only on
one flank and that would be the case
here so Lavon is thinking do I just take
this Pawn with my Rook or maybe I can
actually sacrifice my extra Rook for
that night and then go forward with a
pass pawn and win the ensuing rook and
pawn and game it's a big moment for
Lavon thankfully for him he has time to
calculate it yeah that's what the top
players do they save their time for
later when the calculation is really
essential and okay he goes for the kind
of Safety First simple approach he's
still a rook for night up but as Robert
says the game will take a slower turn as
uh for the safe here tries to set up a
fortress he needs to eliminate that
remaining white Pawn there we go and now
he's going to bring his Knight back
towards the king side towards the pawns
he's going to try and find a safe Square
to Anchor it on and uh it's not easy for
live on Iranian to win this one a nasty
check first of all the white King has to
be careful where it steps there might be
some nasty night Forks but yeah this
this one will be very difficult to
defend for fellas it feels like it
should be winning for white but not easy
uh to convert yeah this is actually I
mean honestly especially if the time is
low but he has four minutes so he
shouldn't walk into a four we say
shouldn't you never know sometimes
especially when time gets lower but yeah
the Rooks I mean you obviously want to
favor the side with the extra material
we have two Rooks versus the three Rook
Knight versus the three of course the
rook and Knight can definitely hold in
many positions especially if we get the
Knight to F5 like we saw with the
Fortress that Fabi and Liam lay had so
you know in that game you could set up
some things here it is going to be a
play but he's going to play that clock
look at that clock run you see he's out
of time yeah one of the issues I I would
say from looking at this from White's
perspective is I don't see an obvious
win like what's the winning plan not
just what's the next move but how do I
win this game and I think that if black
can get that Knight stabilized somewhere
and it likely will hop backwards and
towards the king side I actually don't
clearly see how white makes progress as
the Knight is doing a great job
defending the loose Pawn
fully agreed one wow there's someone a
little helper there at the back for
Levon uh being disturbed will this
distract him from his game but uh if
white could swap off one set of Rooks
it's an easy win Rook versus knight
you'll win that one you'll convert it at
the right moment you'll sacrifice uh and
witness and pawns but uh while one set
of Rooks remain on the board uh for
black there is always going to be some
hope yeah whatever happened that Lavon
wasn't too happy about that little
disturbance because this is such a
critical moment he wins this and he goes
back up to the Winner's bracket should
white keep that one extra pair of Rooks
on the board or should he try and trade
that off David uh White would love to
trade off Tanya as I mentioned if the
Rooks come off if one set of Rooks come
off easy win but uh feather save will be
the one dodging that avoiding that here
I'm expecting Levon to drop his Rook
back to block this check to offer that
trade but uh he could well March forward
with his King instead what is he
deciding the answer to your question
Tanya I think will come now will white
accept the trade or at least ask for the
trade or will he Dodge it and remember
the truth three minutes though against
12 seconds it's hard to believe likes to
defend with no time on his clock
but I feel like we've seen this before
right we expect somebody's just going to
lose because they have no time and then
they play Perfect chess our time you
have yesterday in that scramble against
Magnus Carlson he didn't have much time
but he was able to withstand the
pressure and this Knight it can go
forward and hop backwards to a square
like F5 James you were calling out
that's how Liam held against carwana he
had an outpost for his Knight and said
it's going to stay there you can't kick
me from there yeah what's what's King
going I don't understand what levon's
done with this King he could easily have
marched his King over towards his pawns
a bit earlier on suddenly the white king
is stuck on the back rank cut off okay
he breaks that uh breaks that tension
now offering The Rook trade notice how
FedEx immediately said no no trade for
you because uh he believes that having
one active Rook is uh the best chance to
save this game but look at the e-ball
bar eBay bar going crazy
now you can swap off the Rooks you can
Retreat your Rook from the center all
the way down and he's trapped his own
Rook feder save he has to agree to a
rook exchange and as we mentioned Rook
Exchange
is disaster time for black uh now all
level needs to do is to move his King
away defend his Rook on B2 and the Rooks
are coming off
new phase of the game begins and you can
see Federal save he just reacted he is
not happy those Rooks traded because
with Rooks on the board he can pester
those pawns without Rooks that Knight is
just a lone wolf and that Knight might
get trapped in a couple moves does not
have many squares to hop to yeah I think
you're right uh Robert it's about to get
trapped all white needs to do step
forward there we go defend your pawns
and the white king is coming it's just
gonna Shuffle across and uh the Black
Knight might have to find itself on even
weirder uh even uglier squares there we
go we go to the board just to survive
that's a funny move that's where my
night goes bro like hey hold on my light
goes there bro that's where the white
knight starts again right yeah uh
instead of still on the edge of the
board but the white king is coming just
Shuffle it across push it across towards
the Black Knight the best black can do
is push his Jeep on forward to try and
trade off next move but I don't think
that's going to save you that doesn't
improve the black chances no it doesn't
at all and actually the reason why is
because the night will still be stuck
there and white would then be playing up
a rook essentially and the rookers are
attacking black spawn on so this is what
Lavon is doing he's saying your knight
is offside it's not getting back in the
game and now the Rook is free to start
challenging black but Federal Sav he's
doing this the best he possibly can he's
trying to challenge this Pawn if he can
trade more pawns right Rook versus
knight if there are no Pawns of the
board that would be a draw so if Federal
Sav gets lucky and he can trade these
last two pawns he will have a shot but
look at Levon he's a man on a mission he
is not going to blow this one yeah he
shouldn't blow this one he's got enough
time he needs to just kind of sit on his
hands and just wait and there we go look
at his last move just waiting passing
the move to black black has to worsen
the position of his King unfortunately
with a knight you can never pass you can
never just pass the move back to your
opponent Rooks can always wait and now
Levon can he find a winning plan he
would love to move the king towards the
night but still not easy to trap it not
easy to attack it because White's pawns
are slightly weak still some work to be
done can we find a winning plan here
that's the big question crazy yeah chess
is hard like let alone figure out that
what's the winning plan here right I was
even looking at like Rook B8 maybe I
mean sitting up of traps obviously if
Knight takes Rook f8 but then I wanted
to go Rook B6 because if I go Rook B8 he
might go back to G4 there so uh Rook B6
but then if G5 I could check and then
King G4 maybe I go F5 there though let's
just show some of these ideas that
you're looking at maybe Rook B8 setting
up this trap as you mentioned a nice
little skewer there uh but if the king
moves forward then you want to attack
this Pawn it's on the board okay wow
it's on the board he's actually gone the
other way here uh he's defended his Pawn
now and this looks very very strong for
levonne Iranian this Knight still simply
trapped actually you don't really want
to move the king either because suddenly
you might get trapped on the edge of the
board you might get checkmated uh with
the king so you're kind of running out
of moves if you push this Pawn forward
he has just done this now white can make
a past Pawn of his own run through to
Glory
it's very critical for him to not trade
these pawns as you said more pawns on
the board more chances for white to win
but why is left having a think right now
you've got to push the F Pawn Yeah play
does become very forced after that very
forcing black knight comes in now white
dominates that black knight the white
king nicely nice opposition yeah he was
just calculating this I think he's
worked out that his Pawn is going to run
through and it will cost black his night
I don't think you should push the pawn
now or at least if you do you need to
calculate for a very very carefully
because black snipe wants to sacrifice
itself for the white porn and the black
pawns are going to start running uh if
you can win that Black Knight without
giving up your white Pawn that would be
the smoothest uh simplest technique nice
move on that's beautiful that's it game
over if you start pushing the Jeep on
you can also hit the Knight on H5 by
sliding The Rook up G4 on the board he
does it and the F Pawn will March down
the board yeah great play by Lavon there
because if he slipped it could have
still been a draw but he gives Federal
save no chance here comes his F Pawn
it's gonna become a queen and there's
resignation Levon aronian he moves on
LeBron wow LeBron Levon does it with a
win and the best stuff too it is Levon
who will be going back to the Winner's
bracket it is the end of the road for
federal safe could have been a very
different narrative fantasy have had his
moments in the chessable Masters day one
he almost knocked out Hikaru Nakamura
but today
Levon was the better player Robert yeah
Levon had the upper hand in both games
it was clear that he was playing great
chess and Lavon yesterday he won his
first game against Wesley so he stumbled
after that but he is a great player
Federal save he missed his chances
yesterday he didn't really have any
chances yeah and that was because of the
Fantastic play by Lavon let's Deep dive
into the action with our Lee soweta
learning points
oh
today's learning point is about knowing
your opponents if you know their
strengths their weaknesses you can form
a matched strategy that might give you
better chances to win the game here
levona Ronin is in the end game but he
actually traded off the Queens very
early in this game he traded them off on
move four the Queens came off and fair
to save a very attacking very Dynamic
player was unable to get his type of
position was unable to get any activity
in the game Levon later went on to win
The Exchange and I just want to show an
action replay of how he finished it off
really tense position here it looks like
the Black Knight the black king are
holding off the white Army the white
Rook is temporarily passive holding this
Pawn but he found the right moment Levon
to go active with this Rook bringing it
to B8 to the top of the board now
relying on this trick that Knight takes
porn does walk into a nasty check
picking up the Knight when the king
moved he just simply brought his Rook
across and black is in zuk Swang there's
nothing black can do without worsening
his position he was forced to push his
Pawn forward and live on Levon correctly
realized he could a past Pawn of his own
I just want to show one final move to
wrap this one up a really nice idea here
not getting Hasty not getting carried
away with pushing the pawn because the
Black Knight can sacrifice itself but
domination that is the key to Black
Knight is on a bad Square anyway so
shuffling The Rook across and going for
this Knight clinched the game the Knight
is trapped and after a couple more moves
the white porn was free to run forward
and make a new Queen nice technique from
level neronian and with that 11 advances
to the winner bracket create technique
that these are our results of the
loser's bracket it's not over yet as
we've got Armageddon action coming up
with Magnus Carlsen taking on Liam the
bids with B will be with us shortly with
joining us
right now is the winner of the match
Levon or onion Levon congratulations
thank you very much Levon not just the
result not just the score line but you
have reasons to be very pleased with the
quality of your play today
it's more place than yesterday for sure
what do you think what is it that worked
for you in today's match against
federative
at some point I told myself that I have
to play faster and because I've been
playing too slowly yesterday but also I
think today uh in the first game I I
also managed to spoil it although it
looked very promising I was done on time
I didn't see a simple tactic but
generally I think the positions that
I've got today
um I mean especially in the second game
it was uh such an easy position for me
to play that
once I got this Knight so I felt that
I'm going to win
yeah Lavon congratulations I mean that
was a great match Victory and we have to
ask there's somebody who walked behind
you so where are you playing from and
who was that
so I'm in a hotel in Egypt and some uh
well I I asked the general manager of
the hotel if he could provide me some
space to play my matches and he kindly
provided his
room you know the
his office
and there there was a some guy who was
responsible for for watering the plants
and I was trying as
I was trying so much I forgot to notify
that nobody should enter here
great job Lavon you won today I always
like to call you LeBron aronian uh sir
so Lavon um you you know I've noticed
that you know you stretch when you when
you're like comfortable or when you're
winning just like I've noticed this from
games when you're winning so is this
something that you actually know or is
this something that you do when you're
when you're winning you just like
stretch and you do the head knot like
this so I wanted to know is that
something you actually know that you're
doing
it's a never stick man isn't
here something it's sort of a stretching
or some sort of psychological thing I I
can't really control it it's some sort
of a tick that I have and as you
probably know most of the grand Masters
are
pretty screwed up people so it's one of
the uh
ways you know I I relax I guess I don't
know it's
unvoluntarily so I have to really
stretch my back sometimes
love it fantastic play today uh 11 and
you will be back in the Winner's bracket
tomorrow how are you feeling about this
double elimination bracket do you enjoy
this format
folks it's so confusing I have no idea
who
all I know that the time that I'm
playing it
so it's the same time so
I think uh it would be the best if in
order to confuse us even more we had to
start at different times and then play a
different game you know or the bishop
moves as a rook or something like that
I love thank you so much we do have
action coming I love this
well we're really excited to see you
back tomorrow in the Winner's bracket
thank you so much Lavon for joining us
and good luck for tomorrow
wow we will be having the Winner's
bracket later on but before that we're
gonna go into a short twitch break
[Music]
he is the chess streamer of the Year
Levy Rossman has arrived on chessable
you want to know how to counter the
Sicilian the French the Carol then Levy
shows us the way with one info he brings
masterful technique to bring in those
wins with white head over to chaserville
and start up in your game today use the
command Gotham chasable to Master One E4
and if you want to play some chess in
the Bahamas so get ready to play in the
international Quan Chess Championship
there is a lot of action coming up and
earlier on our very own David Howell
visited the Norwegian business school
this is what happened
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up World Quant is
seeking new talent and new energy and
it's looking at the world of Chess to
help because nobody knows how to analyze
a position better than a chess player
right no Quan experience no problem so
do you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
wow definitely get ready for the
international Quan Championship but
right now it is time to get ready for
the Armageddon this is going to be a lot
of fun because take a look at the format
these are the regulations we've got a
bidding Armageddon and we know what that
means a lot of excitement the player who
bids the lower time wins the Armageddon
gets to decide the color the player who
picks the black pieces and it's usually
the winner of the bed who wins who takes
the black pieces gets the time that they
bid for base time is 15 minutes so white
would start with a 15 minute but black
has got result odds which means that
white has to win on demand a draw means
that black wins the match Magnus Carlsen
what is he going to bid Robert I don't
know what the number is but he's gonna
bid lower than the M late that I can
assure you he's so good David with these
Mind Games we remember in the Athens
Masters how he outfit Hikaru are you
expecting him to
it did back far yesterday we should
mention against our team I think you've
been a bit too low Magnus Carson under
eight minutes and in the end the time
really counted he blundered his Queen
and ended up getting checkmated so he'll
go low but how low will he go that's the
big question and Liam I think we'll be
happy with the white pieces he'll be
happy in that masculine situation you
want to know how low he'll go well we've
got the bids let's reveal the players
bids for our Armageddon and wow James
how close was this Magnus Carlsen
bidding 10 minutes 29 seconds takes the
bit James how does he do this I don't
know how he does this I mean it's just
literally a mind it's the Magnus effect
he just knows what you're thinking at
all times especially in this building
with the armor getting here he's going
to take the black pieces against that
hey if I draw I win if I win I win and
Liam is going to be under some pressure
yeah and Robert I have to say Magnus
wins this bit by almost just 30 seconds
just about 30 29 seconds to be exact
right and that is just insane which
means he gets to pick the colors but not
that big a Time Advantage for Liam then
yeah Magnus can thank Fabiano because
they play this Armageddon match
yesterday Liam spin way too low for his
own good and five on a punish him so
after seeing that Max like he's not
gonna do that again I could actually
start with more time than I have in
other matches still get the black pieces
still get drawds still have good chances
yeah
he's won the bit he's taking black
taking black 100 100 yeah we've seen
Magnus he knows that if he doesn't need
to lose he can shut up shop and he's
very good at being solid when he wants
to be so he'll take black he'll take 10
and a half minutes and he'll be happy
surely but Liam really hasn't given him
too many chances in the rapid whether it
was white or black both games just
amazing play by Liam yeah but Liam needs
amazing play plus more in order to beat
Magnus in this next game if Magnus
chooses black so it's not going to be
easy for him James draw will just not
cut it out and that is what Magnus needs
games were drawn two games were drawn so
Liam gonna have to take some risk here
he's like oh go ahead take as many risk
as you want you'll lose or we can play
something quiet and go to a draw guess
who wins there I do right you get
eliminated so this is elimination on the
break of elimination really especially
when you have those two chances to
either win or Draw the game and get
black with black ladies and gentlemen
fasten your seat by the time we're
getting is about to start Liam we'll
start with the white pieces 15 minutes
on the clock Magnus will have 10 minutes
and 29 seconds as he outbid Liam Magnus
plays with the black pieces he needs
just a draw to win the match Liam will
be knocked out in that case Liam has to
win on demand he has to win on The Mod
and he might have to pick a new opening
last time he chose the Catalan but
Magnus equalized effortlessly very
easily Magna showed his preparation and
unless Liam's been studying in that last
break then uh yeah something new need
something completely different to catch
Magnus off guard not going to be easy
and Liam's also a very kind person he's
a lot of respect for every opponent not
just Magnus you have to lose all respect
in Armageddon you need to flag your
opponent you need to use the clock as a
weapon and right now you know Magnus
he's had been shielded with increment
doesn't have that anymore so Liam has to
play quickly play sharply and just say
to Magnus you know what I may be a solid
player but here I have to go all in yeah
Shameless flagging is recommended in the
Armageddon are you at all expecting a
king's Indian today uh James you're not
a king's Indian today unfortunately but
of course Kings Indians can you can go
quietly in King's Innings you can play
them to a draw or win actually with
King's Indian but I think he's just
going to go with something solid maybe a
nimso Indian or even a ragozan or even
Queen's camber decline something that
he's used to play yeah E6 right some
something cool here okay maybe yeah and
queen's game of decline Here We Go Again
wow what is this
another Catalan and Magnus is the one
thinking early dose it's a bit
surprising his last black game he
equalized very very easily and I would
say if you if it's not broken why fix it
and uh okay why is he thinking it is a
race against the clock I think it's a
bit psychological because Magnus is not
one of the players who likes to repeat
the same opening over and over again so
even though he had success with it just
a moment ago he says I'm not going to
play the same one and this is actually
what both players want Magnus well
prepared but for lamb it's not just a
simple straightforward symmetrical
structure in fact white has the bishop
pair now but White's Pawn structure is a
bit compromised yeah I don't like this
Choice by Liam Magnus has used this
exact line himself multiple times he won
a really nice game against Anish giri a
few years ago as white in this exact
variation with those double day pawns uh
so if Magnus isn't kind of played it as
white he knows what's going on he'll
know the antidote he'll know how to play
it as black
Liam should have picked a different line
different opening 100 I mean I think
already uh it feels like he's already
equalized when it comes to the Catalan
and what's the best piece is that bishop
and when you get Bishop D7 Bishop C6 in
I find that this is a very cool way to
actually uh kind of almost neutralize
the cattle in here but at least we get
to get rid of that ridiculously strong
Bishop on G2 if you ever move the Knight
you don't have a knight C3 coming I mean
Black's just for a choice I mean all all
the way here now I do like white has the
bishop pair you can try to make some
some problems obviously try to get E4 in
that's what you want in Catalan anyway
maybe play Bishop to B2 Rook B1 but
black actually is just totally fine in
this position that might be totally fine
but Liam's strategy is clear keep all
pieces as many pieces as you can on the
board and try and run Magnus low on the
clock any trades favor Magnus and Robert
is that the reason why he's gone for a
central break with C5 yeah he wants to
trade he wants to make the position
easier to play and for Liam he's a
former World Blitz Champion the problem
is he's playing somebody who's the
reigning world Blitz champion in a
multiple time world Blitz Champion did
we mention that Magnus the world
champion in all formats yeah he's that
and the issue for Liam he's not much as
I've seen on chess.com not much of a
bullet player Magnus he's been playing
more and more streaming these quick time
patrols the speed Chess Championship you
name it he's there and unfortunately for
Liam I don't see his opening going very
well I actually like black Swiss Even If
This Were a classical game yeah and
James alluded to that white Catalan
Bishop sitting on G2 in front of the
white king normally the best piece in
this opening but Black's light Square
Bishop in the center completely
neutralizes it uh if the white knight
ever moves we'll see a Trader Bishops
black will be very happy to trade off
that Bishop pair the white has and with
a better structure long term look at
those white acorns black has all the
chances with sounding very biased here
in the studio but I think that does
reflect just White's opening not being a
success so far if you could keep pieces
on the board great there'll be tension
you can flag your opponent later but
pieces will come off Magnus is so good
uh to turning things his way and okay A
bit of a mysterious Pawn push there
Magnus now I'm pretty sure we'll just
move his Queen out connect the black
Rooks bring them to the center nothing
to worry about here just rock solid and
all you need is a draw perfect scenario
for black
now connected I mean I'm finishing my
development I'm feeling good the OC file
is going to open you got weak pawns here
neutralize the cattle and Bishop this
feels like a disaster I'm not even gonna
lie for as a Catalan player here on
takes taste I mean what is this I'm
supposed to play for a win here guys my
Queen's off the board how do I you know
this is this is over yeah at least he's
improve this pull structure small gains
here but yeah off to this porn capture
if the white knight goes and takes this
Pawn back actually you end up losing
material you have to be really careful
how uh you recapture this Pawn okay he
brings us up to the center let's just
show that on the board if you were Hasty
here if you were greedy and took this
Pawn back after a trade of Bishops
whoops this is a double attack a fork
and lose a piece lose the Armageddon
immediately so the white Rook has slid
across but now Magnus is simply going to
occupy the open file I'm not sure which
Rook you use but he's going to bring his
rook in and uh black is fine black
totally fine black swirl for choice
because you can bring the Rook to C8
like Dave's A6 let's open open up the
file for the rook and its place and if
you take on A6 The Rook captures back A2
is loose there's just nothing to Target
in Black's position white is the one
who's down upon temporarily and has to
protect other pawns this has not gone
Lamb's way and I don't think this is
biased I think it's just objective
evaluation of the position Liam himself
will be the first to admit that this has
not gone the way he wanted and for
Magnus his moves are quite
straightforward which means he's not
even going to get into severe time
trouble unfortunately for Liam he's
playing somebody who does not lose very
often and to win on demand is difficult
against anyone but Magnus Carlson
sometimes impossible yeah it looks
impossible it looks like white is trying
to play for equality if anything this is
the type of Chess that I play when I'm
trying to draw top players in the world
but uh he needs to win remember Liam and
uh looking difficult right now I mean he
must win a situation that you you have
to
opening choice is very important too as
well I mean Catalan is the small
Advantage squeeze opening right and
you're trying to squeeze the squeezer
right it just doesn't work that way you
know it's very difficult especially in a
must-win situation if this was okay if
you're okay with the draw that's cool
but not in this situation I think uh
this opening Choice definitely is not
going to be uh he's going to be kicking
himself for this one yeah it comes back
to those Mind Games Tanya you use that
phrase Mind Games he guessed on the
clock he got got the black pieces and I
think actually that was the Turning
Point uh he knew that actually opening
wise he would never really be in trouble
against Liam's repertoire he's clearly
done his homework against the Catalan
Magnus and uh Liam meanwhile because he
was maybe affected by those Mind Games
chose wrong in the opening he chose an
opening that Magnus knows everything
about you need to catch him off guard
you need to provoke him uh if you want
to take him down but as Robert says
those pawns have disappeared from the
board the whole Queen side is going to
be liquidated you can imagine the black
people and despairing maybe the white
apron will disappear and if play
switches just to one side of the board
White's Bishop pair I say Advantage uh
won't amount to anything at all he does
have this unique ability to get into his
opponent's Minds where we see him outbid
in the Armageddon time and time again
what was most impressive was the margin
that he did it with we were talking
about how low will he go to just get the
black pieces and he barely just went
enough knowing somewhere annoying how
much he pretty much guessed what would
Williams be that's the that's the
feeling that we got with the bidding
that we saw in the Armageddon it's
because Magnus is not just a great
player he's a great student of the game
and he watches everything I mean he
devours chess material he watched
yesterday on replay I'm sure he saw what
happened between Liam and Fabiano he saw
the huge time disadvantage that Liam had
and stayed throughout the game so he
realized them can't bid that against
Fabiano if they repeated that he
wouldn't bid it against Magnus so he
learned from it and I just want to give
a quick shout out to Liam it sounds
harsh because he's unfortunately it
seems like going to be limited against
Magnus but he hasn't been worse for a
single move in these three games and
that is something that not many people
can say they have done so Liam he just
needed to play less solidly to try to
get something it's okay to lose an arm
again because it draws the same as the
loss when you have the white pieces but
I really want to shout out the
Vietnamese super Grand Master the coach
of Webster University because he's
played a stellar match he also Drew four
games yesterday before losing an
Armageddon so he's been right there he's
so close but unfortunately with the
white pieces you need to win when it
comes down to it he's not getting it
done in this game yeah but one also had
a feeling in his match against Fabiano
where he was really struggling playing
that active position he never got the
kind of positions that he would enjoy
playing and here we see the pieces all
being trade off more and more which
means it is Advantage Magnus because he
needs just to draw Robert is taking your
point following on that point that you
mentioned the biggest problem here is
that the draw just doesn't suffice Liam
hasn't lost or been worse throughout the
match but it's not good enough
yeah small margins at the top level
sometimes you have a victim of the
format sometimes you're a victim of your
own type of Chess your own style and
here it's just dead level it's going to
be a draw with best play but not enough
and uh yeah on Robert's Point as well
that Magnus devours the game people
don't give him credit for studying chess
he studies in a different way to others
but for sure every game yesterday both
division one division two even division
three he would have played through all
of those games he would have noticed the
clock usage he would have kind of
adapted his Armageddon strategy
according to the opponent and that's
what brought in Victory today or what is
likely most likely now to give him
Victory and we saw a small Shake of the
head from Liam he's normally stoic he
normally barely gives away any emotions
but he knows he's up against it and his
time in this tournament is almost done
yeah I think Liam should have played uh
the London system of course because he
does have a London courts he has one of
the best chance of London courses right
you have other ones too as well but his
is one of the best especially as a super
gm2 as well very great you know system I
think he probably should have went for
that just to maybe play something
different get some different positions
here because this I mean this was a
Magnus had no trouble at all Blitz the
moves out me Barely Used any time then
he started with 10 minutes right so he
barely used any time here and I mean you
know time is about to be even this is
going to be in a draw and it looks like
Liam is on the brink of elimination
James we know one other person who has a
course on the London London oh the jar
jar base London oh okay yeah the meanest
Obama that is coming your way on
Chesterfield make sure you're looking
for that one well he should have chosen
something else because right out of the
opening Magnus managed to equalize and
we see a very symmetrical Pawn structure
this one it is hard to imagine white
creating anything and we see the clocks
are leveling out as well David is there
anything left in this position can white
create something with that lone Bishop
well that's going to be traded off as
well now yeah I think I think the
question is can black women can black
play for more look at those beautiful
black knights in the center of the board
look at that beautiful black Rook just
x-ray vision across the second rank
looks like it's holding together by a
thread fullium it should still be a draw
but it might be Magnus getting uh
enthusiastic getting excited here uh
James you mentioned he could have played
the London system for example the
problem is Magnus plays the London
system himself he probably knows how to
equalize against that opening it's so
hard to give advice at this top level
because if you catch Magnus on a good
day he's hard to beat and uh yeah Magnus
has done enough just about enough but
enough to progress but I like how you
framed it that I think Lem is a victim
of his own style within this format
because the players who take risk tend
to be the players who do better in
Armageddon because when they get the
white pieces they're willing to lose
some people even in a regular tournament
where you're going to play the same
number of games no matter your result
they don't want to lose they're almost
like afraid of losing it breaks their
Spirit it hurts them to the core whereas
other players like I'll win some I'll
lose them but that's okay and I think
the players who do take more risks the
nakamuras even the federal saves they
tend to thrive a little bit more because
we can't forget even though just got
eliminated he probably should have taken
down Hikaru Nakamura yesterday uh it was
just unfortunate for him Misfortune in
that end game that he couldn't break
through and made a slip there but I
think that players who are very solid we
often comment them for their Precision
they're really hard to take down but
when they need a win on demand they
often struggle to get it because they
don't go outside of their comfort zones
and that's what sets Magnus Hikaru apart
they have different gears they can shift
to kind of hustle mode they can shift to
all-out winning mode and they can try
and trick bamboos or their opponents and
not everyone has that in their locker
also they can play solid which helps in
situations like this as Magnus is
showing really cynical chess but it's
effective chess just trading off the
remaining imbalance another night for
Bishop imbalance has disappeared
symmetrical Pawn structure will ensure a
draw here Magnus though setting up
tricks setting up potential traps maybe
the pawns will step forward kick away
the white king from the defense of his
Knight
uh Liam has to be careful to hold this
one wow David you're mentioning a
Potential Threat with that Bond moving
forward to F4 giving a check deflecting
the king at the right moment also watch
out four
a potential sacrifice on D2 with the
Rook there are threats and folks all
over the board and Liam is the one who
needs to be careful even though the most
likely result is a draw in this one but
that would mean that Magnus Carlsen wins
the match Magnus looks almost a little
bored right now James yeah actually in
fact uh it's funny the body language
you'll see that even a Hans used to do
that they just sit here like this and
like I'm like are you even feel it feels
disrespectful so you playing anything
like this
I'm looking around you and actually
earlier today it looked like Magnus was
just doing he's doing laundry he closed
the blinds behind him he was eating food
like this mattress was just like in fact
he felt like the confidence for Magnus
even knowing that he has a plus record
on Liam is just saying that I had this
in the back the whole time I think Liam
kinda knew that too in a way I mean he
is down you do you know your opponent
your record against opponents here but
he's gonna fight and I mean he did and
it's just it's not looking good though
for them yeah no Magnus as well he'll
feel slightly guilty that he just kind
of hoovered off all the pieces and just
went for the draw he probably wanted a
fight he probably uh wanted some more
excitement today but he did what he
needed to do and he's actually said
another cunning trap in this position if
the white knight now moves then he can
force the draw immediately at least by
uh giving up his Rook the White Knight
is a bit stuck a bit pinned if it had
moved on this last go sorry uh then nice
Rook sacrifice Rook takes Pawn check and
a nasty Fork this is what white has to
watch out for uh next move the Rook will
disappear and black would be uh with the
advantage four versus three meanwhile
white moved his Rook but this did allow
Magnus now to throw in a check and just
to show what happens if the pawn is
captured uh it has been captured the
first point at least Rook takes Knight
Rook takes Knight Brook takes Bourne
everything off the board two versus two
draw immediately so uh Magnus continuing
in that same vein hover off those pieces
and a draw is about to happen I love the
difference between American English and
British English
we say vacuum you know it's okay again
it but I'm just saying you know I
appreciate it you know our differences
is what makes us special and I it's not
oh
[Laughter]
wow I think just to point it out a
little bit that there was a nasty little
trap there set up David yeah if Rook
takes Knight I think everyone got
excited for a second by Rook takes night
it looks like it wins because after King
takes there's a nasty night fork and
black picks up the white Rook but don't
what uh don't forget about those checks
watch out because Sonny White flicks in
a check the king moose now after King
takes Rook the king and Knight King and
Rook sorry are sufficiently far apart
for uh them to avoid any Forks black
would have been on the blundered here
trickster gets tricked as they say
instead we go to this position limbs
kept the knights alive he kept the game
going the problem is he's still stuck
the black Rook along this rank look how
strong it is just keeping white
completely tied down Black's Knight
holds all the other pawns and still no
way to make progress for white and
that's not his biggest problem he's
actually behind on the clock now
with a little less than five minutes and
a position where it's hard to imagine
white making any progress while he is
going after the H Pawn but oh these
pawns are going to be traded off James
absolutely like it when you get one same
same appreciate it right you know thank
you thank you buddy appreciate it right
take taken and that's really it we got
to move the night you have to take take
and maybe put the Knight on F5 very
strong post for it maybe go to E3 after
that there it is Knight of five plate
and I mean there's no way I'm losing
this game unless I mean even Knight G3
looks good too unless some type of mouse
slip right which we actually saw in
division what was this division two or
uh division three division three right
there was a mouse slip happen where uh
um Josh from Jose Martinez geez Jasper
lost from a mouse that got eliminated
from a mouse slip that hurts so this is
definitely got to make sure your click
game is correct here okay
yeah I feel so bad for Liam he's done
nothing wrong at all he's got this game
going credit to him there would have
been so many ways for Magnus to force
the draw against uh someone who is
slightly inaccurate he's kept the game
going but still making zero Headway and
we saw it for a moment on the camera
Liam kind of sagged slightly in his
chair
um less upright than he previously was
but uh yeah just looking for ways to
keep the game going that's all he can do
at this moment four minutes though no
increment not easy such a current guy
though I go Liam and I played in the
same youth tournaments growing up he won
the world youth under 14. and I drew
somebody who could have tie with him if
he had beaten me and his whole like the
whole Vietnamese Federation came and
like was thanking me I'm like I didn't
win the term why are you thinking me I'm
like oh it's because Liam won and I I
understood but you know since ever since
every time I've come across some super
friendly guy always wanting to talk
chess look at new uh possibilities and
he's the coach of Webster University and
for those of you who don't know Webster
University has the best chess team they
are stacked their chess team could beat
most countries Olympic teams and so he's
the coach he's working on chess all the
time he's a great leader and this time
it's not going his way in the chessel
Masters but I think we'll see him again
hundred percent and we've seen him have
a great performance in the past seasons
of The Champions Chester but it just
feels like Robert that in these formats
being Mr Nice Guy it doesn't help
gotta be nasty gotta be nasty right now
oh man yeah I mean as Robert pointed out
to me Liam played great chess here this
is a draw three draws I didn't lose
right I mean I didn't lose but I'm still
getting eliminated I'm not even lost in
any position in any game correct
all right rookie one played defunded the
pawn black advances the King Liam is
going to play it down but we can't even
imagine a possible flagging scenario
here I can he'll get flagged he's the
one who's down a lot of time now but he
cried to him he keeps trying to find
ways to keep the game going uh but
unfortunately against Magnus Magnus
hasn't given him an ounce of hope uh
White's pieces are tied down Black's
pieces are more active and they both
know what the result was likely going to
be from an early stage but for them he
kept going and finally there is that
exchange sacrifice liquidates everything
yeah and night Fork picks back the
material gets that white rook and we
will see I think for the third time out
of three games King versus King damn
that's how close it's been how strong
how hard they fought and Magnus does
progress he does and it is the end of
the road for Liam a heartbreaking moment
but Liam has so much to take away so
many good moments from this one he was
never was in his match against Magnus
Carlsen but that is that is the
brutality of this format sometimes a
draw is just not enough which means it
is the end of the road for Liam while
Magnus is the one who advances big
moments is the in this one David what
got your attention oh it's hard to pick
a key moment actually in this game I'll
just show an action replay of the final
few moves because uh Liam tried but uh
Magnus was so cynical every moment he
got he was alert to those exchanges we
saw it from the beginning Queens came
off Rooks came off Bishops came off and
here Magnus uh after locking down the
white position tying down all of White's
pieces found the final tactic to draw
this one after the white porn stepped
forward we saw a trade and Rook takes
Knight I wouldn't even have been looking
for tricks here but Magnus is so alert
Rook takes Knight forcing the white king
onto a bad square into this uh fork and
that was the end of this match up simply
all of the pawns disappeared we saw King
versus King in a couple of moves time
and the game was a draw just cynical
chest by Magnus but effective chess yeah
wrapping it up as efficiently as
possible with that sacrifice at the end
and that means these are the results of
our losers bracket Magnus Carlsen and
Levon aronian advance to the Winner's
bracket Liam Lee and Vladimir photos
here have been knocked out of the
trustable Masters James the two
favorites of the Elimination Brackets go
ahead absolutely of course you have
Magnus here it was just a favorite in
any time control of course in any format
he definitely Lost first but this is
double elimination now he's back in
there right so that's actually really
annoying for the winner in the Winter's
bracket like oh cool Magnus is out but
he's like oh he's back right so now you
gotta fight Magnus now then it's a
LeBron aronian just doing what he does
very strong creative and if he gets on
the road it's a very it's a problem for
everyone
joining us
Mark is with us Magnus congratulations
thank you
Magnus you were quite disappointed with
your play yesterday are you happier with
the way chess with the way it went today
against Liam
yeah I was okay I didn't do anything
special uh
well I mean apart from the first 10
moves or so in the first game uh I
played more or less okay uh
but I think
uh his choice of opening in the air
Armageddon was pretty unfortunate uh the
way it happened I just
got a very comfortable position where I
could just trade it every opportunity
and then it was really easy
yeah Magnus I have to ask you how have
you always managed to outbid your
opponents in the Armageddon
I mean yesterday my bed was pretty
pretty awful uh in the sense that it was
not close to his uh uh today
I was sort of fine with playing white I
thought let's try that as a challenge
and if your bids
you know a few bits higher than 10 and a
half minutes you know be my guests
that's fun
and uh Magnus you posted on Instagram
before today's match that uh you're out
skiing a different form of preparation
do you think that helped
um well I was skiing yesterday as well
but uh apparently it worked better today
I'm not sure why I don't think my play
was particularly better but I enjoyed
Ariel so hmm that's fine
Magnus you were grubbing hard man when
you came in what were you eating
everybody in the chat wanted to know you
were eating and it looked like it was
great what were you eating
it's just a little snack
um some
uh bread with
[Music]
um
bread with some local cheese and uh
avocado as well as a few tomatoes on the
side it was really interesting do you
have any left because I'm getting hungry
just hearing about it
no
I think we should wrap this up soon
because there is uh there is a risotto
waiting for me I managed to have like
two bites before I played the Armageddon
but now I'm really eager to to get back
to it all right Magnus we let you get to
the risotto congratulations and we look
forward to seeing you back in the
winners bracket tomorrow
isn't it the losers
you're always a winner to us Magnus
don't worry winning one match doesn't
make it uh uh but yeah I'm happy to
survive another day uh tomorrow's match
will be inside the tough
uh regardless of whom I play
um but yeah
I'll uh we'll try
all the best we look forward to that
thank you for joining us
thank you
Magnus Carlsen there after his
Armageddon win against Liam Lee I did
make it look
quite easy in that one Liam never really
had his chances yeah maggots himself
said it was kind of unfortunate for Liam
he just didn't get anything whatsoever
in the opening not only did he not get
an advantage he let everything to be
traded and it was easy for Magnus from
there
well we've got a shot twitch break
coming up for our non-subscribers
[Music]
there's so much ass action going on all
over the world including a very famous a
very well-loved tournament the Reykjavik
open the chessable team caught up with
the players at the Reykjavik open take a
look
my name is I am Bjorn torfinson from
Iceland I'm an international Master
forever striving to become GM basically
because my little brother made it as a
GM and I'm doing pretty well I I I'm I
have two and a half out of four I I beat
the players that I'm supposed to beat
but the super GMS are still uh yeah I
can't get past them at the at the moment
I was playing here in the Reykjavik open
yesterday against Grandmaster embra Khan
and there I hit my Achilles heel we
started openings I only had limited
knowledge of the opening I played and
against the super Grand Masters it's uh
almost impossible you have to be very
accurate so yeah I I hit a wall against
that strong player
wow the action is also on in division
two we've got some results David coming
in yeah we do and uh there have been
some huge clashes as we mentioned
earlier in the day look at the winners
bracket nordebec Abdul sotorov continues
his hot form takes down Arjun eragisi in
form four games uh Dennis lazovic as
well taking down Vincent kymer a bit of
a surprise on paper but not to those
familiar with denlaz and Maxim
vashilograph winning his match actually
a blowout there against pregnant and a
bit of a surprise but Vladimir kramnik
14th World Champion continues the fairy
tale comeback he wins his match too and
uh some big games in the losers bracket
Anish uh Geary Daniel dubov Alex hydrov
and Yu yangi winning their matches yeah
I just love it I love to see it Vladimir
kramnik keeping up the Old Guard in this
very difficult format which gets younger
and younger and the hair is Vlad with
his 3-1 win impressive stuff he says
moral degradation he's back
maybe you didn't Lisa the news of his
retirement greatly exaggerated but
Vladimir crummit playing some great
chesses actually looking at the games he
is informed yeah there's also some great
chess going on in division three let's
bring up our a bracket in that one and
some shocking big upsets there
yeah no there are some famous K's from
previous decades you had karpov kaspara
of krumnik but don't leave out komsky he
played a championship match against
Anatoly karpov he was one of the
prodigies of his generation he's still
around don't forget that name he moves
on and so it does Alexi serrana it looks
like taking down itarizaga in Armageddon
so Serana he was in division one in the
air things Masters he still afloat in
division three here in the chessel
Masters yeah
lost his match there five thousand
dollars and tour points at stake in
division three but it is back to
division one as we are about to lift off
the action in the Winner's bracket take
a look at what's on the menu it is
another big Vlog taking on a fabulous
Fabiano caruana
Fabi and we've got Hikaru versus Wesley
all right guys are we going to see any
of those Berlin draws yes or no David
fall asleep on the spot okay
I'll be more optimistic artemiev and
carwana they will fight every single
game so I don't care what happens the
other match they make those draws so be
it carwana entertainment they're gonna
duke it out well I'd love that we need
to be compensated for any of those draws
if they do happen these are the
regulations in the Winner's bracket it
is going to be a best of four it will be
a mini match between the players a best
of all with 15 minutes and a three
second increment of course if the match
is tied we will have more armagedds I'm
gonna call it out you heard it here
first Wesley Hikaru is going into an
Armageddon yes or no David yes James yes
oh my God Robert no no
all right well either ways we would love
to see an Armageddon the players are
getting ready let's take a look at their
head to head a big fight they've played
each other so many times 46 draws oh my
God
hakamura leads with Dan wins Wesley so
to seven one thing's clear Wesley cannot
rely on an Armageddon David we've seen
that go against him that's right twice
in the air things Masters a couple of
months ago how
took down Wesley so in the Armageddon
and remember in the American Cup they
had that kind of marathon Clash where
Hikaru was Victorious as well so Wesley
he's going to be sick of the sight of
Hikaru right now but he needs to go in
the attack he needs to take him down in
normal time before it gets to that stage
yeah yeah and that is Fabiano caruana
that is a big fight as well I think that
is going to be all out fireworks in the
four rapid games I'm gonna expect the
unexpected in that one but we do have
leftover scenes with Hikaru and Wesley
though Wesley he doesn't even know that
the game has started so here he comes
he's got some cats that are often
hanging around and he will probably play
E5 and oh no are we gonna see it oh my
God it's gonna it's happening early days
laughing oh my goodness don't do it
don't do it I'm about to go to sleep
okay the Italian game the scotch the
four nights anything just not the Berlin
draw and we've seen some Anarchy
villains between these two I'm hoping
for an antebellum push the Deep one push
the Deep ones
we can breathe and uh this is actually
something that occurred during the
American Cup Hikaru was playing D3 the
Black Knight would jump into the center
very quickly and the games were very
balanced I've got to say a few drawers
here in that but at least we see some
action a bit later on and this last
bishop move dropping back has surprised
Wesley it's not typical not normal it's
very reminiscent however of that game
earlier between feathersev and Iranian
you know time and time again we saw that
14 move Berlin jaw with the queen check
and the Perpetual uh not the Perpetual
but the repetition being played out and
I really think that it is the flag that
the two players got for repeating that
draw James that has discouraged them
from doing that and that's the reason we
see an auntie Berlin today absolutely of
course I mean hikara wants to fight you
know he's uh this is a big match of
course and if I can take it to you or
maybe mix it up a little bit maybe we
got 46 draws I'm like I don't I'm tired
of this like I'm coming man bro how many
draws does it take right so we want to
actually fight this time and I like the
choice for mikaru Auntie Berlin yeah and
that's the beauty of a four-game match
that is time to take risks if it was
just a two-game match neither side
really wants to push forward and neither
side wants to kind of gamble but uh even
if something goes wrong for white hair
for example Hikaru will have three more
games to strike back I really like this
format and okay the game is alive
there's only been a trade of one set of
nights so far the other white knight is
coming back to replace uh it's departed
counter its departed fellow there on F3
and black still needs to Castle Wesley
so needs to get his King to safety needs
to get his Bishop out of the center at
some time uh sometime soon before it
gets trapped and it's very balanced I've
got to say I like Black's position it's
solid but still plenty ahead plenty
ahead and not just on the Hikaru Wesley
matchup we are about to kick off
vladislav our tummy have starting with
the white pieces against Fabiano caruana
I am not expecting a Berlin in this one
Robert
um or an auntie Berlin you know I wasn't
gonna expect it either because Artemis
doesn't play E4 so that'd be hard to get
to the Berlin but understand what you're
saying the spirit of the question is
that these two will fight for artemia I
think giving away the white pieces that
would not be very bright and for Fabiano
he loves the game of chess he always
plays I don't I can't think of a single
short draw he's made unless it's the end
of a term that secures him first place I
can't think of casual short draws yeah
he's one of the most fighting players at
the top level there Fabi for sure uh he
likes I mean he loves chess in general
he just loves to play he loves the heat
of the battle and he actually goes out
of his way to avoid those uh quick draws
more often than not I will mention last
time I played altamif when I was black
he played white the Berlin against me
and uh it was a draw
occasionally he dabbles but uh not
regularly instead it's the symmetrical
English and it's the four nights
variation I'll tell me I'm opening
things up black will most likely push
his E Pawn there we go and very
theoretical stuff this was an old
favorite of Magnus back in the day a few
years back with the white pieces it
started with this Queen spawn position
starting with one Knight F3 but it's
kind of transposed into a sicilian
structure absolutely this looks just
like some type of Sicilian here I'm a
big fan of these type of positions from
the white side almost some Roxy bind
type but the night uh Bishop E3 could
maybe be hit with some Knight G4
sometimes even though it's hanging there
you still can take on D4 right but this
should be three there's also Knight C6
threats there's all kinds of things
there so you can also try to go Knight
B3 and even go a weird G4 right Knight
B3 anytime you have these Sicilian type
positions with the Knight on F6 and you
have the clamp on D5 you are able to go
G4 and try to you know obviously hit
them hit the Knight there but you do
also can play in the maroxy buying
fashion by playing F3 Bishop B2 and
getting the bishop outside the pawn
chain or Bishop of G5 I mean and Bishop
F4 and castling uh king size sometimes
weirdly enough even Queen side it's very
aggressive but actually you're they
would never get D5 off if Black's able
to get D5 often a lot of times white has
actually failed in these structures
because you uh you bind it up with E4
and C E4 and they play D5 anyway that is
a concession or you actually are in
trouble sometimes if they're allowed to
play D5 with black yeah I think we will
see the structure you're right James uh
if I'm not mistaken this is one of the
most uh principled moves uh I guess you
could also take on this square but that
does transpose into another variation
where white would be a Tempo down so a
bit of a rare one as far as I know from
Fabiana karawana bringing his Bishop to
this square or maybe not the most kind
of typical at least and already that has
caused artemia to think at this early
stage yeah and as someone who's worked
with Fabian on the past I won't give
away too many of his Secrets but what he
has publicly said in broadcasting during
the World Championship 2021 he said that
sometimes he looks for what the computer
would say is the third best move because
then his opponents don't expect it so he
is caught artemian by surprise I like
the opening choices combative and
Fabiano's reputation precedes him people
are afraid of his preparation what he
did to Maxine vashir lagrav in the
Cannons tournament when Maxine was in
first place at halftime they came back
and fabulous showed like 25 moves of
preparation and blew him off the board
frankly so I think that you know that is
scary for people and I'll tell you he
said oh I just wanted to win a match he
beat Magnus he was Smiley but he is
taking this seriously and he is
seriously not you know going to be in
time trouble because he doesn't know
what to do right now and he had a lot of
problem with the clock in his match
against Magnus on day one he needs to
make sure that is not a repeat he's
already down by more than three minutes
on the clock really nice inside there
Robert what you said third best line of
the engine not to go for what is most
topical because in these formats David
it's often about asking and posing the
most practical questions to your
opponent those slight Novelties that
forces them to think out of the opening
to burn their clock yeah yeah time is
money and if you gain a few minutes on
the clock then uh who cares if you've
played the top move or the second choice
move uh often having a few minutes extra
is worth that small sacrifice and look
at this the White Knight drops back very
logical very normal move and Fabi
immediately with the big threats lining
up the black queen with its dark Square
Bishop hitting that white F2 Pawn
suddenly some big threats on the board
Artemis his heart rate is going to be
racing he's already facing some massive
threats as white and normally as white
you're happy to just kind of ease your
way into the game you normally get a
space Advantage push it to the middle
game here he's struggling to survive
already and four minutes down uh
interesting strategy by Fabi there will
be ways for white to defend I should
mention but it's not obvious you can't
rely on kind of automatic chess here you
can't rely on instincts it's pure
calculation and I'll tell you outside
his comfort zone he does not like direct
play like this one early in the game
yeah it's a very annoying move Queen to
B6 is direct it hits F2 and it stops you
from really moving the bishop because
Queen takes B2 Knight A4 you can't
actually play I mean you could try it
Knight A4 but the problem is the Knight
on C2 blocks the square so after Bishop
F2 and then King E2 I can play Queen A5
or sorry yeah Queen A5 it's not check
but Queen A5 I take the Knight you take
the bishop right so you have to like
play something strange here for instance
actually on the light board Queen D2 was
played but that blocks the bishop in now
so now you have to go Bishop B2 castle
and you do have to take some time to
actually develop this dark Square Bishop
later by even moving the queen or
playing B3 and Bishop B2 so we kind of
in a way wasted a Tempo where we cannot
get this bishop we have to make an extra
move to get the bishop out or uh on the
contrary if we would have played Knight
to B3 that would actually hit the bishop
with Tempo giving us uh more time time
being the tempo to be uh to be able to
do more things in our position wow and
uh I was just going to ask James last
move what would have happened if the
Black Knight had jumped in to continue
pressuring the F2 Pawn Fabi says no he
just gets castled instead uh not asking
any more direct questions but now this
surprises me because I thought it was
possible to bring the white knight to A4
with a double attack with a fork and the
computer hasn't a reacted the evaluation
bar hasn't moved so this can't be a
blunder by Fabi but what must the idea
be here 94 Knight E4 this gets crazy
isn't Knight takes Pawn I don't think
this quite works because Knight takes
Queen Knight takes Queen it looks level
but the Rook is hanging in the corner
white does pick up this rook and uh wins
material it must be in this position to
move the bishop to B4 but oh wow wow
this is crazy stuff this must be
Fabiano's opening preparation I like
your reaction because it seems like
black just hands weight the pair of
Bishops but what black gets in return is
activity you'll notice the black king is
already castle if we just go through
line Knight takes B6 Bishop takes D2 is
check you can't take the rook in the
corner you have to deal with this bishop
you take it then black takes the Knight
on B6 and now Black's Pawn structure
double isolated pawns however King
safely castled Pawn on e4 is threatened
The Rook on 8 with an open file and
black will strike with D5 next exploding
the center of the board while white King
still sits there that means that the
king could be in some danger just
because Queens are trained it does not
mean your king is going to be safe
permanently and I think that this is
what fabi's relying on wow this is so
deep and I think you're completely
correct there Robert this is what he has
in mind uh Fabiano but look at the clock
time he's asking this question to answer
me if he's saying yes you can go for
this but you know that I'm prepared you
know that I've studied this with a
computer and that is scary and
personally I don't see what else
ultimate can even try to do maybe he can
move his bishop and try to get castled
but go for the bishop pair get the
Queens off the board it's the safest
it's the most logical it's the most
principled and uh yeah the game will go
on but as Robert says black very very
active there and yeah I worry for
Artemis chances I'll tell me against
Magnus it's kind of a perfect style as
we saw yesterday because his strengths
of match magnets and strengths those end
games that kind of strategy strategic
play but automatic against Fabi he lacks
the openings there to compete he lacks
uh he lacks the dynamism that Fabi has
and the line we mentioned on the board
wow counter-attacking chess already and
Fabi just kind of flexing there did you
see what he put on his shoulder as well
was it some kind of like blanket some
kind of uh a few moments ago he looked
very very cozy in that secret lab chair
but uh very comfortable too clock that
clock he's down to eight minutes fabi's
Barely Used any time so far this is
going to really tell and our tummy have
hasn't yet finished his development is
white in trouble already in this one
feels like there should be a way to just
get those Queens off the end game that
Robert mentioned yes it looks a bit
scary but you should be able to hold
that one and we will find out I think
it's scary on the clock more than it is
on the board it definitely looks like an
Armageddon game where it's kind of uh
I'll tell you have his bid seven minutes
42 but yeah he started with 15 and he's
just burned all of it and uh what's he
thinking about here maybe King takes
Bishop get that King active in the end
game Queens are off the board what a
move that would be bro stop okay yeah
it's just one of those positions where
you trust fabula king take D2 is too
enterprising we appreciate it as fans of
chaz's commenters but against a strong
player like Fabiana car one like nah my
king should be in a more natural place
but we kind of expect this and artemia
burned a lot of clock to get here look
at it 500 was more than double the time
of his opponent and at this point I
guess I'm asking you guys all right do
you think the five to start thinking do
I not just equalize would play for more
I think he's gonna get excited the more
the clock ticks down for our tummy Fabby
he's missed ambitious right Robert you
worked with him he wants to beat
everyone he wants to win every game uh
like you said he avoids the quick draws
because he's so confident and he loves
the fight oh and uh Chad is saying I'm
calling it now Vlad is going to bring a
big upset while he's already done it
once the biggest upset of the tournament
so far he did knock Magnus into the
loser's bracket is he is he going to
pull off another big one against Fabiano
that is the big question it looks like a
pretty level start let's head back to
our Hikaru versus uh to our Hikaru match
up with Wesley and there we have it wow
it was an auntie Berlin but if this was
the position that we saw David one
wouldn't believe this started as an
auntie Berlin yeah it looks like a
reverse filador or some reverse Spanish
type of opening but uh yeah crazy this
Pawn structure I like White's kind of
queen side it looks like a little heart
or a little I don't know what that
structure is called on the queen side
but uh either way I can't uh I can't
criticize Wesley's position too much as
black he's got the center he's very
solid it's got all his pieces out where
do you see the heart and Black's
position in White's position I don't
know with the pawns but I'm just seeing
these pretty patterns and getting
carried away uh these players of course
calculating moves and roughly balanced
on the clock compared to the other game
uh that's good signs yeah the primary is
there's so many captures there's moves
you can make into ABCs you can do B5 you
can do cd5 you can do ed5 you can go F4
like there's lots of moves here you're
gonna go see like there's just too many
things here I think what James is saying
let me translate for a second is uh
takes takes takes okay
and then we win a juicer in the end I
bet you didn't uh see this one coming
Knight C1 James that's not a capture
wow what is the ID oh Bishop A4 maybe
and the Knight swing around that is
Crafty he always finds some crafty moves
yeah sneaky guy Hikaru Nakamura uh
really creative will oh await uh the
reason for that mysterious Retreat yeah
your pieces bringing them to a better
square but Robert what is the better
Square for that night is it heading to
G3 or C3 yeah usually carbo had good
positions when he made this kind of
Maneuvers and I'm just being honest I
think black's position is much better
here I think Wesley has the better
position out of the opening look his
Rooks are connected his Queen is more
active his Dark Sword Bishop is
attacking a pawn that white Stark Square
Bishop is defending White's light Square
Bishop is stuck behind pawns it's kind
of like a big pause sitting back there
so I feel like Wesley's position is
better that said hikar's position
remains solid the foundation of it is
strong but I feel like Wesley should be
thrilled about the opening and he's just
about even on the clock
yeah what would he call it rotating his
nights he's rotating it around three and
uh maybe it has uh more life there on a
better circuit but yeah Wesley it feels
like the time to strike might be in the
next couple of moves uh just before
Hikaru is able to rotate his pieces
around and kind of uh consolidate get a
grip on the center for example or maybe
go for those exchanges that James was
mentioning but uh Wesley spent around a
minute and a half now I'm expecting
something big from him here not sure
exactly what it is I don't see an
immediate breakthrough but it feels like
now is the moment to kind of uh at least
ask questions of Hikaru normally when
you see your opponent Retreat you go
forward so I wouldn't be surprised if
Wesley so pushes forward in the center
now I actually completely understand uh
the nice C1 move now of course lots of
times here um uh the positional play
from Jacob Agar that is unchecible by
the way but you can also get the horror
copy Grandmaster preparation positional
players three questions to ask what's
the weakness in the position what's the
worst place piece and what's your
opponent's idea so of course having the
three questions there what's the worst
place piece if you go back fact the
night was disgusting oh my goodness you
don't have a square right so it makes
sense even if you take on B6 you still
have no squares if you take on D5 you
still have no Square so he says this
Knight is the worst place piece so he
moves it to C1 to reroute it and you can
do this type of maneuver due to the
nature of the pawn structure because
it's closed it's a closed position so
having close positions mean you can make
lots of Maneuvers like what he's trying
to do right now problem is I think after
92 you may actually have some problems
with the E4 Pawn so you have to do
something there first and then move the
Knight but Wesley has a very nice
position because all of his pieces are
developed he doesn't have any really
worse place pieces really right now so
he actually is doing a little bit better
even though the engine says actually
probably slightly better for black I
mean like point four three maybe and
maybe even zeros here right now but
black is a little bit for Choice here
but definitely understand the move from
Hikaru here but his pieces definitely
need to get you know active in the next
few moves here he needs to get active
and he starts by shifting his Queen up
one square just keeping all the pawns
nice and defended
um and it's really hard to find a
productive plan it's easy to see moves I
was going to say just uh one move
threats such as this one it's easy to
spot those one move threats but to find
a kind of uh comprehensive plan is more
of a challenge and wow Wesley attacked
the White Queen and Hikaru felt
compelled to block with the pawn Wesley
steps back so he's actually lost two
moves but he's created some weaknesses
in the white Camp look at the dark
squares around the white king now those
might be uh really vulnerable really
weak long term imagine a knight or
Bishop landing on those squares
especially the G3 square and uh yeah
interesting that Wesley's willing to
invest a couple of moves on that one I
like it right because the bishop was
taking away the nice jump now the H5
score is accessible for the Knight and
F6 and when the Knight jumps to the rim
it's heading right back in F4 and G3
these weak dark squares are explodable
for black to take advantage of so I
think that Wesley he just tried to
provoke a weakness that position is
closed so there's a couple Tempe there
it didn't make a big difference and for
akaru that night that went back to C1 it
can't move forward the queen is in its
Square the pawn still sits on D3 I like
the way that Wesley is managing his
clock and the position but at some point
soon a car is going to lash out and
Wesley needs to be looking out for that
yeah I agree with Robert I think the
last few moves by Wesley super
impressive just taking it slow provoking
some more weaknesses forcing Hikaru to
take a little bit more time on the clock
it's always harder in these formats to
be on the defense and find moves rather
than the one who's got a more pleasant
position and that is Wesley's strategy
here but coming to the point that where
is the big breakthrough David does
Wesley have more quiet moves just simply
improving the position he might have
more quiet moves available but I'm also
thinking about the player's Styles
Hikaru he's very resourceful he'll make
quick Snappy decisions Wesley he's
actually nearly two minutes behind on
the clock because he doesn't like these
slow maneuvering positions as much as
some at the top of World Chess Wesley
likes Clarity where it's a clear plan
maybe it's a very simple position where
he can uh kind of play with no risk he
can ask questions and if the opponents
answer them draw is fine but uh Wesley
here it's very very tense and his nerves
will they hold up we've seen uh hit he
um wisely play games with heart rate
monitors on and his heart rate gets very
high when the position is very tense and
look at what hikara is doing no Clarity
here just keeping the tension and lining
up his Bishop with the black queen oh
yeah some questions though can't really
push that pawn with that Queen and which
is why Wesley falls back with the queen
how critical James do you think the
clock situation will be in this round
one well it's definitely critical when
you're playing Hikaru Nakamura you are
either one of the fastest one of the
greatest on the planet when it comes to
speed chess when you get in time trouble
that's almost an ale just it's very it's
just you can count on him being very
good in all time formats and if you get
lower and lower and lower on time you're
gonna feel that and even Wesley
mentioned that yesterday he was like
yeah I was down a lot of time I see a
small head shake from Wesley they're not
even sure what that was about what he
was thinking about but he is getting
lower on time and that is going to
affect it and car was going to sense
that like I'm up time and you smell
blood in the water as a shark or a half
man half whatever he is you know what I
mean like he's gonna do his thing right
when you down time he's going to make
things happen yeah and that's kind of
forced Wesley's hand to take a decision
in the center Robert are you happy with
Wesley's decision of how to fix
structure I'm not unhappy but I think if
I'm a car I'm happy so not that a car is
better in this position but at least his
Knight can jump forward that pawn was in
its path uh White has more plans in this
position I actually think it's quite a
level game and Wesley decides to go back
instead of forward he just wants to keep
his foundation solid I can't blame him
he's the black piece he's a draw is a
good result but Hikaru I mean he is
showing that he's willing to fight even
it gives him a shaky position and he
almost better than anyone on the planet
not named Magus Carlson is able to make
it look like oh what was the issue I'm
fine right now and if you're not careful
he might play for more especially given
his time Edge
yeah meanwhile both sides maneuvering I
really like what Wesley's done he's
going to bring his Knight into E6 and
maybe into the center uh I do however
feel that that two minute Advantage
gives Hikaru a small Edge uh long term
it looks like the other game is fizzling
out slightly we mentioned that Fabi came
armed with that great opening
preparation but Artemis has found a way
to shut that game down good practical
play uh from him so we might have to
check in on that one before it finishes
let's do it now let's take a look on the
other game it looks like this one will
be finishing soon all the action is on
the Wesley Hikaru board but is this just
a draw or is there something to play for
while the pawns are getting traded yep
we're hoovering we're vacuuming those
pieces
the only question is Hoover vacuum you
beat me to it sorry Robert
yeah this is as drawish as you will get
wow that was an illegal movement
hey that's a glitch that's a glitch
a big move and gets up and leaves and
with that draw we are left with one game
in round one of our winners bracket and
things are really heating up on this one
Rooks have been doubled up on the a file
how big is that a threat for black
big threat white threatened simply to
capture on B6 opening the line for those
two white Rooks and at the moment black
can't deal with that tension you need to
commit maybe you need even need to run
away with that black rook in the corner
simply two are better than one and that
black Rook has to be the first one to
evacuate the a file now if we do see a
Trader pawns the white Rooks will have
access to some really nice squares
they'll have complete domination of an
open Line there we go and white trucks
look nice but if they do Advance now
they might get traded off so Hikaru just
needs to figure out whether there's
anything else productive to do right now
quite level I think you need to uh keep
improving your position like what pieces
are bad and we improve them but it's
kind of hard to like I mean the B4 Pawn
is hanging if you go Bishop E3 or move
the queen you're going to lose the B4
Pawn maybe just Rook A7 but then he's
happy to trade you know maybe with a
rook B7 right immediately and the trade
but maybe then we could mile move the
bishop to E3 and try to go maybe Queen
B1 and A2 but then he goes Rook A8 so I
mean he's going to be he's comfortable I
think Wesley's very comfortable here now
we both have terrible y-square Bishops
like the bishop on G6 like what is that
and the bishop on B3 is like yeah I'm
the same bro like look at us like right
terrible Bishops right so it's quite
level here I think and Wesley's doing
fine but if that clock gets lower it
then that that's when Hikaru comes up
with more tricks and and then you can
have some problems
yeah uh no problems right now but
potentially later on as you mentioned
that James uh if I were Hikaru I just
want to keep the tension I'm not sure
how maybe to move the uh White dark
Square Bishop just Shuffle it to C3 I'm
not sure try and improve the light
squared Bishop again not sure how it's
not clear what the moves are it's not
clear what the plans are but if you can
keep your time Advantage then that will
count later this game will likely
explode at some point having a having an
extra minute might be decisive and if
the board opens up that's probably bad
news for white because white has some
holes on the king side those dark
squares in front of the white king are
blacks for the taking especially if you
could throw that pawn on E5 that King's
Point thrown off the board get out of
there the bishop on D6 will open up so
Knight D4 is a legitimate idea for black
sometimes even if it costs you a pawn
you make a move like that just to get
the E5 Pawn out of the way so I'm
actually looking at this position I
think that Wesley does have some chances
if a car does not start trading off
pieces so he played his Rook up to A7 I
like that choice for Macaro it's not
worth taking huge risks in game one
yep and uh okay he does vacuum off those
Rooks and he does get rid of those
pieces and uh okay what now he's freed
up his Bishop to move potentially but
still looking very very balanced the
more pieces that disappear the more
likely uh this game is going to be equal
but uh okay the clocks as well balancing
out this is good news for Wesley so yeah
the time advantages Hoover as well
I have a feeling that will be a
recurring theme uh in this match
specifically uh lots of hoovering
and uh yeah looking very balanced I
think her courage is struggling for a
plan because there is none uh or at
least nothing that makes a great
impression and okay he lines up his
Bishops but that's purely defensive
guard uh guarding against Robert's idea
of jumping in with that black knight to
D4 he is I'm that E5 pawn and we've been
talking about a potential break in this
position for white or for black which
all the pawn breaks that are possible
and wow we've got one on the board on
cue but hey Karu says none of that
happening the position completely
blocked but this does give black the
access to jump on with the Knight to D4
how dangerous would that be rather it is
very natural look at Black's play
hopping a knight forward cementing the
control let's go with the pawns the
white Bishop went back to D1 it's just
being very defensive and passive and I
wouldn't be surprised if Wesley decides
to strike we talk about how he is so
solid
two squares he only went one square but
I this might be a good choice in the
long run the C4 Pawn is a bit of a
vulnerability and he's going to try to
retreat his Bishop back on the light
Square as an attacker it's happening
it's happening you call it the only way
to defend it with the Rook it advances
to the fourth fourth rank defends that
C4 Square James you mentioned it the
black Bishop the light squared Bishop is
dead but Wesley's Bishop is now quite a
powerful piece attacking the only
weakness in White's position absolutely
I mean a black right now is definitely
for choice I mean you don't want to take
this Knight on D4 I mean you're just
going to open up things you have lots of
dark Square weaknesses around the king
here the bishop on D1 I mean what is
that I mean if you take it off the board
it's the same position right so you know
it's a very bad Bishop especially with
his counterpart there and you know in
these type of positions Wesley is very
very good here I mean he's even beat the
Hikaru before in the CDC chess Global
Championship right so these positions I
mean are are difficult and the time is
getting a little bit closer here yes
Wesley's down on time but I mean pieces
are coming off and as Pieces come off
the board here and the hope maybe he's
able to hold this might be a draw
because might end up being a draw
shuffling here if you can't make
anything happen yeah but the last few
moves it just looks like a Carlo is gone
on a bit of a defense Robert yeah it
does seem that way I think that uh kind
of I'm still
contemplating that moment where Wesley
pushed his F Pawn one square instead of
two I think Hikaru surely would have
pushed it to open up the board and
Wesley he might be using the Mantra you
draw with black and try to win with
white that's what these top players do
and so I think Wesley he went into this
game Thinking let me try to draw he's
still in that mindset but he could have
taken uh some chances there and played
for more than just a draw yeah we've
seen it countless times in the past
against these top players if you don't
take your opportunities to attack you
might not get any opportunities in
future again and uh Wesley switching out
of that mindset has maybe been the one
thing that stopped him throughout his
career from really elevating up to uh
kind of take take out the likes of
Magnus Carlson on a consistent basis and
yeah just being happy to draw is great
but to win to progress to beat Nakamura
he needs more and I don't see him
switching out of this mentality now he's
just waiting look at his last moves
Wesley just shuffling his Bishop around
shuffling the other Bishop around
waiting waiting waiting if he doesn't go
for it sometime soon I think the rest of
the match he will be regressing that
opportunity and Hikaru I'm not saying
that his position is fine now I still
really prefer Black's position feels
like whiteness with that terrible Bishop
on D1 it's a bit stuck but the question
is can Wesley break through one minute
down on the clock he needs to get the
black queen active how is he going to do
that okay first more shuffling oh yeah
this is actually a great idea here I'm I
definitely understand he wants to go
Queen F7 at some point but Queen F7 was
uh always hit with Knight B6 back around
the D5 so he wanted to put the bishop on
C7 which he did then he went bishop d8
and he's going to play Queen F7 but
that's why uh with Bishop C3 so you can
put the Knight on B2 because the bishop
was on B2 at first I think it was on B2
but um Knight B2 and he's just gonna sit
there and I think that's probably going
to be a repetition from there or like a
knight B2 and then just Shuffle pieces
because literally white has nothing else
to do and there's nothing to attack man
unless someone to make some type of
break like F5 or F4 that's the only
thing that we have at this point yeah
for example just to show your idea that
James the queen will come across hitting
this Pawn the White Knight will be
forced back into passivity to defend it
and the question is can Wesley break out
can he open up some lines you need Pawn
breaks you need these levers to open
lines for your pieces I do like this
idea for black the bishop could somehow
come out now from this diagonal Robert
highlighted the G3 Square earlier on it
could sit on the Square trapping that
white king but uh of course every Pawn
break comes with risks and it depends on
whether Wesley so is willing to break
with this Pawn push in the near future
first however he's trying to get the
black queen to a more active post uh he
tries to bring it to the open file and
white plugs that with his Bishop first
he's pushing some points Harry the H
Pawn making an appearance Harry
my voice
[Laughter]
I'm gonna get you back for that
I was expecting that honestly I I
appreciate it but I think this H5 move
is his idea to continue pushing the pawn
off the board that's a big question and
hikara says I don't want to fall victim
to an attack over there I'm gonna move
my king towards the center we might see
a petrogen King march where you Castle
the one side and run to the other but
speaking of running to the other side
Wesley brings his Queen over and watch
out that Queen may lead in the way black
can keep pushing pause the kings of G5
and F5 and all your pawns to go forward
so maybe Wesley did the right thing he
shut everything down and now he's the
only one who could press forward the
side that controls the pawn breaks is
off the side with the advantage here
Wesley definitely has the edge yeah just
don't repeat just don't go back with the
queen 287 Wesley he can push in this
position just a little more he pushed
yeah he pushed he literally pushed the
pawn H4 on the board no repetition
vesely so making his intentions clear he
wants to play this out till the end it
is about getting that F5 break he's
timing it to a point Hikaru has the
least amount of time on the clock to
counter it precisely and I think David
it's going to come down to that F5 when
it's played yep F5 and will white
survive that's the big question you
can't play it yet White's bishop and
queen are lined up on that diagonal but
that pawn break that we highlighted a
few moments ago black will eventually
aim for it first Wesley's gonna Shuffle
around tease his opponent and keep
Hikaru guessing when is it going to come
when is it going to come look at that
white Bishop it's so sad that piece that
light Square Bishop that's just stepped
back but it's purely defensive right now
lined up behind the queen just in case
the position opens the first Wesley
massaging this Advantage sneaking in
with the black queen potentially look at
it
wow big threats potentially of some
sacrifices
Queen F1
gotta just chill that's kind of annoying
there it is and then Bishop E1 is the
idea look at her car repairing into his
screen that he was like wait have I
blended no I'm fine not bad yeah no and
Bishop he won next for uh White bring
that dark Square Bishop back next to the
queen to kick the black queen out of
there so I feel like a car is doing
everything correct at the moment Wesley
did not strike with that five he may not
get a chance to and you have to watch
out because black has some weaknesses in
his position as well that pawn on B6 it
looks like it's nothing's attacking it
but later in the game that could be a
problem so Hikaru he's doing a good job
of playing defense let's point this out
right here look at the camera what does
that say back there on let's put the
back what did I say look at that yeah
possible championships
I mean that's beautiful wow look at that
that's crazy I love how I call you out
for calculation not being over
everything but you support me this is a
good friendship I like how this works
it's a bull masters
wow that's beautiful yeah and uh okay
Hikaru plugging those holes with his
Bishops uh I must say there's no one
better I think in chess history he's
done Hikaru when it comes to defending
but now Wesley is getting ready to
strike he's preparing that move you
mentioned dying it's gonna happen on the
board any moment Knight D1 has been
played Wesley preparing all his pieces
for that F5 break does he do it now yes
if you've got to do it play it fast but
he decides not to
do oh he hasn't made a decision yet
it's on the board and that means Wesley
is going for the win all out for the win
now and Hikaru backs to the wall
defensive chess I just praised his
defensive skills but he's gonna need
every ounce of them here look how he's
just rotated all his pieces to the
background he's just retreated
everything this is backs to the
wheelchairs park the bus chest pocket in
front of your goal and your opponent
can't score past you but uh it needs to
be done and where's Wesley's
breakthrough yeah but Wesley could bring
his Queen to the the first rank as well
all the pieces on the first Rank and
there are a lot of pins here pieces are
hanging I'm not sure if the mouse say
anything we see the evaluation bar
suggesting that it can't be that much
better for black but look at him take
control of all the squares white has no
activity he does bring his Knight
forward but that B6 Pawn I mentioned
earlier watch out because that is the
one target that white can go after
um White Knight can also plant itself
maybe in the center of the board kind of
mirror the actions of the Black Knight
later on and while the Queen's jumped in
dived into White's camp and what is the
threat I didn't see it yet but oh hey to
trade Knights
well the nitrate benefit white is the
defensive task feels like this must be
good for black must be good for Wesley
so but 30 seconds on the clock Hikaru is
so resourceful such a tenacious Defender
and the Knights are off oh this is not
good this looks like the worst is all it
is over for Hikaru and we're just 30
seconds left this is going to be tough
what amazing play by Wesley and he's
still pushing but if the Queens are
created is that essentially a draw for
it should be yeah absolutely too blocked
if the Queen's come off he doesn't do it
yeah nice play by Wesley so I really
like what uh hikara has done just over
the last few moves he's covered
everything every week Square in his Camp
has been covered now he's simply going
to start attacking that black queen with
his dark Square Bishop kick her out or
maybe offer a queen trade you need to
get those Queens off at some point yeah
the big prompt for black there are no
more piece that can jump into the
position the Knight that was in D4 was
so strong now we're seeing a repetition
and that's a fair time to do so this
position is completely locked up any
decision to trade pawns for example E4
is probably a bad one for black there's
just nowhere to go so I think that this
draw is imminent and it was a
hard-fought game and I think everybody
everyone at home should be happy about
that they did not make their quick
Berlin draw they really fought and
Hikaru he was the one who needed to show
starting defense he did demonstrate just
that oh did he just refuse a repetition
17 seconds what's going on is he playing
on the clock wow is Hikari gonna switch
attack now and just try to flag and is
he going to try and trick Wesley it
feels like he should be the one playing
for the draw but suddenly getting
ambitious Hikaru Nakamura and uh he will
move his Bishop most likely the Queens
will come off but at least he's trying
at least he's putting that fear into
Wesley so he gives that headshake I
think he's just gonna come back with the
bishop yeah there's nothing I mean you
have no where do you try in this
position
[Laughter]
well now the Queens have to come off so
there they go and that means no progress
for either side yep totally blocked here
uh White will just uh at some point
start centralizing his king that's the
worst piece for white and this one
should be a draw Wesley still the only
one who can break he's the only one who
can try and play but it feels like
there's no way through and uh yeah white
pretty much has a fortress
draw incoming
that was shocking he just moved his King
away from the defense of the pawn for no
reason he's playing too quickly he's
fortunate the eval bar suggests it's
still even it's because he's more
activity but wow that could have been a
huge blunder look how focused Hikaru is
right now he realizes it's a golden
opportunity handed to him on a plate and
uh okay the black King's coming in
attacking some pawns but uh Hikaru can't
cover everything and yeah that's way too
it should be six feathers like a mate
but that's G5 luckily nearly Checkmate
living a Charmed lifestyle way too
active yeah you might have to just trade
I mean because if you have King G3 too I
mean like this is a bishop D4 check King
G3 I mean then like who's winning you
know be careful here so there's a
definitely uh he blundered that but I
mean that's crazy how active his King
ladies playing on Hikaru with under 10
seconds on the clock a moment ago he's
allowing the black thing in wow this is
playing for fire for both sides it's
real but Hikaru is taking risk his
Bishop is trapped that white dark Square
Bishop okay Wesley's repeating the
position yeah will we finally see that
draw I think Wesley's had enough
excitement Bishop F6 he refuses the
repetition what on Earth is going on wow
maybe he's just trying to zigzag and
give away that Tempo and then now we can
go kingji through if he wants I don't
think he's crashing through but maybe he
look at him he's trying to win this game
is there a place
that pawn shop was a blunder but now
suddenly Wesley has all the initiative
in a queenless position but this should
be the third time the position has
repeated Bishop D4 check is a drawn well
I can't believe it because this actually
feels like history repeating itself do
you remember in the air things Masters
they were playing and the car was like
because he realized he blundered in that
Queen and pawn end game and so gifting
your opponent still doesn't lose the
game apparently I don't know how these
super jams do it wow Wesley again
rejects the draw his opponent down
doesn't he can't he count it
the phone down but he's keeping the game
going he's hoping to trap that white dot
Square Bishop he's coming the whole way
round but this feels risky I don't think
you should get too greedy if if you're
not careful the white Central Pool might
step forward and break your coordination
look at this the bishop always finding
squares that's a nasty check and uh
Wesley the win with only 10 seconds left
against it right who is this who is it
Wesley yeah but he has to watch out
because that's why both his kingdom this
Square white was trying to push that
extra Pawn forward to distract the dark
Square Bishop so King has to remain in
this kind of territory and Wesley he
doesn't have a problem yet but if he
keeps this game going too long and he's
the one in time travel that's where
mistakes occur yeah this is such a cat
and mouse game it's just hard to imagine
and hard to think who is playing for a
win now
shuffling around with the bishop but
there's no progress to be made they're
just playing with each other's nerves
right now just uh teasing each other
testing each other and we will see a
repetition surely oh that black Bishop
coming back around attacking some pawns
this should be E2 yeah is that dark
Squad Bishop that white has manages to
find a way to attack the B6 spawn it's
game over so black has to make sure that
the bishop remains trapped on the king
side an offer of Trades by giving back
the pawn I think it's smart by Westie it
might have still been a draw but he says
I know that I have a fortress so let me
just go back to that and they're just
look at this they're almost a move 100
in Wesley Hikaru language that's like 20
games
at least and uh still this position
hasn't changed too much in the that last
30 40 moves for both sides asking these
little questions asking setting traps
and neither side has fallen taken the
baits so far surely we'll see that draw
surely we'll see that repetition but
yeah packed full of content this game
that's for sure that was just not dry I
was just not a draw right now grind it
out grind like a grand master Ryan right
that's right that's to get that course
that's a chessable course that is
accessible course with Magnus and David
in fact I didn't get it went to sleep a
little bit because it is like it's like
in game stuff but of course when you
wake up you know you are oh you're gonna
learn how to grind right yeah that's
what this is so everyone's taste but
that's how the top Grand Masters uh
squeeze out their results they're so
well balanced these two great warriors
and uh sometimes they just need to rely
on testing the opponent like this and
Karu reacting the game is over it seems
like they've made either a 50 move rule
or they I think they repeated the
position three times from all sorts of
directions but the game has finished it
is a draw it feels like a fair result a
fair result and what a fight that
streams either the 14 move Berlin draw
or a hundred move fight David take it
away yeah we saw that end game that was
so blocked even after a porn blunder
Wesley so was able to hold the draw but
I want to rewind all the way back to the
middle game where Wesley if he was
feeling slightly more aggressive could
have struck and I think Hikaru would
have been struggling here he could have
been on the back foot and it was this
move he moved his Pawn but it was only
one square foot he pushed it forward to
F6 and the game entered a maneuvering
phase and Hikaru held his own instead if
Wesley had been uh feeling brave
attacking now with F5 I think was
extremely strong the problem here for
Hikaru is you can't really hold your
structure together if you capture this
Pawn The Black Queen jumps out into the
position there will be ideas of throwing
this Pawn forward next some attacks
against the white king potentially and
it's all about this Black Knight the
best piece in the game giving black the
advantage a missed opportunity because
Wesley wasn't brave enough
I could even stop waving the anger he
kept trying but when the moment really
mattered and not getting that F5 move in
but what a fight and with that let's
take a look at our results of the
Winner's bracket just down one game wow
that game felt like we've played through
I don't know how many games it didn't
feel like a one game uh match there and
we've got a tie on both these matchups a
draw in the Fabi zlata slab as well as
the Hikaru Wesley but such big fights
and with that right before we move into
our second game we will take a shot
twitch break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what amazing action we've had and one of
the players who's been on fire in the
chessable Masters is Fabiano caruana
he's had such great performances the
last few months including the bronze
medal win at the world rapid
championship and of course winning
division two off the essence Masters two
punches stick it into the chasseable
Masters let's take a closer look at Fabi
speaking of that that deep after the
world championship match what happened
after that 2018 match well after the
match I felt very confident I had a
decent 2019 I think like I I tied for
first in the PD Grand Swiss with Wang
Hao and that was an event with with
Magnus and with Hikaru and with
basically all the best players in the
world level and so on and so 2019 I
wasn't unhappy uh 2020 started very very
well I won Vikings day with um plus
seven results and that was one of my
highest ratings that I achieved 2014
2018 and 2020 were the highest ratings I
achieved I was like 28 40 or so I forget
exactly so so I was definitely at like a
very good level at 2020 but after uh
things got kind of shaken apart by covid
my results did to have a dip from from
that point forward
UE improved quite a lot on your rapid
and Blitz chess for the past couple of
years why did you do differently to get
to that point there was a period when I
had some some better wrapping list
results I didn't like put much weight
into it I didn't care so much and not
that I didn't care like when I was
losing I was very upset somehow I didn't
take it seriously before the event and
didn't know exactly how to prepare
myself
so yeah now I take it more seriously but
it's already been many many years since
I've had like
I've had some some bad results I had a
match against Magnus where everything
went wrong and I got completely wiped
out obviously I have some bad results
and we're having Blitz but for the most
part my results are pretty much on par
now my glittering is so much higher than
my classical rating I don't it's like
almost 100 points higher
I'm almost like now I want to get my
classical rating up more it matters much
more to me normal chest work will
hopefully get me back there I think
things are a bit more difficult now
because everyone got stronger that's my
feeling at least that a lot of people
especially young guys got very strong so
you don't you don't really have any
tournaments where you have some like
easier games you know I I'm playing like
17 year olds and they're not only are
they very strong and calculated well and
they're discipline but they also have
fully fledged opening repertoires and
they're
it's things have changed quite a bit
especially opening wise that people are
just like super well prepared and I very
often feel like I'm on the back foot
against these guys
chess wise still want to qualify for the
Kansas now qualify for the World
Championship
would be the ultimate goal and
you know last time was was a strange
cycle
obviously five years ago already it's
been since I I played the world
championship so the goal is to try to
get back there it's it's very difficult
it's always been difficult but it's I
think getting even more difficult
because now we have the you know
established guys who are very good and
the young guys were also very good so we
have even more competition
[Music]
in the world the 2018 World Championship
challenge look at that profile he is
defeated candidates winner of the 2018.
and what's been amazing about fabi's
progress over the last few years Robert
just the work that he's put into faster
speed formats and that's what he
mentioned in the video that he's put in
some real work to improve his rapid and
Blitz he was perhaps the most criticized
player in the world when it came to
quicker time controls he lost the rapid
to Magnus Carlsen for the 2018 World
Championship title everyone said oh this
guy can't play faster chess what did he
do raise his feed a blitz rating over
2800 winning some important rapping and
Blitz events he's showing that he's up
there with the best of them I mean he's
working on his game but not only that of
course a mind and body I'm a big fan of
that and actually also uh the chess
players Army if you Google Fitness and
chess I recommend you do that at home
fitness and chess actually it's a huge
correlation right he's now working out
more I saw him with the grabbing a
little weight off the thing trying to
get his little squats on I'll help him
out with that of course get help your
squat form poppy but at the same time
right that man's working and you can see
it in his game yeah it's so impressive
just the level of professionalism that
he has in his early 20s he burst onto
the scene I remember in St Louis winning
seven out of seven in 2014 in the single
cup but he had that youthful energy now
he's a bit older as James says he's is
working in order to continue maintaining
that high level of form Fitness stamina
everything and uh yeah it's paying off
with his results here yeah 100 he also
had a smooth win against Liam it went
into the Armageddon but Fabby pretty
much dominated on day one in that match
today is a very tough battle as he does
face our Tamia our tamiyab is also on
fire he's a man on a mission in the
chessable Masters yeah artemium is
fantastic people may not be as familiar
with him as there are some of the other
players but he beat Magus Carlson in the
world rapid Championship he then beat
him yesterday here in the chesswell
Masters and in game one he didn't really
get anything as far you know Stellar
preparation from carwana but for artemia
he's happy to be here and he's a threat
to anybody
our teammate is extremely scary I mean
he took out Magnus right and he's also
very very strong his rat what is that
28-70 or something like that he was
basically close to Magnus by 30 points
or so right it's insane how strong our
Timmy have is but also Fabi with the
preparation and the calculation of
course calculation over everything is a
human calculator right in a way Fabian
is very good with that but he's
definitely up for a challenge with our
Timmy especially in this form he's in
right now yeah and that first game it
might have been a draw but this Clash of
styles guarantees action and I think
we're going to see it in this next game
we're going to see Fabi with the white
pieces if he can unleash prep like he
did in the last game watch out or tell
me if right watch out our time here but
our channel has been so impressive
especially the way he took down a Magnus
on a day one we will get to the action
in division one very soon but action is
on in division three wow Robert what
stands out to you here well me and tap
it to buy it
from Uzbekistan the Olympia Champions
these two are super strong they may not
have the name recognition that some of
the others do but they make their way up
to the winners bracket finals and down
the losers bracket you've got Wei Yi
Mama jar bluebound and when these are
superstars in their own right and that's
the losers bracket of the third division
unbelievable what kind of strength is
this at the chessable Masters it feels
like an elite tournament just this
bracket yeah they don't need a workout
they're already super strong so James
you can help a lot of people out they
don't need it right now no unite they
don't need it right now of course they
are absolutely pushing out of their mind
right now great chest for them yeah and
the clock is sticking the players are
ready we will have liftoff for round two
the winners bracket Fabiano caruana
takes on the white pieces against
vladislavartame Wesley so what's this
after that Marathon game one how
important will stamina be in this well
Fabiano's been working out we sell it on
video but he doesn't need the stamina
right now it's the others and I think
actually sometimes it's hard to wait
before a game so for Fabiano and artemia
they need to stay in game shape whereas
for Wesley in the car there was a lot of
jockeying back and forth but I think
they're ready for the next game so
Wesley and nicaro feeling the floor
there James absolutely what Wesley and
Carl I mean they 46 48 draws I mean 100
draws like that's what it feels like of
course so many games they already know
each other they're gonna have to bring
something different to make something
worker or something shake for somebody
to get some type of event this year or
less you know maybe they take some draws
go to Armageddon right and then that's
Hikaru favorite there so maybe that
could be match strategy as well
you should be starting any moment and
David what is the opening that you're
expecting from Fabi oh from Fabi uh this
one I'm expecting to Berlin you heard
it was an obvious answer from Fabi I'm
expecting him to start with one E4 he
can play Everything of course he's well
prepared Robert knows his repertoire
better than me probably but uh I'm
expecting him to be very direct because
artemia does try and duck and dive and
Dodge and dip and all those things but
uh yeah he does tend to have a bit of a
soft Center if the opponents go very
direct against him that's why atomific
classical chess maybe never ascended the
heights it's uh yeah this one
first moves are about to start any
moment Robert I love the answer from
patches of howl hand over here so I'm
waiting for the first move it seems like
the clocks are going but the boys are
not yeah we'll uh we'll make sure we're
up to date on that but uh the players
are making moves we will get the board
updated but it's early stages with these
two they've played so many times before
and we're gonna get I'm sure a familiar
gameplay from these two Monsters of the
game they meet at the highest level
everywhere I have a theory it's been a
Berlin the clocks are on but the board
is so disgusted doesn't you want to show
it and Hikari doesn't look too amused
either it looked like he was making the
pieces levitate his arms were just kind
of at his side and this is the position
we have so um yeah this is the position
right now and uh it came from the
Italian not the Berlin but very similar
uh type of position so we'll watch it on
this board for now and we'll get things
sorted soon but yeah looking very
balanced we've actually seen these two
face off in this exact line this exact
variation plenty of times before
including in the air things Masters a
couple of months ago where things were
drawn the games were drawn but uh very
strategic style of play I'm happy to see
a non-berlin position in Italian by
Wesley because it's clear that he knows
he needs to make the most of his white
pieces when he's playing a beast like
Hikaru you can't just rely on the
Armageddon you can't just go draw and
I'm gonna bet all my chances in that
Armageddon it hasn't worked out in the
past so Wesley there trying to maximize
with the white pieces but it's Hikaru
who strikes in the center how dangerous
is the D5 break Robert well D5 is
typical right we just saw Wesley try to
do something similar when he had the
black pieces and you just need space and
this move D5 it doesn't actually
threaten all that much White's pawns are
defended but it's kind of a tale of two
Bishops the dark Square Bishop for each
side and here we see five little caruana
and vladis overtime E4 played by car one
not surprising he mostly plays E4 he
does dabble with other openings but
actually E5 from artemia that's a bit of
a surprise to me pretty easy play he
doesn't play Carol Khan you know he
plays a bit of everything but I didn't
think he would go so Mainline against
Favi wow in the Berlin will we see that
Berlin draw I think not we might see the
Berlin end game from Fabiano he has been
known to crack that one from time to
time uh what is he feeling like wow it's
a pawn sacrifice a very trendy topical
move maybe asking her tell me if whether
he studied his theory we were surprised
that Tim F went for the Berlin he's not
a habitual Berlin player he normally
goes for something else so here he needs
to know his stuff I've faced this a few
times myself recently it's actually very
dangerous if black isn't familiar with
all the ins and outs all the details you
need to get that black king to safety
soon it's still stuck in the center and
it's a clear Target for white pieces so
you're reporting up as black but you
need to be fast often you need to give
back the pawn in order to complete
development well fabi's prep is out of
this world some of the greatest prep
you've ever seen I mean it took a whole
year and uh to you know um with the with
the candidates and beat MBL and that
night or finder was crazy with the t-sac
so here same thing with our Timmy I mean
he was mentioning it's like oh he needs
to know it he does not know it he's just
sitting here thinking and trying to
figure this out and we already know our
Timmy does has a little bit of a problem
with the time trouble he even mentioned
that himself in the interview yesterday
so this I mean I've never seen this upon
sacrifice either I'm not even going to
lie here so what is actually black
supposed to do here yeah as far as I
know black should actually just bite the
bullet and take that white Pawn in the
center but he did not do it doesn't go
for it it does look maybe a bit too
brave to actually open lines for that
white Rook but uh now this black pawn
that has advanced it's holding things
together it's blocking lines but it will
fall at some point and I'll tell me I
think he just needs to rush get that
Bishop moving get that black king to
safety you know who plays his line is
none of the Daniel narodeski Daniel
loves this type of position and it is a
pawn sacrifice but I think as we're
highlighting that black should probably
just say I don't need the extra material
I want my king to be safe there is a
castled king for white a rook staring
down the middle of the board and that
pawn is pinned for the time being it
likely will be won by white and then
maybe black says okay as long as my king
gets safe I will be equal in that
position so I think for our team he
doesn't mind spending time in the early
stage of the game he just does not want
a blunder yeah what's he even thinking
about here it looks almost automatic
just move your Bishop break the pin the
White Knight now is finally attacked and
uh when it moves for example jumps into
the center you are safe to Castle this
is maybe the most sensible way to play
is he really considering uh maybe
ponderboard okay it's on the board I was
gonna say is he gonna consider pushing
his Pawn forward and uh trying to cling
on for dear life to that one nope he
plays the most sensible approach of
course Very solid uh play and now whoops
not that one I'm expecting him to Castle
and uh the game will go on uh often
white will win this Pawn back white will
bring the Knight out at this point might
fall but that will just lead to a
symmetrical position
that this is what I'm expecting I'll
tell me if tanking though in the opening
I've seen so many near-dizzy games in
Blitz in this exact variation and so for
Fabiano he's doing what we've said he is
playing an offbeat opening not the main
line maybe not in the second most common
line he's trying to get our team of on
his own he wants artemiev to be working
it out with his brain where Fabi can
still rely on some of his pregame
preparation it's working to Perfection
right now both games Fabiano has had a
sizeable lead on the clock the first
game was for equality here he would like
to play for more West Daniel bring him
in bring him in covering division three
right now oh yeah he is yeah yeah
definitely check out the action in
division three Daniel narditski will be
covering that on his twitch Channel but
the action is also on in our other game
let's bring it up with Wesley Seoul
white pieces against Hikaru Nakamura
that D5 move
Wesley's still having a thing hasn't
really decided what to do in the center
which pawns to trade this is a critical
moment for white yeah we left this game
four and a half minutes ago and Wesley's
been thinking for four and a half
minutes he hasn't moved he hasn't
reacted I think he just needs to
maintain the tension maintain the status
quo I was about to say move your queen
out the way avoid any potential coin
trades on the D file and uh here you're
throwing the move back to nakamuri or
throwing the question back to him how do
you improve your pieces the central
tension it's not clear how white was
going to clarify it so you asked black
the question you take but only on my
terms under Hikaru looking up now to the
side that normally means either he's
trying to recall what his opening notes
say or he's surprised by his opponent's
move and he's thinking oh you can't get
away with that I'm going to punish you
and um yeah I'm not as good as Danny
reading hikaru's faces but uh he's
surprised by this last move from Wesley
and there are two main options right
from hikara's point of view he could
lock the position up in the center by
pushing his d-pawn forward or he can
capture in one of those pawns I'm not
sure what he should do but you know
Hikari he just leaned in he's
calculating and he's trying to figure
out not just this one turn but the
direction of the game is closing the
center good for him because oftentimes
if someone's going to attack you you
want to strike in the center but what
attack is there going to be both Knights
you look at the Knights there are mirror
images of one another right but for
white and for black same situation White
Knight trying to go to F5 the Black
Knight might go into F4 but what's the
difference the F5 square is light the F4
square is dark white has a dark Square
Bishop that can kick a knight that jumps
into F4 so white has the ability to boot
that Knight out of there of course the
E5 Pawn would hang immediately in some
of these positions as well but just
knowing that for the long term yeah it's
a big moment here as the players decide
what pawn structures to take often in
chess we speak of critical moments which
is why Hikaru is taking his time here
critical moments are not just about
calculation and tactics but also
decisive moments that do Define the
nature of the middle game and Hikaru
takes a very committed decision he fixes
the pawn structure he moves that pawn
forward the bishop on A7 that kind of
kills his own Bishop David do you
approve uh in one word no Tanya I'm
gonna trust Hikaru he understands these
positions much better than me but uh
it's not what I would have done uh I'll
just say that the black Bishop as you
mentioned very very unhappy by that
decision and also as Robert alluded to
the Black Knights if they ever jump into
the white half of the board will be
kicked away will be traded off by
White's Bishop whitesnites but the same
can't be said if White Knight jumps into
F5 and I don't F5 will Thrive that's the
rhyme and I wouldn't be surprised to see
that one land at some point soon still
balanced I don't think it changes the
evaluation objectively but in terms of
the nature of the position maybe Hikaru
is playing against Wesley because he
noticed that Wesley did spend a lot of
time in the last game because it was so
blocked uh he's hoping maybe the clock
Factor might be an issue later Wesley
already down four minutes and uh in
these slow maneuvering phases maybe
he'll burn even more of that remaining
time
yet to be seen yeah definitely uh
because you have to figure out how
you're going to get the bishop active
where are you going to put you want to
ideally think about okay where are these
pieces going to go Bishop A3 I like I
was also a fan of Bishop C12 as well and
then Knight F5 and almost I mean just
setting up just hinting that I may sack
on H6 um but Bishop A3 is is totally
fine too as well but the bishop is uh
very bad on A7 look at it he looks a
little surprised by that move obviously
taking on C6 liquidating the queen side
but what's so surprising about that why
does he have that expression I think he
just didn't think it was coming but it
makes a lot of sense if black takes with
the Rook then that B7 Pawn becomes a
Target if black takes with a pawn well
then the B file is open so he decides to
keep the B file closed for the time
being I like the look of Rook to B1 I
don't look at this position and think
that black has any sort of Advantage but
the engine obviously stronger than I am
saying black is better wow I'm surprised
too I'm gonna say Robert does look
familiar this Pawn structure it looks
very similar to a benko Gambit where uh
White actually accepts the Gambit and
gives the pawn back and it might be
because in this position Black's next
move is going to be to try and trade off
these Bishops for example if white takes
a timeout maybe a silly move actually
I'll give white a useful move just to
have the argument's sake but the bishop
is going to come to C5 if we ever see a
trade this Knight might be the best
piece on the board it is attacking this
backward Pawn it's keeping white pieces
on us tied down to this a pawn as well
watch out for this Black Knight to
re-maneuver itself as well into a nice
Outpost later so I think he's playing by
analogy Nakamura this Pawn structure
actually happens with reverse colors in
the benko in the benoni and those types
of openings and he knows that if he gets
a knight to this beautiful C5 Square he
will have the advantage and actually
this position is on the board I don't
know if Wesley should actually trade off
these pieces maybe he needs to step back
and keep these pieces on the board just
because a Black Knight on the Square
would be too scary to deal with
and uh yeah it's very strategic here
these players they're both so good they
never go for each other I notice though
it's always kind of playing for playing
finishes here and there uh playing for
these tiny little incremental gains
so they do lead to these fascinating
kind of maneuvering battles yeah
positional fights between Wesley and
Carl that's exactly what we saw in game
one also just a little bit
it's our 100 move Marathon but they're
definitely in the moo in the mood for a
big fight Bishop trades have been
offered that F5 Square for the night
still up for grabs what are we expecting
in this one the one thing that person is
to watch out for though is that clock
James seven and a half minutes he's
burning too much time it's almost double
the time I mean of course we talked
about this before and I was in these
fast time controls I mean he car was
always a favorite second to him
literally no one in fact I mean Magnus
can obviously keep up there you know and
even he beat him in the speed test
Championship right uh he covered it
right so it's very important to
understand when you get long time you
have to use your time or your clock as a
piece here and if you're not able to do
that or you mismanage it you're going to
get in time trouble and actually Hikaru
will just Blitz you you're gonna make a
mistake for instance last game he
dropped a pawn got a long time it was
still good his King was active but he
did drop upon due to time trouble so he
needs to watch that time and manage the
time a little bit better and a headshake
from Wesley there what's that about
David yeah he's just not enjoying life
not enjoying his position enjoying life
it's hard when you're facing Hikaru
every time the Beast uh himself and look
at that white Rook that white Rook on B5
it looks like it's entrenched in the
black half on a nice Outpost but it's
stuck it's completely trapped and you
could imagine some fine day one of the
Black Knights coming around to attack
and when in that white Rook uh that
black knight I mentioned on C5 maybe the
most important piece as well and white
is just a bit stuck the best you can
note for is to trade off maybe black
start Square Bishop for your own Bishop
but as we mentioned earlier in that
earlier variation
actually suits Hikaru and I will as well
just record the American Cup where these
two faced off recently Hikaru took the
win because Wesley was the slower player
and he decided to lash out in the final
game of that one blundering his Queen in
one move just because he thought okay I
might as well go down fighting uh rather
than lose on time lose uh in Armageddon
and that was the decided it's small
margins but it feels like hikaru's
nerves are slightly stronger and he's
slightly quicker and I think once he has
to lash out here because his Rook is
trapped on B5 his Rook on B1 not really
doing anything I think you start pushing
his pawns on the king side he needs to
break free from the position because
right now everything is locked up I
don't see a plan for him except for
pushing those pawns forward but we know
that if you push pause they don't move
backwards and you may uh regret it in
the future so I just don't love the look
of this for Wesley oliverson at first I
was surprised that the evil barge black
a nod but now I'm looking at the car
does have a slight Edge
the Knight on C5 is such a monstrous
piece just tying down white screen to
defend the D3 Pawn you're talking about
lashing out here but where is the big
break for Wesley how does he really
build the counter play on the king side
good question right James Maybe
it's the idea to push this Pawn forward
move this Knight out the way for example
if the Black Knight moves uh actually
bad Square sorry let's move to this one
the White Knight can move out the way
and at some point later on you could
hope to push the spawn forward Again
Play played by analogy with the king's
Indian but it does feel very very loose
this white king will also uh have
something to say about that it will have
questions to answer in the future if you
do open it up so you go for the black
king but at the cost of weakening your
own King very difficult I've got to say
maybe you just kind of in the game
position start stepping forward with
this pawn put a clamp on and hope that
long term you might have some activity
over there just kind of consolidate your
night on this beautiful square but this
night alone won't do the work it won't
do enough and it's just very difficult
this position very mysterious look at
Wesley's clock time as well oh man under
six minutes you're not looking good
there a clock time is serious here and I
mean I even like uh I mean Pro it's just
hard to find a plan for a white here I
mean you want to play some maybe even
like if if the Rook wasn't on C6 you
have things like King H1 or even talking
going King F1 King E2 Rook G1 G 4g5 of
course this is a nice plan the reason
why we go to E2 is because it's actually
really safe here because the center is
really locked down you also you know the
queen isn't very you know you don't want
that defending the pawn on D3 for
forever you want to actually use the
queen and if you can but the queen is
just stuck here on C2 you have to defend
D3 so maybe moving the king over to E2
playing Rook G1 and G4 and going for
something but the Rook is doing a great
job on a six rank of any type of
sacrifices or allowing anything to
happen even if we get G5 in I could even
go Rook G6 myself and kind of just
neutralize your attack so it is quite
difficult to find anything for white
yeah
Black Rock
ing that you're saying and I'm
sad that is going to be trapped for a
long time and one can actually imagine
Wesley getting into big trouble just
losing that Rook David yeah
yeah stuck Behind Enemy Lines and he's
trying to get it out now by trading off
those Bishops in Hikaru he's asking
himself look how interested he is in
this one moment he's asking himself can
I leave my Bishop on this Square can I
leave that white Rook trapped on B5 can
the Black Knight start coming in for
example at some point towards it but
okay what is he calculating that's his
calculation face James you're the expert
on calculation yeah you know what's
funny actually believe it or not there's
actually a study I've read this you can
read this actually looking away actually
improves you actually can calculate a
little bit better from doing it so
actually in tournaments I do this I
actually do this you might look at me
strange but at least I'm gonna beat you
on the board because I calculate it
right so of course it actually when he
does this you know I graduated from a
school of Hikaru I draw the arrows I
even look up when I'm eating food
calculator yep absolutely it works every
time works every time I do it when I
usually just blunder a piece where I'm
like oh God please save me right now it
doesn't work
okay at least the Bishops have been
traded off and another trade has been
offered The Rook is coming back yeah no
it looks like Wesley's trying to trade
everything off and this is good game
management he was worse if he didn't
start trading pieces now they're coming
off at frankaru a draw with the black
pieces that's a pretty decent result but
for Wesley given the position he was in
this is good decision making I think
that he understood how much risk there
was for him his position was that awful
so he's just saying give me some space
let's trade and now it should be a
neutral one trade everything off Robert
don't you mean Hoover everything off
yeah you're right it's I think it's just
simply a necessary decision here you
need to get at least one set of nights
off the board you're cramped if you look
at the central structure Black's
actually got the furthest Advanced Pawn
hence more space and uh when you're
struggling when you're cramped take
those pieces off the board Hoover them
off and uh
vacuum vacuum them off if you have to
and uh yeah this one should be safe
enough I still slightly prefer blacks
pieces uh Black's position I've got to
say but we're sleep doing what he needs
to do a small trick as well we should
mention in the current position uh
Nakamura here is calculating whether he
can take this Pawn okay he hasn't gone
for this but uh if he had captured this
Pawn the White Knight would have jumped
out the way capturing a pawn itself and
after it's taken this Knight would have
fallen and actually this changing
structure would have helped white so uh
Nakamura here instead just pushes his
Pawn the reason he did this was to push
this Pawn next Gary the G Pawn will
follow Harry and uh it will kick out
whoops sorry my arrows it will kick out
this knight from F5
so G6 coming next to evict the White
Knight
on the camera it just looks like it'll
be such a nightmare to play against him
OTB because he's so intimidating with
his expressions and body language you
just don't know what to expect from him
he's always such a tricky player on the
board off the board we see this move H5
just threatening building an attack on
the king side the G Pawn might March
forward the Knight will come to F4 we
will check in with this in just a short
bit but let's rush over to the other
game Fabiano caruana takes on a
vladislav or Tamia their first game has
ended in a draw an uneventful result but
it was quite a fight Fabi is up against
vladislav
and while we bring that up a decision
has been made by Wesley to retreat with
the Knight and Robert I see that
expression you are surprised
um the Eva went really far down there so
you know maybe the fact that we're still
in this game is a good thing because it
is sinking and I wonder why because I
look at this position Knight G3 are
attacking a pawn but can black suddenly
maybe take the a pawn over there is that
the point you take one Rook Pawn I take
the other but that trait should help
black there is a past Pawn in the making
The Rook on A8 is behind that past Pawn
so the Knight jumps forward into C3
that's an issue and I see tactically why
this is a problem for white in the
previous position why I could play
Knight takes D4 this Knight Gets Out The
Way of the queen and then after uh the
Knight takes back on D4 you keep trading
everything and the queen finally takes
on A4 at long last but because white
retreated that knight from F5 it gives
black a tactical shot and now Hikaru can
take advantage wow is that just another
blunder in one by Wesley dropping upon
David yes simply he's forgotten that
Knight takes D4 is not available now
because after the night recaptures you
don't have your knight able to cover the
D4 Square as Robert mentions and yes you
can take this Knight but your Rook Falls
at the very end of this variation no
compensation here for white and game
over and Hikaru has definitely noticed
this look at his facial expressions over
the last couple of minutes he's
calculating this he's just thinking
Wesley you must have a trick up your
sleeve otherwise I'm just winning you
can't take this Pawn what is your idea
if you move your Rook across maybe this
is what Wesley's got up his sleeve
trying to attack the Knight attack the
pawn behind it but again the Black
Knight just jumps in and even if there's
a rook exchange yes you're happy to go
for this and after the move Rook A6 this
Rook is trapped you have to agree to
this exchange and Robert's Point again
comes into Focus this past Pawn is going
to win the game long term Knights are
super bad at stopping these Corner pawns
these Rook spawns and this Pawn is going
to decide things so Hikaru by pure
calculation by Brute Force here can work
it out every move is forced and it is
winning for black you just ignore this
Pawn on the edge of the board ignore or
that threat just capture that's the more
important Point Hikaru should be winning
yeah no he's going to go for it he
doesn't miss these opportunities he has
the unique ability to just have such
precise calculation in a short amount of
time and not shy away from tactics
resourcefulness I'm expecting Knight A4
any moment and with Wesley down to four
minutes how difficult James will it be
for him to find counter play in that
this is why he blundered in the first
place is because of the time trouble
right as soon as that time gets low it's
just I mean anyone can be substituted to
this even it even happened to Magnus
when he lost and played that Rook B6 or
Timmy evmu game was over he was in time
trouble in fact I mean actually or to me
I have four seconds too but also he was
getting low times too so it's important
to understand when that time gets low
like he's just start moving fast I don't
want to get lower on time let me move
real quick Knight G3 oh blunder right
immediate move here and of course uh
Knight A4 is definitely on top here but
I wonder what else he's thinking about
here because he hasn't played it yet
yeah I think he's just trying to weigh
up that variation uh that we saw with
all of the Rooks coming off the board
and we should also mention at the bottom
of your screen you can see the computer
top suggestions everything else would
miss the opportunity lose the advantage
and it would go back to being a level
game so he needs to capitalize now this
is the moment of this game he needs to
take that point he does it it doesn't
miss this stuff 94 he's calculated it
all and we will be coming to the
variation that David showed us Wesley
immediately goes for the A5 point but
after all that Skirmish it looks like
Hikaru will be the one on top
he will be what could be more natural
just jump in with the Black Knight to a
beautiful outpost on the C3 Square the
line we showed and that should lead to
an advantage Hikaru meanwhile he's got
that Evil Genius look I'm just uh
wondering how should I uh play with my
food here how should I progress but uh
we see the Jedi here with James but I
actually you point out his look made me
think of something he could of course
jump in with today Four Knights and C3
but he might bring the other Knight to
C5 to defend his Knights that way he's
removing one of the attackers on his
past Pawn so I really thought that
Knight C3 that was a foregone conclusion
he would jump forward but he could bring
his other Knight into C5 defending one
night with the other and yeah the eval
Bar says Robert you're a fool but I
actually think once if you trade Knights
there then black does have this outside
pass Pawn so it's something that he has
to consider here white will take the H5
Pawn but that Rook Pawn is way less
important than the queen side one
yeah I agree from a human point of view
this still looks like a fantastic
Advantage
um yes you can take this Pawn but uh the
black Rook is always going to guard
across I don't think there'll ever be
threats against the black king and it
will all be about this passer so I
wouldn't be surprised if he goes for
this but nope he goes for the other one
instead just as strong uh if if not more
so and uh there we go all the Rooks are
coming off the board and this is the key
moment he needs to bring his Rook across
and he has done eliminate the remaining
Rooks trade on your terms and at this
point is surely going to decide this
game
yeah Wesley maybe he missed the sting in
the tail this final move of the
variation he'd calculated all of this
but underestimated this Rook slide from
Hikaru and uh here we go temporarily a
H well I was going to say a pawn up is
it level material now uh but that black
apron so dangerous Wesley stepping back
to try and trade off Knights
do we agree take that night or do we
keep them on the board I mean I have to
move it somewhere strange which is like
I don't really want to go Knight A4 I
feel like I'm giving him something
specially maybe after Queen A2 like
Temple I'm a big fan of the tempo I
worked with coaches before about that
was like I'm just I love the tempo and
I'm like oh cool I didn't I love it too
right so so I mean a strong player tell
you something you're gonna listen so all
right cool perfect you love the tempo
well I'ma love fall in love with it too
92 is Timbo so 92 is a movie A5 just
gave it back while Eva didn't like it
either I love it though he's loving it
yep well he's going with Pawn quality is
more important than Pawn quantity so
he's actually giving uh Wesley a pawn in
an unexpected Way Wesley could have
taken that Rook Pawn that clearly wasn't
valuable but this Pawn does feel a
little bit more important in the
position so if white takes on C3 black
has to take back the queen could step up
and capture the black a pawn goes up one
square hits the Knight and we are seeing
this variation but when the Knight moves
away black has carved up the D4 Square
for his own Knight that Apon is a force
but white has a pass Pawn of his own and
that's why you see the Evo react to
Knight D4 why you start pushing the pawn
distract Black's pieces and then white
is going to take that passer that black
has established that's deep that's a
very brave decision by Hikaru just
sacrifice a pawn went very well you
could have kept a material balance
traded the knights and then looked for a
way to advance the a pawn he's going for
blood in this one yeah he really is and
this whole variation has played out on
the board if the Queens come off white
has an extra Pawn but I have a feeling
that black porn will win the day that
black apron will tie down white tonight
completely and it should be decisive but
uh meanwhile Hikaru activates the black
queen he's actually giving up another
Pawn that other black porn in the center
he's not materialistic at all he's
saying please
he's saying please go take my point if
the White Queen now gets greedy and
takes that black Central Pawn wow I
think we're gonna see a pin that black
queen is going to jump down to the first
rank that white knight might be gone in
the near future he loves the initiative
he's happy to sacrifice that Bond it's
all about the a pawn three squares away
from queening combined with the queen on
B1 the Knight jumping to D4 that will be
a tough one to save and we see the eval
bar despite Wesley being up on material
it loves zakaru's position this is
dangerous
terms as well two minutes down on the
clock white is on the back foot yes you
report up but you're defending I don't
like Wesley's chances you can't take
that second Pawn either they're taking
the pawn on E5 is losing I think by
force because Black's Pawn is way way
way too fast I keep saying it's about
the quality
but here even with A3 for black and the
point is if you try to bring your queen
back to C3 The Black Queen goes to B2
typically when you're down material you
don't trade but here trading wins for
black because you cannot stop the past
pawn and your Knight's under attack so
you kind of have to do something about
everything and I just don't think Wes
can get it done yeah it's just a new
Queen appearing on the board and uh
simply no way to stop it so Hikaru right
now maybe there are multiple strong
moves uh this is one of the most natural
maybe you can bring your queen down the
whole way I think this is uh just a
beautiful position for Hikaru he's
looking for other options clearly but as
Robert points out this is the most
natural Pusher pass Pawn follow the
rules and you're gonna make a new Queen
don't think Wesley's going to be able to
stop it Hikaru spending his remaining
time trying to figure out uh the most
accurate path to Victory now he knows
he's winning he must do oh shim baby
and is this just completely busted he
goes Queen B5 so Wesley did think of how
to continue after A3 and Hikaru says I'm
not trading Queen before he says wait
what kind of a move was that was that
the reaction that we just saw he said
what what he's just like criticizing
Wesley's play he's doing analysis while
he's playing and he's doing it for the
fans you know how a card does he's the
big chess streamer but right now I mean
is there a way out for Wesley doesn't
look like it that pass Pawn is too
dangerous the Knight and C1 is a flimsy
Defender here so I do think that Wesley
is going to go down yeah wow big moment
here but we will come back because our
Tammy have is playing on second scan
Fabiano caruana win and take the lead in
his game Let's jump straight into
Fabiano versus vladislav or Tamia huge
time advantage to Fabi here wow huge
time Advantage something we're used to
saying at this point I'll tell me if
just too slow his position is almost
fine it looks Rock Solid he does have
the bishop pair I slightly prefer white
here just because you have more space in
the center White's pieces are more
centralized than their counterparts but
uh yeah the clock factor is the biggest
difference right now uh can Fabi turn
that into Victory though another
question
James I'm definitely picking Fabi
especially when I'm with you I mean when
you get our team you have to make Emmy
he usually sits very calm like he is
right now but I feel if you know if we
roll the tape back he was looking he
actually did a little head shaking away
a little head Bob like you see that when
you can get that reaction out of
somebody to just be magnets with a
straight face right here it's a it's
already a win here the prep is working
and he's up so much time now of course
our Timmy have already has time in
trouble uh time trouble anyway here but
I mean white has the better pieces right
now yeah we have the bishop here but
better pieces more time this is uh
looking bad for our tomato right now
well Fabi will try to grind out the
clock on this one but Hikaru is grinding
down the position against Wesley so
we're going to jump straight back into
that game because that is heating up and
should what that Fawn on E3 oh my God
but is there a way to just finish this
off immediately you might resign uh
Wesley in the next couple of moves okay
he brings his Queen back he needed to do
this there was a huge threat of black
screen actually coming all the way into
the corner to A1 and pin that white
knight now the White Queen is back able
to defend just about but uh I think
Robert's idea from earlier bringing the
black queen to B2 that's a beautiful
Square you're completely paralyze
White's pieces and then the Black Knight
will be able to rejoin the action
White's dream here is to give up his
Knight for that Blackboard but I don't
think Hikaru is going to cash in anytime
soon he can wait that black pawn is way
more valuable than the poor White Knight
here and if white gets that if white is
able to give the knife for a pawn Wade
will have three pawns for a night that's
actually even material and well the eval
bar is you know go back and forth a
little bit Quincy to the most natural
move Wesleyan timetable he has to play
quickly and if the move A2 is played
then the White Queen could take it black
will take the Knight so we get that
trade so just what David has been
highlighting that it's likely in some
positions that white will be able to
sacrifice the knife for the pawn and
give him some chances yeah but is that
the best option because he get his
Knight into the game jumping back to E6
and D4 and asking more questions to
Wesley when he's down to just 50 seconds
on the clock
it's good to meet Tanya what could be
more natural just to put the other one
on the board if the pawn does step
forward as Robert mentions white would
love to eliminate it you can maybe wait
one more move but uh this position maybe
the three pawns can at least hold for a
while instead uh here Nakamura he didn't
get his Knight into the game yet he
offered a queen trade White had to avoid
that as we showed earlier and now this
Black Knight is coming into the center
it's gonna sit pretty nice and pretty on
D4 and totally dominate the white Army
white is paralyzed could barely move uh
look at this poor White Knight it's
stuck defending the A2 Square the White
Queen is stuck defending that night and
uh I think it's good night here for
Wesley so he's such a nasty threat
Knight D4 for black and then Knight E2
like even if there's no Forks or any of
that like you can put your king
somewhere else so I'm not giving you a
fork Knight E2 I think still works you
take my knight I push my Pawn I get a
new Queen deflection that's best wow
this is how strong Corner pawns are
against Knights simply nothing to do and
that night is coming in and uh Wesley
holding off uh just delaying the
inevitable here the night's coming and
uh as Robert also alluded to uh if for
example the Knight jumps in if you're
not careful if you move your queen
there's also Queen takes Knight as a
tactic and a nasty Fork to win the day
yeah this one's over the night is coming
in to get the win as they say James
you've been saying Hikaru is your boy
half half man half beast half everything
else what is that everything else and
how is he this strong okay well I mean
he's half man and other half we just
don't know what it is yet but at the
same time he's very strong especially
when you get low on time it's a wrap
like a lot of times I mean you would
just count it I mean unless you're like
winning you up some material you've got
the clear plan there's very few people
on the planet Magnus even included that
when you get long time against against
icaro I mean it's really bad it's really
hard he's very accurate he creates
problems for you I mean even in the game
with uh for the sale like I had three
extra I had three pawns how
how did I make it through right it's
just it's insane almost a magician like
of course Robert
rubber with the tactinos hey guys I hear
you okay he better not be hearing me
that would be a big problem but no I
mean 92 it was a long way coming the
night jumped from f8 E60 for E2 and then
White Knight is distraction and now the
black pawn will promote and Wesley does
have a knight and will be three pawns
for a queen now that should be
completely losing but stranger things
have happened especially if you can win
a fourth Pawn maybe there's some outside
chance to survive super unlikely but I'm
just saying Wesley he's not being too
crazy to play on what a poker face from
Wesley I mean I would be crying my eyes
out here but he looks uh
that's mean yeah that's mean
and finally promotes are expecting
wrestling to resign or get flagged but
resting wow Knight H5 the game continues
three queens on the board but the queen
can always fall back no Perpetual there
and with that we see Hikaru he knows
he's done it what a big win by him and
honestly a fantastic game there yeah you
want to hear something else that we
didn't make mention of Wesley actually
offered a car a draw at some point in
the game and the card declined it so he
was playing for a win he understood he
had the better chances he maximized them
now he's a one-game lead
actor with the black beast is he starts
the next game where the white piece is
Wesley has to win to level the match
there is action still on in Fabi versus
James he's down to 10 seconds oh yeah
you know what's funny I mean yes he gets
in time trouble it's almost like grishek
in a way like he gets stronger as the
time gets lower because I mean he beat
Magnus with four seconds on the clock I
mean that was like oh he's gonna fly and
he was like how you thought so right
then he actually did the same thing in
that other game to eliminate Magnus when
he had like he was about to flag oh he's
flying then he made it him so when he
gets you know you got to be careful Here
and Now Fabi is the one actually getting
in time trouble he had a five minute
lead right now of course he is doing
well here but Bobby actually is the one
that usually uh kind of like has the
less experience in the lower time
controls here like that this low you see
as the email bar is going down here more
mistakes usually you'll see from Fabi
than our Timmy have in this time uh in
this time like the time that we're set
right now the lower the time gets that's
actually a great point that against a
player like our time you have you can't
stop playing on the clock he's just so
strong even when he plays on the second
but the position is getting crazier
David Black's King is it in any danger I
see that night on 86 I'd be scared yeah
I'd be scared for the black king first
of all but I'd also be slightly scared
foreign that white knight entrenched on
H6 could actually be trapped long term
so you've got to be careful yes you're
attacking but if the attack Fizzles out
then you might be in trouble and uh it
definitely feels like Fabi had more
control a few moves ago he's lost some
of that control now but he's going all
out for that black king threatening some
nasty stuff we see a porn trade here
like a ship her as well if the Queens
disappear
whoa okay both sides moving very very
quickly here we're looking for tactics
we're looking for checks captures and
threats James if I had a five is it does
it work or no 9-5 takes Queen H6
no checks approach King G8 I feel like
in this position yeah he's gonna trade
but you really want to keep more peace
on the board if you're Fabiano but he
just brings his Knight back to Satan
David he's taking your advice and well
what attack does white have anymore in
fact black might have the upper hand
White Pond might be in some trouble yeah
if that black knight wasn't so stupid
over there on B7 then black would
definitely have the advantage but here
Fabi he does have coordination between
his scissors the queen of knights oh
okay dropping back here what a move just
hanging D6 but you could take on G4 I'm
telling you it's scary when he's in time
trouble like this he just gets stronger
when the time gets lower yeah you're
completely right James Bobby how is he
going to go for it I was going to say
how do you go for the attack you're
retreating this is the wrong direction
for Fabiana caruana Black's pieces are
coming forward it looks like great great
winning chances now for vladislav I'll
tell me a nice classy move the black
king super safe the white king is the
one that needs to watch out trading
Queens as you mentioned if the Queens
are off the board White's the one who's
going to be super happy but does he
allow the H Pawn he says yes my knights
in the center are going to be really
strong does this end game favor white no
it favors black because look at White's
Queen side pawns all on light squares
sitting ducks in many variations when
the Black Bishop gets involved so look
at this Knight of five check now the
Knight is going to deform a check
picking off some of those pawns yeah you
can even keep the black a pawn if you
want you can push that black a point
even further down the board he gives a
check first crazy just looks beautiful
for black I've got to say he starts
munching on those pawns maybe it's more
slip but he's going after that white
Central Pawn and uh everything's falling
apart for Fabiano he's having he's
actually low on the clock right now wow
everything's dropping the pawns are
falling I'm telling you when he is when
he gets when the time gets lower our
teammate gets her they need to start him
at a minute let's start him at a minute
okay that's how artemiev gets his
chances and we the time gets low and he
just turns up everything goes crazy he
plays better just like Grisham does it's
very strange very strong players here
they can play on this time controller in
this time pressure like this no time on
the clock and was able I mean it feels
like he's about to take down Fabiano
another Central pawns are moving officer
trade has to to be captured but I see
that valmar says that the worst is over
now for Fabian that's a big blunder he
allowed this H Pawn to stay alive that
black Corner Pawn watch out they're so
strong against these Knights and while
he's coming in for those pawns that's
tough there's two white pawns are doomed
on the queen side stop cemented on light
squares that's a life Bishop had me said
it doesn't matter what he moves because
those pawns are falling and
unfortunately for Fabiano it looks like
artemia I mean the guy is just ice cold
when he has no time in the clock James
you've been calling from the beginning
and he's really scored up I mean it's
crazy it's literally like he gets lower
and he gets stronger like the power
level gets over nine thousand as soon as
he starts getting low on time somehow
some way he just he just becomes another
player it's really he's done it to
Magnus twice right and now he's doing it
to Fabiano here he had no times of five
minutes Bobby had a five minute time
Edge right to tell you how big of an
edge this was completely winning five
minutes and wasn't able to convert and
now it's simply hopeless for white that
night is going to struggle to contain
those two black pawns a bit of a trick
here that night it's poisoned okay don't
take that night the white corn would run
through you fighting yeah he's fighting
Fabby maybe some small chances the white
king coming back now but uh three
seconds two seconds oh time time he made
a move don't worry the moves are coming
in yeah no that's gonna happen when it
was coming with the increments so chill
guys okay you can trust our Timmy if he
does not lose on time he doesn't get
flagged you're right wow but he's
playing he said the last 15 moves on
seconds and it looks like that was an
inaccuracy fabi's back because the
bishop couldn't go forward there would
have been a fork and now he gets the
pawns he takes both of them wow I'm
sorry he's celebrating he can't believe
it he cannot believe his luck that he
survived this WOW don't ride off these
top players ever I think that's the
lesson from this game Fabi saves a draw
King versus King it's a miracle vladis
love I'll tell me let it slip though one
move or two moves away from winning oh
what a turnaround it's a roll reversal
from yesterday far beyond a car one was
winning against Miami and just like what
we just saw here that's what happened
lamlay was able to survive so the
players they're going to make their
mistakes in time trouble but Fabiano he
should count his lucky stars that was an
absolutely crazy game there we saw Fabi
with a smile he knows that he survived a
scare it was completely busted at some
point but Fabi survives to level the
score and go into game three what a
round we've had full of action David so
many critical moments so many critical
moments both in the game between Wesley
and Hikaru and also this one I just want
to show where vladislav could have
actually finished it off just a few
moves before the end he was still
winning Bishops are better than knights
in these types of positions with pawns
on both flanks and he could have showed
this by simply pushing his pawns this
white knight is so far away there's no
way to come back and stop there's only
actually one route you have to come into
the center but black simply continues
pushing you park the bishop on this
Square the white king can come across
but now you defend everything and
Black's King could take this Pawn at
will if the white king ever Strays too
far away you'll make a new Queen White
is stuck and it's a matter of time
before black wins instead he moved his
Bishop to a poor poor Square allowing
the White Knight back and the white King
was just in time to come back and take
these pawns missed opportunity for Tamia
Fabiano breathing a sigh of relief yeah
on the camera in the end sabi is smiling
after picking up those Queen side bonds
what action we've had and this is where
we stand Hikaru Nakamura with a
fantastic win oh Wesley Seoul playing on
the clock playing on the position now he
takes the lead Vesti saw Trails by a
point Fabiano Carana but vladislav about
time yeah that match is tied there is a
big a big game three coming up but
before that we're gonna take a shot
twitch break
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome everybody my name is
Champion our starting a new course here
for chessable a very special chessful
course master your chest with Judith
bulgar you know what I learned a lot
foreign
[Music]
knows this story so at some point we
were we were running what was called the
chess.com ambassador program I was
convincing to give this little chess
website that could a chance because I
know ICC is better to play but give us a
chance when we thought about trying to
get someone to play on our site who
could who could motivate other title
players to come we were having a lot of
internal debates about all the top
players at the time I mean I've noted
Carlos since I was 11 and he was nine
right it was we were everyone was good
there was no Pros I'm not gonna list any
of the cons But Eric was the one who was
like Hey like if we're gonna do this why
not just go right to the top like hey
cars the best online chess player in the
world we had all the other Grand Masters
weirdo but like hey we really care about
this why are we spending our time
um you know trying to trying to do this
in five years let's just go get Hikaru
to play on our site and and Eric reached
out to a car and had a great call
and I donated Carter for a year so it
wasn't hard for me to connect with him
and and the moment we got Hikaru playing
on our site it was like every top chess
player in the world followed
foreign
ERS in the world for not just that I
mean over the last year what performance
he's had winning the American Cup
re-entering the world's top five even in
2022 in his grappy performance
qualifying for the candidates and a
fantastic candidate is Hikaru Robert in
the best shape of his life you know he
was number two in the world in classical
Chess at some point but right now I
think he is just on fire every
tournament he plays in he doesn't just
have a chance he's right up there if not
winning the event so Hikaru Nakamura
seems Unstoppable most events he plays
in yeah and he is leading his match
against Wesley James what does flexley
need to do to come back and do this one
Lexi snow he Flex likely so needs to
flex right he needs to flex he also
needs to play his game maybe play more
solid a little bit here don't take I'll
take less rate but also he needs to like
get his time right right if you get the
time right he's blundered both times in
time pressure so if I can get my time
right just play maybe a little bit more
Instinct here a little more solid but
you also have to get over the fact that
I just lost this game right and I'm
losing on time he said this yesterday
too about his time management wasn't the
greatest so he needs to fix that today
and then right now in fact is because
he's got two matches left so two games
so he needs to fix that right now before
he gets out of hand yeah Wesley so has
been struggling on the clock and on the
board and takes a big decision to go for
the Sicilian wow yeah less risk evenly
yeah James you jinxed it though with the
opening I was actually going to make a
bow prediction that it would be a quick
bowling draw Hikaru would be happy to
get one closer one game closer to that
Finishing Line Wesley meanwhile throw
away that black game focus on white uh a
white win in the next one but no Wesley
wants to risk now here and now it's a
bishop B5 check Sicilian this is a more
solid option for white no open Sicilians
where it's kind of throwing pieces
towards each other's King this one is
more strategic kind of in line with
nakamura's strategy for this match
seemingly but uh yeah what do we think
of this opening Choice the bishop B5
check for any Sicilian player like me
being included as well I've ventured off
into E5 and Carol Khan too as well but
being a long time Sicilian player the
one that you hate the most is when they
go Bishop B5 Tech believe it or not you
can see the face that Wesley's making
right now he actually made that fair as
soon as Bishop B5 check landed on the
board his face he was just mad the
little smirk of like bro come on man
like that's exactly what happened here
and I understand because this is
annoying nobody likes to face the bishop
B5 check Cecilia now you play this is
someone have an open position attacking
chances in here you're like this
everything's closed now a single piece
has been traded and when Magnus was
playing at zakaru we saw some closest
zones as well just trying to keep the
action closed until black has to force
it open and look at Wesley's last move
C4 maybe opening the C5 Square for his
Knight trying to get some forward
squares but white can always strike at
that pawn B3 or D3 just try to trade
some pieces and we do see a quick song
yep a quick on percent and this will be
recaptured at least now for Wesley if he
wants to win this game there is a small
imbalance in the pawn structure black
has a rock solid structure black once he
gets castled will be very happy I think
Hikaru meanwhile will want to strike on
that Queen side so still early days in
that game as these two starts their
battle Yeah I had a big game coming up
where vladislav our Tamia was so close
to winning round two against Fabiano
caruana but a miraculous save that and
now Vlad starts with the King spawn
opening Robert you are surprised yeah I
mean a lot of songs I'm playing a lot of
Knight F3 systems but he's challenging
Fabiano head on in the Best Buy test one
E4 lines and then he's thinking so I I'm
just not sure what our team is aiming
for it seems like it's part of his game
plan to spend a ton of time in the
opening and then speed up later but he
chose this first move he could have
expected Fabiano to play this he was
renowned as a Petrov player but he also
of course plays the Spanish and now he's
playing the Four Knights which is not
the most testing variation I'm a little
bit surprised at what's going on yeah
really surprising stuff it feels like
the Mind Games maybe he's on tilt maybe
he's been affected by failing to convert
that advantage in the last game and okay
he's actually using the Spanish four
nights just like fedes did earlier in
the day maybe this is uh something the
two Russians have been working on that
okay bringing his Bishop out for black
now Fabiano and this is still mirroring
that game earlier in the day FedEx
against Levon aronian and in that game I
believe there was uh just a pawn push
here in the center and that game was
very balanced for a while but
spice things up at all early days here
but very symmetrical solid start for
both
yeah David I have to ask you the spawn
push with the Deep on defending E4 why
could white not just pick up the E5 pawn
it looked like it was hanging Center
Pawn I'm attacking F7 yeah Natalia this
would have led into a maze of
complications let's just jump in uh if
White had taken this Pawn I've taken it
myself in this exact position black for
example can bring his Queen out and here
things do get spicy white for example
can cash in on this square but uh watch
out for the white king as well a bit of
a Target so this leads to uh just uh
reams of opening theory that I don't
want to get bogged down in here but it
would have got very complicated and
clearly uh Artemis just in the mood for
a more solid position this is the
current position on the board and you do
have to watch out slightly for this type
of move you don't get your queen trap
but uh of course there is still one
Escape Square maybe the White Queen will
slide across to attack this black king
and you said opening Theory and we have
five on a Corona on screen when you
think opening Theory he's one of the
first names that comes to mind along
with the likes of Anish giri so artemian
wants no part of those crazy positions
he'd likely hasn't looked at it much
himself he's not not really an E4 player
he does not play The King's Pawn often
so he's trying to play something solid
he wants a slight Edge so they can try
to press because as David you said
yesterday before he faced off against
Magnus he loves himself a good end game
and Magnus Carlson he is the highest
standard of end game player and artemium
is right up there with him yep for sure
so if the Queens do come off then watch
out for our team have trying to work his
magic there against Fabiano but Fabiano
as he's shown in the first game
especially if he's direct he can catch
our team off guard in the opening and I
think that just that experience of game
one today has scared us away from his
usual opening so that's why we see this
position in front of us I think that's a
win for Fabi in fact I mean he scared
you away from your regular Knight F3 I
mean he played it every game against
Magnus through you know the World Champ
Fabiano here he went he's like let's mix
it up wow that says a lot you know about
Fabio's Fabiano's prep and also maybe
the psych part there
um psychology part on our Timmy of there
of like oh man oh let's play something
different but then you know I'm not
familiar with these positions and if he
gets along time I mean this can be bad
let's see how prep how much prep Fabi
has here too as well he feels like he's
good right now only 30 seconds off the
clock here up time already I'm still at
the beginning of the game here so I'm
pretty good for probably here but very
level position and nothing that you know
both players cannot play well yeah it's
only moved eight or nine but it's clear
that our time if it's freestyling
completely and again another long think
what could be more natural just Castle
the white king but maybe he wants to
attack maybe he wants to throw some
pawns towards the black king maybe he's
going to bring White's Dart score Bishop
out just pin that black knight lots of
choices but I'm worried if he keeps this
uh pattern of dropping low on the clock
then at some point in the day it will
come back to bite him yeah and we've
often seen that to come back when there
are those critical moments where you
whereas that difference of half a point
and converting it into a win after
playing a great game and then not having
enough time to do that so our time we
have needs to take care of the clock
he's down by two minutes also I just
notice it's the same it's not the same
t-shirt that he wore yesterday when he
hit Magnus yeah I was trying not to call
him chess players are often Very
Superstitious right we've seen Daniel
dubov where that Balenciaga sweater many
days in a row when he's having a good
event Jana Palm she's done the same so
some people are very Superstition in
fact they use the same pen every single
time as soon as they lose a game that
pen is thrown off off the balcony what
Sam jersey Sam seven with the Jersey
right so at least that's you know next
week so I hope there was some laundry
being done I don't want to call it out
of this but yeah I think the uh you know
stinging like the Bumblebee that's still
part of our tenderness game plan
see if it works or not today it worked
affection against Magnus but right now
it looks like Fabiano caruana has
everything under control in this
position out of the opening let's hug
back to the other matchup Hikaru
Nakamura taking on Wesley so Hikaru
leads with his win in round two does he
have everything under control in this
one it looks very balanced to me on the
face of things but I do slightly prefer
Black's position just the flexibility of
having two Central pawns if you look on
the two Central files the e d file black
has two why does one so black is the one
who can push pawns forward at the right
moment I'm not sure whether now or later
will be the right moment but uh you're
the one who can make that decision it
definitely feels like Hikaru is playing
Safety First chess just maneuvering
keeping everything on solid squares and
he's saying to Wesley you start the
action and I will react but that's a
risky strategy in a situation like this
if you're too passive if you're too
negative with your Maneuvers your
decisions then it could uh haunt you for
sure Wesley meanwhile just setting up
he's going to bring all of his pieces
into the game maybe centralize his Rook
next to his King maybe step the black
king up one square cover some holes over
there and only then decide what to do in
the center there's something ironic
about it though sometimes in players
they have a lead that's when they get
the most nervous and icaro has been
ahead on the clock throughout most of
the competition right now we see him
spending time on this move he's playing
kind of timidly in on hikaru-like
fashion especially actually in a Sassoon
it was his opening Choice he won a solid
game but he's not getting that so this
is a credit to Wesley so playing a
strong Sicilian getting the type of
position he needs to fight for a win and
akaro now is looking at the center as
David was pointing out will black strike
with that extra Pawn there is there a
problem down the C file what is white
going to attack it doesn't seem like
there's a Target in Black's position I
like the look of this for Wesley so
there are two potential breaks in these
positions for black right you can either
go D5 strike in the center or B4 strike
on the queen side James which one do you
think will appear in this game yeah D5
is the one I'm a big fan of and now of
course B4 yeah you have to be careful of
the C file it's not actually we don't
have that much pressure down and we do
but the nice defending here we also
could play Rook C1 at any time so D5 is
definitely the more thematic break you
also want to get the Knight on maybe
Knight takes D5 and then Knight can even
swing into F4 and you want to open up
that light Square Bishop as much as
humanly possible because of course I
mean even get the bishop to D6 I mean
everything is going to be Amy at this
white king over here and you can get a
lot of trouble um especially if you
don't get the pieces off the back rank I
mean the Queen's still not this Queen's
on D1 The Works are not connected blacks
are like black has all the pieces
developed this is what you want
especially in any opening but definitely
in a sicilian like this there should be
five checks Sicilians can be very
annoying but it looks like I mean the
worst may be over for Wesley I think he
played it very well yeah red Black's got
a Time aimed this break really well
because you also can't allow white to
push that E Pawn forward after D5 just
blocking your own Bishop but James I
love the ideas and I think D5 is what
will be the aim uh Robert
do you agree yeah but I like David's
arrows here because I was just thinking
black played G6 a moment ago and what
was the point of Point upon the take
away the F5 Square so the White Knight
cannot jump forward so you play E5 to
stop white from doing that and then you
play D5 and you really blast the center
of the board open advantageous for black
if that were to occur Yep looks
beautiful for black everything in
Black's favor here I was just going to
point out this move as well if the white
knight Retreats here maybe the black
Knight's actually going to come to this
Square really tie down these pawns this
is kind of thematic uh uh kind of an
idea here especially when you've got
pressure down the C file uh if the white
knight goes the other way however look
how blocked in this queen is this queen
is smothered this queen is suffocated
and now you break open the center boom
and everything is in Black's favor I
really actually fear for Hikaru in this
position if he simply moves his Rook
across I think he's going to be
struggling he needs something more
active but where is that move what can
he try here already shaking his head
notice this uh uh David actually like
you know it's um he carves down time
yeah when is hikaro ever downtown
against anybody on the planet right okay
he's down three minutes in the county
that's a lot Wesley this is a win for
Wesley right now and an opening battle
right now Wesley won the opening battle
and Hikaru is going to have to figure
this out as he's trying to right now he
spent right now the timer says three
minutes and Counting he's thinking and
using his time trying to figure this out
Wesley's up time that's huge for Wesley
right now yeah it is really about
getting these small wins so that you can
get the big win in the end getting that
little time Advantage putting a little
bit more pressure on the opponent having
ideas like E5 D5 in the air hey carbon
Nakamura in a bit of trouble and you can
tell he's just not shaking and bobbing
as much as he usually does when he's
better he's no longer acting right that
that Grimace that you just saw on his
face that was real that's a chest
position Grimace like this is not going
the way I want and it really is that
straightforward for black you have a
clear plan and white doesn't so black
has the pawn bricks I say this so off
and I says so many time in the show the
side that controls the Palm bricks is
usually side of the advantage he brought
his Knight back to the first rank which
opens up ideas on the queen side flag or
still in the center I love the way this
looks for Wesley and I think we've been
all been asking for this we love Wesley
so when he's playing ambitious chess
he's super dangerous but he often sticks
towards more solid openings and
decisions when he's playing the top he
has to his back is against the wall and
he's doing just that so Props to Wesley
right now yeah I first met Wesley so at
the 2007 world junior Championship and
he was a really attacking aggressive
player he crushed me straight out of the
opening once a few years later crushed
me again by playing attacking chess and
I just couldn't handle him and nowadays
he tends to prefer that more solid
approach and it serves him well of
course he's got that level of
consistency that's kind of kept him in
the elite of World Chess for so long but
to beat the likes of Hikaru to beat the
likes of Magnus you need a bit extra so
it's nice to see him in this game
embracing his roots embracing his uh
Natural Instincts when he was a bit
younger and I feel like just like the
first game now is the moment strike in
the center before Hikaru gets organized
David I was thinking about that you know
that F5 break that he had in the earlier
game he missed that opportunity is this
the moment for him to strike in the
center push that epon drive the night
away and then move ahead with the Deep
Pawn opening up the bishop all the ideas
that James mentioned and we've got E5 on
the board we might be seeing D5 next
yeah it's on the boards on the board and
uh does he want to move this Knight
that's the question first maybe he
brings it to the side of the board maybe
he brings it back but uh as you say
Tanya this is the move next D5 break it
open and black has the advantage it's
Unstoppable almost this pawnbrick your
idea is still there Knight A4 first
let's keep the peace on the board when a
side is cramped they want to trade
pieces the only side that doesn't have
space is white so let's keep the knights
on the board then play D5 open up the
center black has an extra Pawn in the
middle of the board this looks so
promising for black and hikar recognize
that it's not that he thinks he's lost
and Wesley did by the way hop the Knight
to the A4 square but hikar is just
uncomfortable and Wesley's in the
driver's seat yeah yeah just to fast
forward a couple of Moves In This
variation to show how strong this is for
black for example what do you do in this
position if you move your queen then at
some point you will get hit by a knight
F4 jump I don't see what else the black
Rook is going to come start creating
some monster threats also watch out for
sacrifices on this Square just looks
fantastic for black right now position
is gross that is just so bad after he
takes D5 it's really bad D5 here I mean
do you have a choice you have to take
this you've got to be careful if you
make a random move maybe we'll even see
the black porn step forward there's a
pin on this file as well and that could
NAB black a pawn at the very least you
just bring your Rook into the center uh
nice position so if you do have to open
things up that will suit black and uh
Wesley done everything right in this
game Hikaru rotates his Knight Retreats
that Knight backwards and uh okay he's
still solid-ish but look at the white
pieces they're all camped on their first
two ranks blacks are pouring forward
with all the momentum
feels like the math situation has forced
Wesley to take drastic ambitious
decisions and good for him because now
after D5 he does control the board white
moving back Hikaru moving back with his
Knights but there is a threat on the
board he is threatening to pick up that
black knight and win a pawn how does
black counter it that's a pawn I'd be
willing to give up if I'm wasted I get
the bishop pair the board will open up
that's good for Bishop so I would even
think about sliding The Rook that's next
to the king into the center in line with
the queen Rooks usually win those
showdowns on an open file and that file
is going to open up Wesley Knight C5
that is not a timid move he just brings
his Knight back towards the center I
think it makes sense he knows he has the
advantage why give hikar even the
slightest bit of Hope with material so
95 is good Rook d8 is next still Wesley
and look at the lead on the clock as
well it's not just the board it's the
clock it's everything and you can see it
on hikara's face
yeah he's worried he's one uh
uncomfortable man right now Hikaru
Nakamura and it's like you said earlier
Robert just when you're in the lead
somehow people freeze I've been there so
many times myself suddenly getting a
draw feels like Mount Everest climbing
that Mount Everest and uh it's the
hardest thing in the world just to stay
solid against these top players uh okay
Hikaru brings his Queen out but that
Queen is not gonna feel too safe anytime
soon James do you spot any attempting
moves for black attempting attempting
ideas here yeah I'm actually looking at
uh I was just going to say captures okay
capture I also looked at d42 but you
know it just locks down everything and I
have to like move the Knight and then
play F5 it's too much so taking at least
keeps the bishop open it's a very strong
Bishop I have there but after takes I
mean I'm not sure what to do yet okay he
took out the night so now we have to
calculate a little bit takes takes takes
takes takes takes takes takes and then
grab the juicer exactly I'm not sure
which way you capture with the Knights
let's say this way for example and I'm
really worried for a car after a move
such as B4 look at this look at the
pressure on the C file it's as if you're
getting hit from all angles this Pawn in
the center is isolated internal weakness
now you're getting hit from this flank
also black is the one actually with the
advantage on the other side it's
actually on the board right wow it's on
the board before we were talking about
should black go for the D5 break or
before wrestling says I'm gonna get both
of them and he does it in the strongest
way possible with that PIN on C2 Hikaru
Nakamura in big trouble low on the clock
as well
92 does that just well the good news is
that the B7 Bishop is attacked David so
you perhaps can't really pick up the C3
Pawn immediately yeah I'm not gonna be
greedy that I'm not I'm not keen to rush
things here if I'm Wesley so he's got
the long-term Advantage so he's actually
done the hard work long-term white
Central Pawn is isolated after a Trader
pawns on the C3 square that we pointed
out he'll have a bunch more isolated
pawns uh Hikaru Nakamura so Wesley can
actually make sure everything's defended
everything's ready first there we go
bring the Rook into the action only
later cash in on that Advantage it's all
about transforming advantages in chess
you have the Strategic Advantage
transform it into a material advantage
later but only when you're ready only on
your own terms and I like this myth and
the one piece for black that really
isn't optimized that Knight on F6 it is
staring at White Center but at some
point it may hop around the board to
find Greener pasture so if that Knight
hops to the rim we typically criticize
those decisions call it dim but here
that night May Venture into F4 that's a
great Square to work with white would
like to use the dark sweat Bishop to
cover but then black will try to trade
off the dark Square if you use your Pawn
to cover by pushing a G3 you open up
even more squares around your king that
does not look like a good way to stop
you see the evaluation go higher and
higher for black in such a position I
think that Wesley his play is so easy
here he has a lead on the clock his car
was not feeling the game right now and I
think Wesley has to punish him yeah he
has to punish him at some point you will
take on this on this Square you don't
need to rush this because of the pin
against the C2 Bishop maybe a move such
as bringing the bishop to C5 I'm also
looking at ideas like Knight G4 trying
to go for this white king trying to cash
in on those dark squares and just looks
beautiful for Wesley but he's spoiled
for choice will he be able to find The
Knockout blow it feels like this is the
game he needs to strike here uh if he
doesn't win this one Wesley he's not
going to recover from this uh from this
disappointment he's up time too as well
he's just trying to Bishop C5 weight we
have a move here okay very logical he's
trying to trade off and take on no you
still can't take us well you can now the
problem was B7 and E7 was hanging now
there's only one piece hanging and then
you can actually win the pawn there but
you allow The Rook on the seventh with
some counter play it is interesting yeah
it's interesting I I just don't see a
movie maybe you have to push the white
king into the corner and just cross your
fingers and hope pray for the best but
uh yeah black is breaking through on the
dark squares that might be the uh the
bigger worry right now for Hikaru yeah
yeah how are we leading the match took
this decision to play a more positional
strategic opening with the Rosa limo not
playing the open Sicilian which is more
his style do you think that is where it
went wrong for him that he didn't
believe in his own position but instead
wanted to play The Mad situation yeah
you got to play the board in front of
you and if Wesley doesn't play the
Sicilian on a regular basis it's because
of the open Sicilian it's because he
doesn't want to be attacked and uh here
Hikaru hasn't tried to attack him hasn't
given any difficult questions hasn't
tried to make Wesley uncomfortable he's
just playing for a draw yes you've got
white you haven't done that much wrong
but it's these small kind of signals
that would have given Wesley confidence
in the match and H3 stopping the black
knight from jumping forward but a bit of
a sad move to play yeah yeah
currently struggling in this game on the
clock and on the board we will come back
to this let's get an update wow lots has
happened here
Queens have been traded off what is
going on how are we evaluating this end
game well when you said struggling on
the clock and on the board that
describes position he is
he is seven minutes and change he's also
a worse position because his Pawn
structure is worse and Fabiano caruana
has full control of this open e-file the
Knight is better than the bishop we like
a bishop pair but when it's a lone
Bishop the Knight can hop from color
complex to color complex the bishop is
inherently limited to its own color the
dark squares and look at this black
controls the E file black has a rook in
the file that Knight on D7 can jump into
the position via B6 and go forward from
there this looks really really nice for
Fabiano and did we mention that he's up
seven minutes
what does he even hope for here I'll
tell me if all the Rooks come off you're
probably losing it's good night versus
bad Bishop uh if the Rooks stay on the
board the black Brooks are likely to
come into the position which pieces do
you want to trade there's no chance
you'll ever get Black's night off the
board for your Bishop I don't see it
what are your hopes long term maybe you
just have to survive move by move but
with three minutes it's uh not an easy
task
and so it's hard that when you have to
play moves and suffer from a worse
position like that's just the worst like
you know you're worse but you're just
trying to hold or make some create some
type of chances here it is Bishop versus
knight but I mean like the night's fine
you have double pawns here I can always
defend the B file with B6 if you go Rook
B1 I'm about to double and then trade
and uh definitely an in-game would be
nice for black here we have the
Maneuvers we can even put the Knight to
E4 we get a knight to E4 it's gonna be
extremely annoying right so black has
all the play here and the time to do it
now Fabi needs to be better with his
time management I think here too because
he got in time trouble and almost lost
that game you know so he needs to be
careful too not to get too low on time
here and I use the time Edge wisely yeah
James we saw that happen and a lot of
Misses happen when you're low on the
clock is it a good idea for Fabi to keep
the Rooks on the board or should he try
to get rid of them I would love to make
them all disappear but if that magic was
done Hoover them off the board just yeah
I think the Black Knight is just uh
gonna be a beast if it lands like James
says on e4 or C4 the route that fabi's
going right now
uh beautiful Outpost and uh when you
have squares that can't be challenged
for that night
the white Bishops simply can't compete
and black can trade a pair of Rooks at
any moment right you can push your Jeep
on Force the bishop out of the way then
trade Rook so I really like the dynamic
here for Fabiano it seems like he has a
pretty easy gameplay and for artemia who
doesn't have much time he's looking am I
going to lose a pawn in the next few
moves and if he loses one Pawn is that
too much to deal with unlike game one
where five ever got in time trouble and
almost lost there is zero losing chance
there he would have to blunder a full
piece or a Miss click and give him his
opponent pass Pawn I don't even know how
you lose this position Fabiano has a
dream situation right now
dream situation just keep things solid
uh just uh defense and pawns get those
Rooks off the board at the right moments
yeah looks perfect strategy and I'll
tell him if he's an in-game expert but
not when he's suffering like this I
don't think anyone could be an expert in
this position uh for white it's just
this is a nightmare we're just two and a
half minutes on the clock playing with
the white pieces it's just not a
scenario you want to be in Fabiano
caruana dominating this end game Let's
head back to our other match
Hikaru versus Wesley Hikaru with the
white pieces has landed up in big
trouble straight from the opening also
for the first time in this match it's
Wesley who is ahead on the clock we see
that the Bishops there's still tension
there trades haven't happened on the
queen side King H1 how does black
continue now oh spoil for Choice uh you
could trade a set of Pawns on the queen
side but again do you rush it I don't
think so
I was going to say Robert's idea from a
few moves back bring that black knight
into the game that's maybe the piece
that can be improved right now I would
love to take a time out as well to just
kind of Shuffle the black king forward
one square just to protect some pawns
but uh you've kind of got this luxury of
time of all these different moves how do
you choose and actually the more I look
at it the more I don't like Wesley's
decision to open up the white Rook on
the B file some trick suddenly in the
air
um we should see five is a threat you're
actually threatening to just win a
baseball big fella swinging I was just
gonna go Knight H5 but he's in with a
tactino David said improve the nicest
give me that pawn in the center and this
works tactically what a shot from Wesley
so he grabs a pawn and it may look like
white is about to win a piece because
that 94 is under attack multiple times
but the issue is that Queen 92 is needed
to guard the dark side Bishop so the
forcing lines actually play out in
Black's favor yeah just as an example of
the forcing lines firstly you can't take
this bishop if you take this bishop
there's a nasty night Fork a nasty check
winning the White Queen so the only
other forcing move is to take this one
take the Knight but suddenly after
Bishop takes Bishop the White Queen is
overloaded as Robert mentions Queen
takes Bishop you drop this piece the
white Bishop here is lost and black will
emerge a clear Pawn up if you take the
other Bishop then black is actually
spoiled for choice you can take this
Knight if you want or you can be even
more ambitious even more greedy and take
this Rook at the very end after the dust
clears black has won the exchange and
the pawn game over so uh Hikaru now he
needs to be resourceful to even stay
alive head shake this game headshake
from Hikaru there headshake classic head
shake saying oh this is terrible you
know what do they do chat oh I'm a
oh am I dumb or am I is that the
title for the YouTube video
that's what he says on stream all the
time right so he definitely just missed
the shot here he's definitely a very
angry at himself very emotional players
you can tell right guys you know he does
this all the time on stream as he's
probably streaming right now in fact but
it is uh it's annoying that's a nice
shot from Wesley and I missed that
Knight H5 I thought he was going forward
but 94 is even better I'm just thinking
yesterday everyone was winning with
black I don't think we had a single win
with the white pieces Hikaru just beat
Wesley with black Wesley gets is this
gonna be like 10 nothing it's a decisive
games with the players the black pieces
we rule out the Armageddon yeah and I'm
ruling out the arm against that's
different format wow nine wins with the
black pieces zero to wide in the rapid
portion on day one and as you're
pointing out it was Hikaru taking the
10th black win and it looks like Wesley
has the upper hand with the black pieces
you could be right I don't think we've
ever seen those stats before black
scoring so heavy yeah it just shows how
well prepared everyone is these days if
you can't make a dent on your opponent
with white then actually things do turn
around and look at Hickory down to one
minute how often do we see this down on
time so significantly and totally lost
position great play by Wesley uh yeah I
don't think this would have been on my
radar either but uh he spotted it and he
deserves to win this game so far Han
grabbed right in the center and I just
do want to point out that I just thought
about it and LeBron one with the white
pieces against Federal Sav earlier so
Lavon I apologize you know please
forgive me you did win with white and
look at uh Hikaru he puts his Bishop
there what is going on hold on man
tactics everywhere everything's hanging
relax yeah you just pick it up you can't
pick up the rug because the queen was
hanging yeah let's do a count so white
has sacrificed The Exchange a rook for
Bishop but in return has got the White
Queen active it shouldn't be enough but
there's an attack against the black
knight from the White Queen that's an
attack against black Rook from White
start squared Bishop so a couple of
tricks in the air he's just gambling at
this point Hikaru he knew he was losing
anyway so he's is going to go down in
flames he's going to hope that Wesley
gets nervous and slips up but four
minutes for Wesley he should be able to
find a solution what is it though that's
the big question Daniel Rook how do you
defend your knight from these threats
it's critical that Wesley has so much
time because with an open King the dark
squares are rolling roll around the
black king if the bishop and queen could
line up there could be even a Checkmate
against it so Wesley has plenty of time
he's up a rook and one Pawn for just the
bishop that is more than enough so I
think he just needs to figure out how to
save his Rook save his Knight I think
maybe moving his Dark Sword Bishop back
to attack the queen that might be the
way to do so but I see chances for
Hikaru he is the king of making things
complicated when it looks like he has no
shot you have really nice move there
really nice suggestion Robert I'm not
sure if it's the only way but it's a
very sensible way you defend your knight
with Tempo James mentioned earlier
everything has to come with Tempo
everything has to have a purpose
and uh Here We Go attacking the White
Queen now the pawn is taken but the
black Rook has time to move I'm not sure
which Square you use you can move it up
you can across as long as the bishop
can't take you you will have a decisive
material advantage and Wesley converting
it really nicely so far he hasn't
slipped up but will there be twists
ahead yeah Hikaru doesn't look too
unhappy looked a bit uh well at least a
bit positive there with his life
decision yeah he understands it's
practical right you've got two Bishops a
weak King over here you know the The
Bishop's on G7 dark Square Bishop there
could be some things there like I mean I
mean by uh sorry uh black would be way I
mean way better I think he'll be fine
you're covering the weaknesses around
the king but white definitely has some
practical chances of like a bishop B3
and if you can reroute this bishop and
then get the queen on the diagonal
there's some problems in there right
there it is Bishop to B3 we're like
maybe you can even play Queen G4 Queen
G6 is there right Bishop F6 Queen H6 I
mean Bishop F6 might be next Queen H6
and you have a mating net this is
disgusting right so it's crazy you can
create chances out of this but Wesley
definitely has to be accurate here
Bishop F6 is a really strong move and
then Queen H6 and you might be getting
mated yeah
Hikaru is very resourceful very
difficult to beat him even when you have
a good position and what might have
looked like a blunder to many of us
giving up that exchange is just him
posing very important strong practical
problems for Wesley currently and we do
see as the clocks get more and more
level right now Wesley has an extra
minute on the clock he does attack the
White Queen and wow that is a dangerous
Quest placing it on the diagonal of the
bishop dangerous squirt but the only
square that Queen was borderline trapped
and look at this Knight E4 retrieving
the Knight but defending everything the
bishop is covered The Rook is covered so
a car once again moves his Queen
attacking the knight in the center and
for Wesley I mean if he gets in time
trouble this is when mistakes happen he
still has over a minute advantage of the
clock gotta be really careful suddenly
James your ideas if the white Queen's
swinging across towards the black king
telling you there's tricks here I mean
even like Knight C3 Queen E8 my guy and
then Rook takes Rook takes Bishop F6 but
of course obviously play I think G5
there is there Bishop C2 ooh exciting
stuff you're thinking about some Queen
sacrifices bringing the queen to the top
of the board I'm not sure they work but
for example you could just swing your
queen across and just to point out a
huge threat but Queen takes Pawn boom as
you say uh due to this pin the black
king is in actually huge trouble here so
you've got to be really wary really
careful uh for Wesley how does he
maintain this Knight in the center of
the board maybe he can't if he can't
then uh at least it's not one-way
traffic maybe driving back trading off
pieces is a good idea but not an easy
move to make Wesley big decisions ahead
practical this is practical decisions
here I mean these Bishops are sharp and
again the dark Square weaknesses are
evident around the king there you have
to move the Knight and queen G4 is a
very strong move maybe he just moves the
king up to G7 or something yeah it feels
scary though suddenly for Wesleyan down
to one minute the clocks are basically
level Anything could happen in this
position Wesley needs to move he needs
to get pieces off the board the Dream
the ultimate goal is to get the Queens
off but uh hikara is going to say no to
that one he's going to keep the Queens
on and go for the attack Black's King
lacking Defenders okay Wesley's down on
the clock for the first time in the game
really
could we see a turnaround what do we
think now yeah that's a problem you know
you cannot be giving all the time Bishop
G3 and oh speaking of turnaround bro is
that Knight only four just hanging it is
just take it the heck was that oh my God
I thought there was a background
Checkmate but there is not one there for
black that was a huge blunder and I'm
looking at was it this am I just losing
the match he lost his absolute on
National Television this is the move he
missed he missed the night Retreat then
the most difficult type of move to see
in chess backward night moves but wow
suddenly he's just lost a piece for free
Wesley so blundered and look at Hikaru
the Bob was going there the head Bob hi
practical chances practical right engine
says oh I'm winning and we all see it at
home and the eval borrowed the evil bar
right we see it and it's but the
Practical chances figuring it out
yourself on the board playing somebody
as strong as this is and the time
trouble again A Time issue for Wesley
when you get low on time you make
mistakes and he blundered a piece can't
express how important this is because
now hit car borrow I mean he's winning
he's up a full uh two minor pieces for a
rook that's too much to deal with for
Wesley so but when I think about the
overall tournament now Westie will drop
to the losers bracket where he faces
Magnus Carlson so so Magnus or Wesley
will do no better than fifth place which
means we'll see them in the play-in for
the next time and if akaro can get this
Victory this looks for him quite easy at
this point if he wins this he makes sure
he makes it to the third event division
one no I mean not just was it a blunder
that blew the advantage it's literally
360. he was totally winning up material
now he's just uh yeah as Robert says
lost in Practical terms and you don't
want to be facing Hikaru in this type of
end game where he's going to grind to
grind grind forever 10 seconds as well
for Wesley at some point very very
shortly the White Knight white bishop
and white Rook are gonna gang up against
Black's F7 Pawn the pawn next to Black's
King on a light Square easy Target and
that one will full watch out for that
white a pawn deciding the game later on
any end game any transitions
Transformations exchanges will favor
because of that past Pawn on the a file
Hikaru taking his time he's gonna win
and so resourceful hats off to him but
Wesley
something was up today a few blunders
we'll see if worst thing can be
resourceful though because right now
Hikaru he's trying to make progress but
if a rook sacrificed himself for one of
the minor pieces and gets a pawn in the
process perhaps white will not have
enough material remaining to win the
game and that's what Wesley is relying
on and a car is avoiding at all costs
he's keeping this game going he
centralizes Knight make sure that no
trades are about to happen and for
Wesley I mean it's back against the wall
time what about a rook trade will The
Rook trade help Wesley here he can force
some of the Rooks off the board there we
go he goes for it now
he is removing one of White's potential
attackers but still he has fewer
Defenders now against the white a pawn
oh fruity stuff yeah for white spawns
and if you wow if you're taking all this
Poland at some point you may not have
enough remaining yeah missed by Hikaru
maybe he went to the wrong square with
his King he should have stepped back he
went forward and now his pawns will fall
wow I wrote him off too soon I wrote off
I can't read first then I wrote up
Wesley and uh these two fighters just
throwing everything at each other maybe
he was gonna hold this one now yeah not
that many pawns remaining and that's all
black need to do is you're gonna trade
off the king side pawns and then bring
your King on over to the queen side and
then try to give up your Rook for Bishop
and Paul or Knight and pawn as long as
white has no pawns remaining and one of
the minor pieces off the board it's
immediately a draw yeah that trade of
Rooks I don't think Hikaru should have
allowed it now his bishop and Knight
don't combine as well without the
protection without the help of their
rook and blackstruck is causing all
sorts of nuisance here there's a nasty
threat of pushing that black pawn
forward with a check and then the black
Rock's gonna go for that lone white Pawn
on the king side and uh okay hey Hikaru
trading everything off this should not
be winning anymore no definitely not you
can't even take the pawn now oh my
goodness so let's say so I mean we were
talking about him being knocked down to
the elimination bracket no he is still
right in this match if he can take this
draw he gets the white pieces in game
four he could force Armageddon with the
win there this is shocking
I thought Hikaru was home and dry he
probably thought he was home and dry but
look at his face now he's devastated
missing the opportunity to cash in on
Wesley's blunder earlier well this one
should be a draw simply not enough
material the best you can hope for here
is uh to give up uh one of your pieces
for those black pawns and the black Rook
but just no material it's going to be a
draw 10 seconds shouldn't be a decisive
Factor here
yeah I had the head Bob too he was
filling it he's like yeah let's go I got
you I got it and then I mean at least he
didn't lose the game though no that was
definitely this was sort of been
Wesley's game for sure of course but
practical chances both being in time
trouble I mean there's still there's
still play left he's going to try me
anything can happen especially after
that our Timmy of uh Magnus game where
there was just that crazy game where he
he should have it should have been a
draw but he did not yeah seconds on the
clock Anything Can Happen the air pawns
advancing black king comes forward the
G6 Pawn is now hanging is it time for
Wesley to pick up that A5 Pawn go for it
now there he goes and I think Hikaru
forgot about the clock for a second uh
he nearly made a move
yeah a little sneaky to the last dish
Everett he's ready to get out of here
Hikaru you can see on his body language
the pawns disappear and Rook F5 this one
ends in the draw but if anyone's pleased
with that it's Gotta Be Hikaru he was
completely busted Wesley had such a big
chance but Hikari difficulty things and
tricked him yeah that being said chess
players they only remember the last
blunder and Hikaru was the one who let
the wind slip at the end there meanwhile
this game has turned what's happened
black has lost control and G5 oh my gosh
you could spring three this past Pawn
immediately I think Batman was just lost
at the moment he was much better all
game time travel James you called it
once again it is his biggest Achilles
heel absolutely and of course it was
funny is he gets stronger as artemiev is
a beast when he get low time when he is
loaded when he gets lower on time
artemia becomes another person it's just
insane how he can do this to the
greatest players in the world with no
time on his claw but during the game
when they have time he's like losing
he's down a little better position
better this better that and now he's
about to go look at that yeah that's a
that's a sign of uh of game over there
yeah sign of desperation he had to give
up his Rook that pawn was about to
become a new Queen and now it's only two
pawns for The Rook White's pieces are
going to coordinate though and pick off
those two black pawns the black porn
simply are Advanced enough and Fabi just
went for it at the wrong moment allowed
counter play and things have turned
I'll tell me if nerves of Steel you've
got to say as long as he avoids a
nightfork he will win this game yeah the
Knight will try to help protect the
pawns but then the white king will join
the party and that's the thing about the
end game the white king can be used as a
weapon but look at this this is like a
pretty good setup for Fabiano it's not
easy to crack this yeah not easy you
need patience and as I try to sing it it
is a shot it is working for him this is
unbelievable stuff there playing on
seconds how does he beat the very best
players in the world and we see Fabiano
Karana bringing his King in but that is
a whole drug that was strong it's it's a
good move just stop D4 everything under
control yeah
important move and uh now the white king
can step into the center
at will and those black pawns will
eventually fall lacking the coordination
now lacking the centralization you can
see from Fabi he's just devastated he's
thrown this game missed opportunities
left right and Center for both players
but uh here we go last a few moves and
this will be over just don't take the
knight uh well you can but uh if you do
don't grab the pawn afterwards gotta be
slightly careful
so it's dropping down to one two seconds
on each move
this one is a matter of time now yeah
the part's not Advanced enough white
will be able to Corral it and the one
thing you need to watch out for is the
black king slides over and the pawn
pushes forward then you have to
sacrifice your Bishop to stop it Rook
against Knight that would be a
theoretical draw so Fabi Clinging On to
his last bit of Hope here our 10 minute
bringing his King back give us a check
um that's that's nice yeah the Pawn's
too slow oh yikes that's it wins the
night and we'll bring the bishop to stop
that seat Pawn it's going nowhere and
with that Fabi shakes his head a lot of
slav our time you have takes the win
takes the lead which means going into
round four Fabiano caruana has to win on
demand to force the playoff wow what a
comeback that was by Fabi big moments in
both these games amazing turnarounds
Hikaru fighting it back to stay alive
and Fabi taking the lead David what was
the standout point for you uh there were
multiple standout points of course that
dramatic game between Wesley so and
hikara Nakamura essential uh for the
whole tournament but Fabiano caruana
where he let it slip was here black is
actually a pawn up he had the winning
chances he was better earlier in the
game as well but rather than allow a
draw rather than agree to a repetition
for example stepping his King back and
allowing a Perpetual check he played for
the win he dropped his Knight back but
suddenly white was better this walked
into a pin of course and suddenly it was
the black pawns that started falling
Bishops are better than knights in these
open positions horns on both flanks and
as we saw atemev went on to guide this
to victory yeah yeah and with that win
let's take a look at our score line
going into the final rapid game in these
two matches
leads his match against Fabiano caruana
after that great idea that David just
showed what a big mess by Fabi
everything was over
still leads the match against Wesley so
surviving a very difficult game where
Wesley could have leveled the score
wow Wesley and Fabi need to win on
demand to take it too
playoffs to take it to the Armageddon we
are hoping we at least get one of the
army Gardens but for now for our
non-subscribers we are going to take a
twitch break but for those of you who
have subscribed here is a video here's a
sneak peek into what makes Hikaru
Nakamura such a beast
[Music]
thank you
Hikaru Nakamura starts the chatable
Masters as one of the favorites
when he was young Nakamura had a really
aggressive style a really direct style
he wanted to win every game by Checkmate
and and many people feared him for that
however as he's got a bit older Hikaru
has slowed things down he plays a very
solid brand of Chess nowadays preferring
to take things to a more strategic level
and to grind down his opponents in Long
games as an example of hikaru's
attacking instincts this is perhaps his
most famous move of all time
that's black here against Boris gelfand
he played a queen sacrifice this game
stemmed from his favorite King's Indian
defense something he's also published a
course about unchessable Queen to D3
what a move try to deflect away this
white Bishop there are multiple threats
including Queen takes Pawn leading to
Checkmate and of course if the queen is
captured this would end in an immediate
Checkmate this is how Hikaru played as a
young player however as a streamer these
days he has an utterly different
repertoire in recent times Hikaru has
shown his natural talent for the game by
winning the Fisher random World
Championship that shows his flexibility
of course and this is reflected in his
streaming career on chess.com his most
successful opening is 1b3 however he's
also very well known for inventing the
bomb cloud and bringing the king out not
to be advised but Hikaru makes it work
wow hey guys
we're having at work but we are going to
reveal the most played openings on day
one of the chassisable Masters and it's
no bong Cloud rabbit it's not 1b3 it is
a very classic Queen's Gambit declined
Queen's gamma decline Ultra solid
opening you know the top players love it
Lavon aronian plays it all these top
guys do but it's super solid for them
yeah are you surprised to see any of the
openings on on this list uh so soon only
at one it used to be such a popular
fighting Choice especially in quicker
time patrols but these days it can be a
bit of two aggressive chests they prefer
their solidity at the top yeah it's such
a solid opening it is the opening of
choice of the top players the Queen's
Gambit declined Robert you've got to
show it to us okay let's go with it the
Queen's Gambit decline it is extra solid
and it starts like this white plays D4
black plays D5 you're countering in the
center white plays the Queen's Gambit
you do not accept but decline no thank
you for the offer I'm gonna play E6 and
here after the move Knight C3 by white
the most popular continuation black has
a vast array of choices and I want to
take us back in time to like of
Pillsbury and he played the Queen's game
but declined of course we had the 1927
World Chess Championship match between
Alexander alecai and Jose roll
capablanca all but a couple games
featured the Queen's Gambit decline so
if you're a qgd fan go back a century
and go look at those games but Magnus
Carlson in this day and age he choose a
variety of opening things of variations
against the qgd he plays A6 you can look
at Neil's Grand deals this course on
chessball where he a former second of
world champion Magnus Carlson goes
through the ins and outs of these
offbeat variations where you say I'm not
going to give you the typical plans you
have to figure out am I going to take on
C4 am I going to continue nacho with
Knight to F6 and we often see a carlsbot
structure if white does take on D5 here
and black takes back with Pawn
eventually the move C6 as possible or in
the spirit of tarash you could play even
for C5
Queen's combat declined has stood the
test of time Robert you mentioned some
really big names there and we see this
opening even in modern times being
played at all levels what makes it so
popular I think part of it is schooling
Mikhail butvinik the former world
champion he had a big chess School in
the Soviet Union and he played against
the Queen's Gambit declined a lot so
when you're taught that when you're
younger it's a very solid opening for
black so trying to break through it is
very difficult and when you're the top
of Chess it's not just about tactics
anymore you have to work those small
advantages so it's been taught
throughout the generations
so if you want to check out the Queen's
Gambit Decline and want to learn the ins
and outs of the opening check out
chasable
[Music]
hello this is Christoph zileki and
welcome to my
Channel One
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
wow action is still on a big game four
coming up in division one but the action
has ended for the day in division three
let's get updated from a division three
wow big games there and we see some
surprising results Robert chakra our
mama Jara one of the world's Elite a
Mainstay of Champions chess tours passed
he is out in division three Wei Yi the
super Grand Mass from China he says
you're not going to get by me and he
moves on so did Matthias bluebaum who
was in the official random world
champion he takes down Nguyen from
Vietnam
action is on everywhere but of course we
will be focusing on the final round of
division one it is now Wesley so needs
to strike what is it that he's going to
do in this one Wesley he gets the white
pieces that's the good news but he can't
keep playing the solid stuff he needs to
take risk the time is now he did it with
black a game ago it almost worked out
for him now he has to play something in
a similar fashion and James Bobby needs
to do the same he is trailing vladislav
or tammyev how is it possible that our
time we have comes down to seconds and
yet he's the one who wins I mean really
in fact both in both matches it's the
time you have to be you have to stop
getting low on time right if it's easier
said than done obviously but of course
probably got low on time in both games
right that he was up time then he got
low on time and then lost right and one
game he actually Drew but he should have
lost that one too as well same story
with Wesley these guys got to get better
a little bit better in that time manager
yeah hey what is going on with Fabi
right now with latislav dropping low on
time but still winning the game yeah
it's hard to pinpoint exactly what's
going wrong Fabi is playing well in
general his openings have been great of
course as usual but as James mentions it
is the time I mean I'm hypocritical if
I'm going to criticize anyone's time
management but for Fabi that has been
the decisive Factor end games not quite
matching our time if especially in the
last one and the clock
big round four coming up will we have
armageddon's it is time for our panel
board in chat tell us what do you think
which one of these two will go into an
Armageddon guys James I'm gonna start
with you on this one there's no
armageddon's right now I feel like these
are all decisive matches right now I
mean it's either draw or win right
that's it I mean of course it depends on
who has white obviously in these
situations here I mean maybe you can
push maybe you cannot but there's a lot
of pressure on you you know you're
facing elimination here I mean half a
point half a point away in the next game
over yeah
are you going to see an Armageddon I'll
say fabi's gonna strike back oh I don't
see Wesley though Hikari just too strong
at the moment too resourceful yeah yeah
one of his players to beat in the world
in the situation if he didn't lose the
third game it's hard for me to see him
losing the fourth especially because
Wesley's confidence might be a little
bit rough but I agree with David about
Fabiano his preparation the great his
leading the clock has been huge he just
needs to put artemia away the clock is
ticking Wesley so does start with the
white pieces but what a win missed him
in the previous round but Hikaru
Nakamura known for his resourcefulness
he did not make it possible and there he
is wow he kind of looked a little
surprised with Wesley's choice of
opening David yes because Wesley nearly
always goes one E4 against him but he
switched it up uh Wesley so here he's
going for the English shout out to the
English opening and uh yeah I like it
he's keeping pieces on the board keeping
tension and he's asking Naka new
questions uh not something that they
play time and time again against each
other which is a good sign for Wesley so
reacting with C6 getting ready to build
upon Santa what do we think of this this
is a sort of a reverse dragon in a way
of reverse Sicilian and that is usually
a lot of times I like yeah this is
actually a line from of chessable course
obviously Simon Williams actually has
this uh where he covers a lot of this
you actually go Knight B3 and you do a
pawn set line Knight B3 you actually
play D3 and then after e takes D3 you go
Bishop G2 you don't even care about the
pawn you actually end up casting so he
went E3 though Knight B3 is usually the
more sharper stuff but he went with a
more solid line yeah and uh Hikaru when
he looks up like that he's normally
trying to record that opening theory of
course playing very quick very
confidently early in this game he's
almost at 15 minutes still and uh even
if he was surprised in the opening he's
not showing it Wesley the first to think
and that's the good thing about akara I
would say right even when he's caught
off guard he still plays quickly and he
still has confident play levana Ronin
actually plays in a similar style uh the
top players sometimes they just go in a
deep think you know they're really
thinking uh Lavon when he plays quickly
he's not always necessarily in his
preparation he is just showing his might
over the board Hikaru he knows this
opening but I think he does that as well
yep interesting it's basically a C3
Sicilian one of your favorite openings
James uh with colors reversed right just
uh white sex remove of playing Pawn to
G3 maybe he wants to take it back
there's some really weak light squares
in White's camp
that's gonna count right these
weaknesses that you're pointing out in a
white scam and Hikaru playing
aggressively in the center I'm always
worried when a player starts thinking
out of the opening James is Wesley
feeling a little uncomfortable no yeah
something he doesn't play a lot of
course here I mean E3 is already
something it's just a different line ip3
is usually more of the mainline ways of
playing or the more Modern Way of
playing is with the Knight B3 line E3 is
just solid very cool but I think the
problem here is choosing the diagonal in
fact in the reverse here actually Roman
DZ slapped the keyboard right when uh
with him in fact colors reverse when
you're playing accelerated Dragon here
the problem is like you can't have the
diagonal you got to choose where's the
bishop gonna go G2 where is artemia
playing from the Invisible Man yeah yeah
I love it he on the toilet we got the
phone right now on the wireless mouse
you know this day and age it's really
helpful where is he this is
he really might be on the toilet right
silly playing from the from there in
fact I think Magnus said he was doing
something like that before that's uh
insane here and the moves are happening
you still know her on the screen what is
happening then this should be set Heaven
from where telepathically chat we need
your help where is vladislava where in
the world is he how is he making the
moves happen who knows it's
oh there he is what just happened he's a
magician
I'm here I'm here I appeared it's not
just when he's got one minute on the
clock that he's full of Tricks he's full
of magic tricks even now and that must
be scary for Fabiano if he's got the
camera up on the zoom call that's crazy
whoa whoa all right but not such a crazy
opening this looks pretty familiar David
yep it is a branch of the Auntie Berlin
white not allowing the Berlin end game
with all of its drawish Tendencies so
Fabiano keeping all the pieces on the
board the game will take a slower Pace
but that's what Fabiano needs at least
for now he needs to keep the tension and
hope that vladislava I'll tell him
cracks a bit later on uh if Abby can
keep the pace that he's shown in the
first three games for the first kind of
90 then he's got a good chance but uh
it's that last 10 where his uh play has
been lacking as Robert mentioned lack of
Killer Instinct for Fabi and uh that
time trouble panic but uh early days
it's looking promising for a full uh
full-blooded fight
is that a strategy Robert just get a
Vlad low on the clock and then find the
chances I think Vlad just gets himself
low on the clock there's nothing you can
do about it you can't be like hey play
faster Planet he said no no no time
troubles my friend but I think for uh
Fabiano he has great wealth of
experience and knowledge in these
Spanish structures so he is where he
wants to be artemiev he dabbles with a
variety of openings he plays the
Sicilian every now and then he plays the
Carol Khan today he's been playing E5
but I think Fabi he's not unhappy with
the opening but I think he was quite
dejected when he threw away that end
game he could have made a draw I
actually looked through it he could
afford hit a repetition he chose not to
do it he ended up losing the game so it
was kind of his fault and I'm sure he's
kicking himself for it yeah that's
always the most heartbreaking defeat
right when it's self-inflicted when you
had a winning position you threw it away
you were too stubborn uh to go for the
draw and suddenly Things Fall Apart and
Fabi needs to pick himself up it does
help kind of resetting when your
opponent is tanking early in the opening
like this that is Love on time what's he
thinking about this is a very standard
type of position surely he's analyzed
something similar to this before you go
to play by Instinct but now Fabi will be
gaining in confidence every moment that
Artemis hesitates and waits I've never
seen her to me of grab his head like
that I know right it's just that Fabiano
actually is making him more emotional
he's giving him some emotions that but
of me it's not working like nothing's
working against our team here like what
is this it gets low on time it gets
itself low on time and then he becomes
some just super engine like play it's
insane precise and everything and with
no time on the clock it's a very very
strange force to be recognized maybe
Fabi is his favorite player so he feels
bad that's why he's getting emotions I
don't want to do this to you buddy I
really like your play I'm sorry bro
there's a reason why a lot of slavors
that we have is the only player who beat
Magnus Carlsen in the world a rapid
Championship the one game that Magnus
lost he then go on to win the World
rapid Championship but he lost to
vladislavartame and here Vlad is on fire
but he's taking his time again big
questions one more time why is he
thinking right out of the opening he's
still recovering from that magic trick
earlier he's just catching his breath
there but uh okay he finally does move
he kicks back that white ship which
Retreats the whole way and uh which
setup is Ultimate of going to go for
here there's a bunch of ways black can
arrange his pieces white will step
forward in the center over the next
couple of turns and you've got to be
ready for that but it's still very
standard if you study the Spanish
opening pretty much you will have had a
position similar to this on your board
so to spend this much time this early
it's the type of thing I do and regret
immediately but it's not the type of
thing we should expect from the world's
top players strange hard to explain yeah
not at all I do the same thing so I'm
also like David guilty of this I spend
way too much time in a position I played
dozens and dozens of times so for our
temmiev he's really just trying to
figure out where to take this game and
he's playing this very solidly he goes
rookie it oftentimes black could have
decided to strike in the center with
Pawn to D5 he may still do that but that
loosens his guard of the E5 Pawn so any
pawn push you make there are weak
squares left behind you could create
some Targets in your own camp and our
attemptive he's just trying to be as
solid as possible right now yeah and I
like fabi's approach just easy plans for
white this white knight is going to
relocate it's going to rotate over
towards the G3 Square in front of the
white king it's going to park itself on
that square actually the Maneuvers are
very simple very straightforward very
thematic for white you will have seen
them all before but he's asking autumnif
how are you going to move where are you
going to put your pawns it's going to be
a question every time for our time we
have I'll tell me if we'll have four or
five logical moves on every turn that
means clock will be burned and uh here
we go again he's just playing a quiet
move there Fabi not threatening anything
and artemia does spend quite a bit of
time yeah he doesn't care about burning
the clock once he's got no time he burns
the position and our time you have after
taking a bit of a tank falls back with
the Knight now David you were talking
about plans for black often in these
positions we see black Advance those
Central pawns is that what we're
expecting next from our Damian I think
it's quite likely uh our 10 minutes last
move might look mysterious to those
uninitiated in this type of opening but
the idea is to Simply Park this Black
Knight on the G6 Square in front of the
black nice and safe white is likely to
do the same for example we could see a
maneuver such as this and actually
something similar happened in a game
between Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
earlier in the day these Knights kind of
mirror each other protect their kings
threaten to maybe jump forward later
it's all about who can strike in the
center first and quite likely white will
be the one occupying the center black
will be reacting and actually this has
happened in the game different move
order but same ideas and at the right
time Artemis might try to release the
tension either by pushing his Pawn in
the center maybe he'll park his Bishop
on this square and put pressure on the
central pawns from afar either way uh
still very typical stuff I'll tell me if
though it needs to speed up absolutely
yeah the Royal Affairs is actually a
card also the Spanish torture in fact
they call it there because of just how
long and maneuvering and like so it's
just boring right but of course I mean
it's such a rich opening there's so many
ways and strategies and and plans that
you can do I mean obviously in ig3 I've
even seen G4 Knight G3 I've seen A4 I've
seen Bishop G5 Bishop E3 I mean it
depends on how you want to go here based
off of what black black setup is here
black is flexible too I actually like
this 97 Knight G6 line it's very rare I
would say I'm used to seeing Knight B8
brayer style or Knight A5 with shigor
and C5 going back with Knight C6 and Roy
Lopez so this is a definitely different
I like how he moved his Knight around to
G6 looks more of like a um Italian game
but the bishop 108 is very bad usually
you'll see in fact Magnus from the black
side likes to play G6 Bishop G7 there
and it's just a common idea to reroute
the bishop to a better Square because
it's gross on f8 right now yeah that
could be the problem piece eventually
long term for vladislavartamev again in
the tank
very surprising but I think rich is the
right word there James you mentioned it
uh Rich because it's got so many ideas
for both sides so many different move
orders nobody can memorize an exact
antidote against the Spanish because
your opponent would play a move in a
slightly different order and it changes
everything and of course Fabiano caruana
Magnus Carlsen these kind of specialists
in the Spanish opening they use it when
they're trying to grind down their
opponents so I like it from a must win
perspective by Fabi and Fabi is kind of
a perfectionist we know that he is a
calculator he wants to play objective
best moves every single time but here he
needs to be pragmatic he needs to punish
Gladys Knight return of on the clock a
lot of someone's gonna think no matter
what he does that's clear at this point
we are in standard opening Fair artemium
has played like this before so if you're
Fabi just keep playing those quick moves
that is what Hikaru Nakamura does so
well he says this time and time again
you play good moves quickly rather than
the perfect move slowly when you're in
this kind of time control and Artemis he
lashed out with C5 Fabi closes the
center with D5 and this is classical
stuff at this point yeah classical stuff
and I love that approach because if
you've got to play on the clock you want
and all your pieces on the board it's
not just all your pieces it's all the
pawns on the board as well no trades
happen it is about playing on our time
uf's clock that is fabi's strategy well
it's clear he needs to find a way to win
this one to force an Armageddon
otherwise he does go down to the
elimination bracket on the other hand
Wesley so also needs to win his game
against Hikaru Nakamura and the Queens
have been traded but there is a lot of
tension in the center look at that
evaluation bar right whoa massive on
white side wow white has the better the
bishop pair better long-term chances but
black has some threats Black's Knight is
attacking White's D4 Pawn that pawn in
the center
what is happening here it must be some
something immediate something in this
position because if black gets one or
two moves you can imagine everything
disappearing from the center and the
play being level maybe Hikaru doesn't
realize how bad it is I'm trying to
figure out as well myself is there a
strong move here I'm gonna take a lesson
from James and I was about to say this
this is wonderful because it gives up a
Central Pawn but James said earlier
sometimes white gives up a Central Pawn
and ignores it just develops castles so
he's giving up a pawn that Knight can
capture that pawn in the center but once
that happens I think the white king can
castle queenside and blacks kings in the
center Bishop takes F6 is happening in
the near future I'm shattering your Pawn
structure and winning that pawn back on
D5 or E4 so James I mean you called this
out earlier it's the same exact theme
and a car could be in big trouble here
wow again getting those Queens off early
maybe playing too much for the draw and
he's in trouble Hikaru Nakamura uh what
a move this is just great vision as well
to see the after Knight takes born you
can Castle Queen side it wouldn't be on
the radar of most players including
myself hey I've got to win it but once
you see it you see how strong it is you
not only get your king to safety but you
bring your Rook into the action with
Tempo Tempo is so important in the
opening uh you're kind of indirectly
hitting this Knight as Robert says
indirectly as well attacking pawns after
capturing this one massive trouble for
black and maybe it's too late you've
kind of burned your Bridges you've
traded off the Queens this Pawn is weak
no matter what this Pawn is weak no
matter what everything is falling
imagine a structure like this I've got
to put it on the board porn takes pawn
bishop takes nine okay look at this
structure double door what is that what
is that Shale like a deer head or
something what the heck is that wow all
of them we can all of them probably
gonna fall this could be the wreckage of
nakamura's structure if he captures the
pawn in the center big trouble yeah for
him and suddenly a girl goes into a
thing it looks like he's he relies after
Bishop G5 that it's not as easy as it
might have seemed to him this position
with black the fact that Wesley's just
sacrificing to Pawns in the center it's
an angry Wesley he is looking for that
win he came so close to it in round
three as well that was a moment where
you're on a car's face it rendered an oh
bleep
Oh I thought I was just developing I'm
attacking the center and now with one
simple bishop move his position is about
to completely collapse the Pawns in the
center are all hanging this bishop is
threatened to ruin the pawn structure on
the king side as well and I feel like
for her car Nakamura for a second game
in a row he's feeling the full force of
Wesley so's might I love it this is the
Wesley we love to see we need to see
this more often this ambitious play by
him James absolutely of course I mean in
fact I was reading up just on like the
history of Wesley and I remember this
this reading but like as David mentioned
before he was very aggressive growing up
he was just a very aggressive player I
mean I guess you see this a lot of from
very strong players now that we're
younger when they were younger they were
very like aggressive Hikaru same way and
as he got better and stronger they
played a little bit more solid because I
always thought Wesley was just solid
like this and just like boring because
he likes Queen he was like my favorite
opening is Queen's game of decline I'm
like bro bro you were ridiculous right
but at the same time you know he was
very aggressive and he still has that
went back to his roots as David said
going back to the roots playing some
aggressive chess here right and it looks
like it's working yeah when he turns off
his brain when he turns off those
emotions that Fear Factor disappears and
uh when he doesn't care he's a dangerous
opponent and yeah he's shown it the last
game almost getting there now this one
big big favorite but costly and queen
side Robert
it's got to be the way to go I think
he's just considering do I first capture
the Knight with the bishop and then
Castle Queen said I'm feeling very
positive that he will Castle queenside
but move order is very important in
chess maybe there's some other move that
hikara can consider if white initially
castles Queen side that may help him
over there on the king side so I think
that Wesley he's doing the right thing
calculating right now because he knows
he will have the upper hand whatever the
move order is always the question how
much time is too much time when you're
playing against Hikaru you know he is
going to be asking you the questions on
every single move so you have to not
burn the clock as much and he finally
takes the decision this is what you were
talking about long Castle
he is looking for the win in this one
how much trouble is Hikaru in with that
King in the center I would say a lot I
would be panicking here I would be
sweating uh it just looks like there are
too many threats Bishop takes knightport
takes porn everything opening up on the
central lines that we highlighted a
minute ago James do you see any wave for
her to even survive the next few moves
sure I don't have seen anything this is
a very scary position I mean and then
looking at casting again and then Bishop
takes F6 and you literally have like it
looks like the almost the box logo you
know with the uh with the the pawn
structure looking like some type of
mystical animal it's very crazy look at
this Pawn structure it looks like a a
composed puzzle or something that you
may like find a maiden 11 right whatever
that's it because this this never
happens right this is a terrible
structure and this is really really bad
I'm I'm definitely don't find a move
here maybe you have to just castle like
because you have to get the king off the
center I mean that's for sure if you
Castle however then I'm not sure whether
you take the Knight but Pawn takes porn
look how many targets there are on this
defile I'm glad I don't have to play
this position that's all I'm saying okay
wow oh bad times her car not camura
Brook's not connected I mean this is
terrible yeah I mean Garo has an extra
Pawn but it counts for nothing in this
position his King is weak the pawn
structure as you're pointing out
everything in the center hanging and he
is getting down on the clock Hikaru not
liking his position shaking his head and
I don't think this time he is being
deceitful about his Expressions not even
a Hoover could clean up this mess
is ruined his King is in the center his
pieces are all in line with an enemy
Rook he has very few options here but we
know Hikaru Nakamura can survive
positions that look like he is just
about to resign so Hikaru he needs to
find a couple moves here but I feel like
for Wesley he should be confident he was
out playing hikara for the majority of
the first game he blundered a piece in
one move very uncharacteristic of Wesley
so so two games in a row he has just
gotten the brute force method and he's
taking it to Nakamura and Hikaru has
looked like the slightly worse player in
the two games
wow yeah I completely agree and
especially in this opening phase okay he
brings this Rook across I'm surprised by
that one maybe lining up a nasty sneaky
night check but can Wesley just Shuffle
his King out the corner that'll be my
first instinct before I even start
calculating I'm sure Wesley will
calculate maybe he'll find something
even stronger but when in doubt Play
Safe and uh that white King's Super safe
and hey girl let's use a a capture on D3
he doesn't care about opening up the
e-file and the pawn structure that
you're talking about is this Brave or
desperation
trap at least Pawn is captured exactly
he set up some trap he set up some good
stuff he got the extra post all right I
grabbed another Pawn from you and also
uh I mean Bishop F5 is an annoying move
Bishop F5 D2 check and like Knight C2
and geez or even almost Knight B3 Rook
A8 it almost is there it's not there yet
but it's almost there like I mean this
there's some threats here there's some
tricks and if anyone can do tricks I
mean we've seen that in the last game
with Wesley it's done it's going to be
or yeah and uh he looks optimistic
actually on his camera Hikaru Nakamura
first I would wreck the black porn
structure just aesthetically it's too
tempting giving black that pawn
structure that we mentioned of course
you can't take this Pawn because you do
walk into the pin uh along this diagonal
or or maybe you can I'm not sure but uh
evaluation bar not too fussed by this
which is incredible I was Bishop E4
there whoa James what a shout what a
cool Bishop E4 and uh or Knight E4 maybe
even uh the idea is to give up a piece
just to block the diagonal and you can
actually snack on that black knight and
the game goes on that's crazy never
gonna happen though sure it's too crazy
yeah but uh I was gonna say maybe you
flick in this one and you take this Pawn
uh at least that would be my first
instinct you take this Pawn next or this
Pawn with check but the question is
whether black can flick in uh this
bishop move and create some counter play
you mentioned this Checkmate I want to
show it on the board James talk us
through this one for example if I
and then King A1 and hopefully you're
doing your puzzle Rush tactics here a
lot of people will love Knight C2 but it
doesn't work you're gonna be three boom
in fact boom maybe three Pawn takes and
rookie mate and get him off the board
getting off the board this is a family
channel let's get this off the screen
off the screen but actually we could be
heading in this direction if Hikaru puts
his Bishop on this Square I'm not sure
he's going to but it looks very tempting
to me yeah white has a great response to
Bishop 5 there are all sorts of tactics
in the position you can interpose with
your own Bishop Bishop E4 it looks like
you're just throwing away a piece but if
the bishop is captured Knight takes Pawn
that is checked to the king and back to
the bishop you take the bishop the D3
Pawn will fall next white will be up at
least one Pawn maybe more because
Black's King is still in the center and
a rook is sliding in for white as well
this looks terrible Robert be doing
puzzle Rush chat make sure you're doing
your puzzle Rush at home okay puzzle
rush we want to see it in the chat we're
supposed to rough score wow that's a
nice trick trumpet fish should be for
just challenging that Bishop on F5 which
is why Hikaru isn't rushing in with this
idea he spotted that the main thread
doesn't work Robert finding that
repetition but if not Bishop F5 look at
that pawn structure it's just collapsing
for black yeah it's uh the most flimsy
edifice I've ever seen those Pawns and
aesthetically of course ugly for black
he's trying to keep it together here
with tactics with tricks and that's why
we're talking about puzzle rush because
if the tricks don't work in Black's
favor game over and uh yeah I love that
geometry of the white Bishop interposing
he's got his King out of the way so now
some of those tricks won't work things
won't come with check again ugly move
especially that black rook in the corner
on h8 not a happy piece right now but uh
at least the tactics might work for
Hikaru if his King won't get checked
what's really annoying is how
resourceful he is because King f8 is a
very strong move now you actually are
looking at Bishop F5 and that's a very
annoying one you still can't take the
pawn I thought Knight B6 was probably
best here like just get to stuff and
he's done it anyway you big fella oh my
goodness and then D2 Knight C2 check but
then where do we go after that let's put
that on the board that would just be a
repetition then yeah if you get greedy
setting this up yeah if you take this
Rook suddenly a discovered check and
Hikaru will progress to the next round
because the King has to move you throw
in a night check the King has to move
and double check this time hitting the
king with the Knight and the bishop and
there's nowhere to go you simply have to
repeat the position with the draw
instead the bishop was kicked back but
still the same tactic on tap here along
this diagonal how do we evade this how
do we get out the way yes
that's a big move he has five kill the
bishop whoa and the black Rook has dived
in jumped in both besides creating
threats here on every turn
or take that pawn on B7 get the bish
op and then you're throwing Pawn F4 to
F5 trapping the bishop on G6 and then
white goes into mop up Duty so this
looks really promising for Wesley Hikaru
though doing a good job he's trying to
wheel himself back in as the head Bob
here is not because he loves his
position but he's like I do actually
have chances at the moment yeah he's
still alive at least for another few
more moves and Wesley down to three
minutes we've talked so much about the
clock today it was always come back to
haunt the side that drops down and uh
kind of struggles to navigate those
complications when they come against a
car you need a few minutes in the bank
in your back pocket for later I do fear
for Wesley could he blow it again due to
the clock just get your pressure out of
the way I think that's the first
instinct Robert's right why not take a
pawn if you can you know if he takes a
pawn I think I was looking at King G7
and an F5 Rook G Rook B8 takes and The
Rook takes B7 hitting B6 and uh hitting
B2 we might find out James we'd like to
see right now he says you can't I mean
you have to do something about this he's
going to move he's going to take this
Pawn on D3 after F5 so King G7 does make
sense you activate the Rook Rook B8
coming in and I'm going to hit the
bishop connect it to the Knight and you
can hit B2 as well but maybe he can go
back to A4 let's just show this on the
boards uh King G7 looks like the most
natural totally agree uh the pawn move
stepping forward the black Rook shifting
across this is a skewer the two pieces
two minor pieces attacked but the engine
is not impressed of course maybe you
just leave this bishop you leave it on
G6 it's trapped anyway you start mopping
up on the other side of the board Rook
takes Pawn Rick takes bishop and now
Rook takes Knight takes takes and at the
end this Rook this is everything just in
time to win my goodness there's so many
captures there there's so many tactics
here so what is he gonna come up with
that magician here he needs some magic
indeed oh you look at agaro it looks
like he does realize that he is in a big
trouble still thinking he's up two
minutes on the clock but not an easy
position to navigate Wesley so could
make a comeback in this one wow he stops
it with his own F5 but this just means
that Bishop on G6 at least
yeah that black Bishop is the most sad
unhappy depressed piece I've seen in a
long time but uh Hikaru he's keeping his
hopes Alive by going for someone's white
pawns if those white pawns on the king
side disappear the black Bishop might
breathe life again in future so uh he's
kind of abandoned everything on the on
one flankaru but he's going for the
other side of the board he kind of
looked over at the camera like a bit
guiltily there he was like yup I'm still
fighting forgive me please uh yeah how
critical is it for Wesley to defend that
at football and he says I don't care I'm
Coming For That Big Pawn on G6 H4 H5 is
a thread on the board wow that's a great
move because I mean everyone would just
take this Pawn on D3 it's a free Pawn
but what hikar was trying to do is take
on F4 and that Bishop that's been
trapped by its own Pawn see which moved
he was trying to spring it free and wow
a card is going less that's ridiculous
every move is tricky it's so tricky he
is just such a difficult player to face
he just sets up these traps and he's so
fast at it and he's so precise with it
it's scary to play against nobody want
to play him nobody ever wants somebody
man give me my ball I'm going home you
know what I mean like that kind of thing
like nobody wants to play Caro that's
just kind of annoying like when you're
winning you're not winning yet you know
what I mean you have to be the fact they
say you have to beat him once in the
right opening middle and game like and
in tactics and on clock and uh you know
the air they breathe in like what the
heck is this man this is crazy he's
making so he's making practical problems
like he did in the last game yeah
Wesley's played I don't know how many
genius moves in a row like 10 fantastic
excellent moves double exclamation mark
moves but he's still not won the game
the Clara is still fighting still
docking still punching and uh will there
be some tricks and traps ahead okay the
black king moving the evaluation Bar
says white should be doing well but look
at it it's dropping every move because
from a human point of view it's
difficult it's not easy maybe that black
Bishop moves jumps in to E2 to attack
the white Rook
odyss Hikaru got up his sleeve now for
sure there's going to be some type of
trick some type of tactic it's not easy
anymore maybe the black Rook is the one
at some point it's going to come over to
B8 as well some pins over there first
you have to defend this black Bishop
whoa what type of move is that the best
move probably because you saw the eval
bar it approves it says that Hikaru is
still in the game I don't know how he
does it but Bishop G4 on the board look
at the clock for Wesley once again he's
getting low on time he's getting low on
time every time this happens what
happens it's not good every time he's
been low on time the history repeats
itself and that's because Hikaru is so
tricky he is going to set a trap on
every move you need those seconds to
navigate through the complications
getting a winning position against this
guy is just not enough Wesley with a big
Advantage Robert will he be able to
convert this one but now it's anything
but clear because the F4 Pawn black is
multiple piece attacking that Rook on F2
for black is attacking not just that
pawn but also the B2 Square in front of
the white king and the black Rook that
has been sitting on h8 this entire game
it's ready to jump on over to B8 and
start threading not just the bishop but
the pawn behind it so all of a sudden
black has a legitimate attack and
White's a pawn is one move too slow if
you could go A5 in one turn if you just
put it there you're winning the game on
the spot it's going forward to A6 A7 and
A8 but it's a little bit too slow he
puts his Bishop on A6 but the evil bar
goes back to level oh my goodness that I
mean he's he's walking into some night
folks some night jumps secondly how are
you actually going to answer this threat
against your pawn it looks like you're
stepping forward but now I'm jumping oh
man you're right Knight F4 first
everything's hanging okay over K3 or D6
yeah this is really scary suddenly right
there's no time oh he's 20 seconds yeah
that's it this is it yeah I was going he
car was going to the ship Right double
attack that's it and uh let's go back to
the players
at least at least a draw yeah he started
again
yeah there's some time he's done it
again it's 12. down two Pawns
yet tactics and now is Wesley the one
who's in trouble you can jump in with a
check capture that B2 Pawn
you know what I actually thought it was
ricegum because I couldn't believe the
fact that he played Bishop C4 I was like
no he can't I mean you can't allow me to
take on B2 can you repeat two I guess
he's saying A2 defended yeah A2 is
defended there could be some tricks that
Wesley has up his sleeve because upon F7
the bishop is in line with it there
could be threats towards the black king
so I'd be very very nervous here for
both players because that Bishop Muncie
for it defends the white king and also
attacks the black king like your point I
think the point that you're trying to
make Robert just to finish that off that
eighth that eighth rank Rook moves
anywhere then White's the one who steps
up with his own rook and don't forget
that G8 Square it could be a check made
on that that would be a big trouble for
black skin just to show actually taking
this is a huge blunder to be more
natural if you move your Rook for
example you get mated simple as that
it's the black king not the white king
that gets trapped 13 seconds
for Wesley now to fight against this
what a genius move though Bishop C4
dropping it back saying please take this
Pawn it's poisoned if you take this Pawn
Hikaru you will lose this game uh why
what else could it be maybe it's the
other room maybe it's the other Rook
what's the evaluation about gonna say it
says yes and the King moves but now what
do you play maybe the idea is to get rid
of this thorn in the side by dropping
your knight into the center but this is
not easy you eliminate the piece that
might trap the black king who's
checkmating who that's the question up a
pawn there and so it's not clear who has
the edge we have the evaluation bar
saying yeah it's Dynamic equality it's
clearly an equal position no of course
not right they're looking this like this
is crazy it's Mayhem and you see Hikaru
he's down to two minutes he's been
spending nearly two minutes on this turn
he knows it's a critical moment and he's
not sure what to do by the way Fabiano
caruana it looks like has a massive
advantage against artemia whoa wow
Armageddon everyone I mean we don't know
actually we gotta be you know never know
going up in this game too so both
players with the white pieces carwana
and here Wesley so they're doing well in
H5 going for the king oh that black king
is in big big trouble and six seconds on
the clock Wesley if he can land
checkmate with two seconds left he's
gonna be happy but it's gonna be so hard
to navigate this one and while Wesley
has six seconds left our Tamia is down
to five seconds and it looks like
Fabiano caruana will be making a
comeback in his game if we can just
quickly get an update on that one
what is happening Rook F7 is a maiden
one let's stay right here I think you
can just take the bishop I was thinking
the same thing and then you repeat you
have to go King E7 Rook D7 wait but I
have key six I'm running away how am I
not winning yeah black is running away
there's no Checkmate if there's no
Checkmate it's a free piece and Hikaru
might be closer to that draw you have to
worry about a few captures here and
there white H6 Pawn might become a new
Queen in some lines
everything's happening it's so
complicated I think we need stockfish
the computer to suggest moves oh 987 I
think is a draw I think that's probably
the way it's not enough oh you're right
yeah John's Ross not enough I was just
trying to figure out why is this draw
yeah yeah it's just a drawer
look at a girl who knows it he's
calculating what he knows he's done it
yeah that's it just go towards the night
what's wrong with that one and then
check and you can't go to the corner I
think because
he needs to win yeah it's desperation
trading pieces was not going to get it
done he wants to bring the Knight back
but where does Trump it's trapped
exactly this is going to be a win for a
car yeah oh that's that's that's tricky
don't take that knife eight seven and
you're not going to be able to save that
bond from promoting you're not going to
stop that bond in your face that's a
that's such a sweet move night of Faith
wow if you had to take pieces in Chess
this would be a winning move but black
can reject the offer just defend the
pawn that the White Knight wants to come
back and take and I think you should be
fine drop back to black Bishop for
example drop back to black Rook I'm not
sure which one but it should be fine
hikaru's got less than a minute he's a
piece up what what what what
because the black Rook can drop down
with a check and go behind save the day
yeah so well these players are so good
I've got to say drop that Rook down
Hikaru and you will not lose this game
he does it how does he find there's just
amazing stuff by Hikaru and Rook H1 he's
gonna take the queen and this end game
only black can try yeah and he doesn't
need to win the game so he just a draw
sends him through to the winners final
he is trying to make a draw right now he
does not want to win he just wants to go
through yeah you have to be slightly
careful where you put your pieces but
now he's bringing the black king across
the black Bishop is able to guard the
promotion square of the white porn the
white Pawn promotes on light squares
Black's Bishop will guard that will even
give itself up if it has to and this
should just be a draw if anyone's better
it's got to be back especially with this
extra Pawn we have here too as well we
can sack and we'll have an extra piece
and the pawn making you have to maybe
even sacrifice your Rook for uh for the
pawn and we end up having a drawer wow
this looks like Hikaru will be advancing
to the Winner's bracket final let's go
back to the other game because Fabiano
Carona is making a comeback on the board
and on the clock look at that black king
it is under Fire and how many pawns is
that three extra Pawns of Fabi he's not
gonna mess this one up he's surely not
needed though he ain't made it yet
it's not me yeah yeah James is always
like that he's our champion is down
under five seconds now our Tammy is
doing well he's fine he's okay he's okay
guys he's fine I like what fabby's done
he's just protected everything look at
those Knights they're each other's best
friend here defending protecting and the
White Queen will eventually break
through you can throw a Central Pawn
forward here if the white Rook gets into
the attack that black king is on an open
line but first he's protecting
everything three pawns up you don't need
to Checkmate when you've got three extra
pawns and it is official Nakamura has
drawn his game against Wesley which
means Wesley moves on to the losers
bracket while Hikaru continues in the
Winner's bracket while action's still on
here David you called it that Fabi will
level this one and we will get an
Armageddon it looks likely but I'm not
going to I'm not going to write him off
just yet vladislava tell me if he's so
resourceful remember he beat Magnus in
an Armageddon as well so even if it does
get there then uh Fabi will have his
work cut out but meanwhile the attack's
gone White's King Super safe three extra
pawns what more can you say I think I
could bring one more piece into the
attack the Knight on E1 maybe it's time
to hop that one forward we just got out
of a pin let's bring that Knight to
deliver the Checkmate it looks like the
last piece you would think to help out
but the Knight can jump forward to D3
hitting the Rook back there then
continue there it goes the knight's
coming into F4 and over to G6 yeah oh
nice do it now bring that Knight in and
that will be the Hammer Blue the final
touch to this game really nice game from
Fabi you've got to say yeah
I mean I don't know how
pointed out Robert you call it check
pick up the bishop with a check and now
pick up the Rook you don't even need to
look for a mate it probably does exist
then move like Queen F5 Tottenham made
on G6 but what he does it what a guy
what a guy he says I don't want your
Rook I want and look at Savvy he knows
he's done what needed to be done to get
that win and vladislav our time you have
resigns what a nice comeback what a
brilliant finish there by Fabi yeah
because he finished what he started
every single game that we saw from and
it was well ahead on the clock he just
couldn't put artemia away in Artemis
time trouble yeah but this time he had a
huge I was keeping track he was up six
minutes on the clock and he made our 10
me a pay wow he finally got it done of
course yeah he had that lead every time
right and he was doing good and then we
like oh yeah and then and then he gets
alone time or timia and he does some
spectacular things in time trouble even
putting away Magnus twice with the same
amount of time right so but not this
time Bobby's like not this time I'm
tired of this and he finally was able to
clinch that I'm going we go to
Armageddon boys yeah Bobby strikes back
we will go into an Armageddon while
Hikaru does advance further let's do a
deep dive of this dramatic round with
David
yeah so much drama it's hard to even
pick a highlight Fabiano well played for
him he takes its Armageddon but I want
to highlight the game between Wesley so
and hikar and Nakamura Wesley so close
again to taking that win but not close
enough in this position he played a very
natural move he brought his Rook forward
but after rotates Bishop there was no
Checkmate Hikaru had grabbed a piece and
was safe if however Wesley had found the
genius move G6 we would have been
heading to Armageddon this is so
difficult for a human James right but uh
it's the clock if Wesley had five
minutes maybe the whole idea here is
that uh for example if Pawn takes now
you capture this Pawn the king moves a
check the king moves again and there's
this beautiful killer blow at the very
end it's so difficult to see
Bishops what the whole point is you
eliminate all the pieces and at the very
end White's night simply moves you make
a new Queen What A variation is this
never gonna be found by a human but
Wesley this was his chance
chess is a beautiful game and with that
let's take a look at our score line of
the Winner's bracket semi-finals we do
have action left as Fabiano caruana
managed to level the score and take it
to the Armageddon we will have the bids
of the players very soon exciting
exciting Armageddon coming up in the
other one Hikaru Nakamura what a match
that was he won in a game two kept it
solid throughout managed to save some
very difficult moments and with that won
his match against Wesley so let's bring
on the winner of that match Hikaru he's
joining us congratulations Hikaru
thank you guys appreciate it it worked
out
it did work out although even after
winning that second game you were in
trouble in game three and four
yeah well I mean in game three game
three I mean I simply confused my lines
early on
um and then I was just too passive and
probably at some point I was lost but
Wesley then made a huge blunder I should
have won the game as well so I mean the
third game could have gone either way
this fourth game probably I was in
trouble for most of it but once it was
kind of getting low on time and the
position was just a very chaotic um I
mean I think I I think I played really
really well to survive to the point when
I got this rugby Rook B2 but I think I
made a couple of bad moves there I
haven't looked yet obviously but it felt
like um felt like I had something and
then apparently there's a win with this
G6 move but you know it is what it is it
was a pretty much a bullet game at the
end yeah hakara you you played really
fantastic resourceful defense but I
actually want to ask you about the
opening choices because you played
Wesley so many times now so many
Berlin's how did you choose what
openings to play today
um I mean you just pick an opening you
play chess that's that's all I did I
mean it's not like my first game was
very inspiring
um you know the second game I think I've
played this line before in this Italian
with this whole d5d4 something very
similar to it
um I mean I just think the second game
was was the only game which was smooth
everything else was was choppy but you
just pick openings you play chess and
we've played each other probably
hundreds of times now if you include
rapid and Blitz and um yeah I just pick
something and roll the dice
hey Carl great play as usual bro what we
want to know is how are you so
resourceful what can we do to get a
little bit of a fraction of
resourcefulness like that
I don't know I mean I I don't think
there's any Secret in terms of how to do
it I think at the end of the day um it's
in the mind though if you believe in
yourself if it's in your mind that you
can do certain things good things happen
there you go
I'm Hikaru congratulations it must be a
relief to uh see the back of Wesley but
tomorrow you face uh vladislav or
Fabiano carawana who'd you rather play
I mean I I it doesn't matter at all
because I think by winning this match
I'm guaranteed to uh be in the top three
if if my math works out
um so I I think I top three guarantees a
spot in the next event that's really the
only thing that matters I mean as long
as you finish in the top three I don't
care I could finish third second first
it's it's all pretty relevant it's just
the fact that I um that I'm guaranteed
to play the next event I don't have to
go through the whole slog of playing the
qualifiers so that's that's what I'm
happy it doesn't matter who I play just
finishing top three is the only thing
that matters
the action and the drama in the
trustable Masters feels like a lot more
than we had in the first event are you
feeling this momentum as well with this
exciting mix of flares that we have
yeah I mean I I think um it's definitely
a little bit different I I guess what I
would say is I didn't have a chance to
look at all the games today but I think
yesterday there's a simple reason it was
exciting which is everyone was playing
like they were completely drunk
um so there were so many blunders in
every single match that I saw today I
don't know as much about
um but I think certainly when you don't
have the same set of top players in
every single event they're going to be
wild things happening you know and um
yeah it's just uh it's great to be on
the the winning end but I think at the
end of the day it's just trying to keep
finding resources trying to keep the
game going get your opponents low on
time and uh I seem to be doing a pretty
good job of that for someone who doesn't
play chess professionally
like or you keep saying that and then
you keep coming up with these big
results we stop believing you now with
the whole not taking chess
professionally I mean I am not playing
over the board shots other than a
handful terms a year so
um I I don't know what you want me to
say it's like you're trying to get me to
say something that gets clipped where
where I'm gonna sound like like really
arrogant or something but I mean the
simple fact is like I'm just doing what
I'm doing and it's I mean I'm not
studying as much chess now as I was four
years ago let's just be clear on that um
nowhere near as much so I mean it's what
it is and yet here you are re-entering
the world top five Hikaru we love it and
fantastic performance today all the best
for tomorrow
thank you so much you guys appreciate it
hey guys insisting that he is not a
professional Chester anymore I am not
buying that what a fantastic play and
performance there by him we've got big
action coming up with the Armageddon but
before that we are going to go into a
twitch break and a very special look at
our tammyev coming up he has been on
fire in this tournament
thank you
[Music]
I was born in um
so it's not a center of Russia not the
chess Center and the
in this city I make my first steps on
I just board and I also would like to
say that my father was just a Mater and
he to support me when I wanted to start
chess learning chess I would like to say
many friends to my father for this great
way I start learning chess probably
between
six and seven years I think that
immediately I have positive emotions and
my first good results
was quickly vladislav altamiyak became a
great chess player at an early age he
also became a father when he was quite
young his daughter Anna was born two
years ago we have a little child
and it's a very big day for me because
uh
many people
have dreams are to be parents and not
[Music]
so I very love my daughter and I hope
that
our waiting for many happiest days
I will show just the pieces
Bishops Rooks and I hope that it will be
interesting for her vladislav has dreams
for his daughter but he also has Big
Dreams for himself maybe in future I
would like to be a candidate on world
title maybe it's not easy but I will try
to improve my chest and training and
maybe I will have some chances I like
sport atmosphere and it's it's my life
and
all right tell me I was just such a nice
guy but it is time to go into an
Armageddon which just means that you've
got to put that being nice guy behind
you because that's the only way to win
the Armageddon of course we are waiting
for the players bids and the this these
are the regulations for the Armageddon
the player who bids the lower time wins
decides the color usually it's black
because black cats result odds which
means if it's a draw black wins the
match whoever gets white has to win on
demand but that means that white would
start with 15 minutes that is the base
time
Robert how important is it for the
players to get the black pieces you know
I this is an interesting match for me
because artemiev he had white against
Magnus a magnet is actually in a good
position and caught up on the clock but
then blundered his Queen at some point
and for Fabiano he's had a huge lead on
the clock every single game and against
Liam yesterday he won with the white
piece so I don't know what to choose
and it is mind game games going on right
now as we are waiting for the bids to
come in to reveal the bids it is about
how low can you go with your bid to get
those black pieces it's going to be
critical black gets result odds while
white has to win on demand but white
gets those extra minutes on the clock
David what are you expecting here well
normally with most players I think they
want black here I think both players
actually are very happy with the white
pieces Fabiano just one with white with
15 minutes a clock advantage against the
slightly slower tell me if why not
Artemis needs the time he took down
Magnus with white with 15 minutes but it
was close but yeah I can't see him
catching him up on the clock if he
starts with black James do you think
then we're gonna have very close bids
and perhaps not compromising on the
clock too much I think they're going to
be a little bit close but I actually
think I'm gonna take a curveball here
and say I think our team here is going
to bid low or he's care he does he he
thinks a lot but it's going to be like
you know I'll take black and I'll take
the less time but I'm gonna move fast
because he's actually really fast and
when he has low time he plays better as
strange as that is so I think that's my
pick there
we saw the players there making that bit
by our time you have expression love yes
how do they stay so in control
very calm we're gonna have bids really
soon
the player is talking to the staff
behind the scenes and I mean I think for
our temi over he won with the white
pieces against Bobby but Bobby was
better with black so I just don't know
what he's gonna do what his bid will be
is super unclear to me yeah I'm trying
to recall what they bid yesterday uh
vladislav I think was over 10 minutes
yeah and uh Fabi was against Liam also
over 10 over 10 minutes as well so it
might be very very close uh if I were
Vlad I would just bid 1459 just a secure
it banquet get those white pieces yeah
it almost feels like it doesn't matter
what he bits 20 moves into the game he's
going to be playing with a minute on the
clock and playing God lover chess might
as well take the black pieces right just
take the black pieces I got two options
draw or win right and I got low time and
I played better when I have low time
that's the sergeant yet
yeah sounds logical when you put it like
that James but these players yeah the
emotions are going to be racing of
course yeah sorry go ahead Robert
completely thought no this is so
difficult right because artemium he is
faster in time scrambles but he's slower
out of the gate so I just don't know who
prefers what yeah wow I can't wait to
see those bids I think it's going to be
dramatic either way and I think we're
going to see a decisive result on the
board I can't see either side playing
solid they just don't know how to play
for draws these days even though we did
have two draws between a Fabi and
artemia but both games they were fire on
the board our time was winning he
managed to survive and it is time to
reveal the player bit wow our Tammy had
made a 12 and a half minute bid that
makes a lot of sense not losing too much
time on the clock but Fabiano caruana
wins the bidding war he starts with 9
minutes and 59 seconds but gets the
black pieces yeah that's what he wanted
and as David was saying yesterday both
bid above 10 minutes so far we thought
maybe 10 minutes was the minimum that
our temmiev would go and his limbo was
just a little bit more Nimble for
Fabiano he gets the black pieces I think
he's very happy about this yeah so our
time we have starts with 15 minutes on
the talk that's almost that's a five
minute and a one second Advantage but
we've seen our time we have go down on
the clock that's gonna go level so James
basically Fabi gets result odds our time
you have has to go for blood he has to
go for blood he can't try his regular
Knight F3 so I mean let's try to go to
an end game and try to in-game him
because he even in-game Carlson right so
it's actually very important to get
something going here maybe play
something short we'll see
well David what are you expecting in the
opening well from Fabi it's just his
best repertoire his most solid
repertoire he shut down our teammate in
the first game of the day very
impressively with black in the third
game also very very impressive getting
an opening Advantage so it's about as
James says the opening for artemia from
Fabi it's clear his strategy the draw
but Automotive needs to handle those
extra five minutes really well he can't
tank he can't think early doors if he
does that Bobby's just gonna flag him
yeah Bobby's actually playing the better
chest between the two today Bobby's had
the advantage for a larger majority of
their games if I'm gonna blundered in
time trouble and lost that one but he
was better throughout and then in game
four he came back and smashed through so
I feel like Bobby should be confident
about his chest yeah in just a few
moments we will have the Armageddon the
players are getting ready to go David
Sabi did make a comeback winning that
game four do you think momentum is on
his side yes that's why I predicted he
would choose the white pieces I thought
he'd go for a win again he's just one
with white why not try again but uh he
needs to switch things up and momentum
might be on Fabi side but momentum is
out the window Armageddon is a lottery
it's just about who is more focused at
the time and uh we see the floating
chair will we see the move start coming
out well last time we have uh the
magician that he is is away from the
board we're just waiting for his
opponent to return to play the first
moves action is about to kick off did
you see that as well Fabio was literally
stretching his wrist he was literally
getting ready getting limber so I think
I might get work about to get this word
only flexible all right let's get it all
right you're probably ready Bobby's
ready right is that the warm-up to flag
your opponent by making really fast
moves yeah you gotta have that Mouse
speed so he's loosen up the wrist he's
making sure that he's going to be set
and for our team up he's just getting
back maybe he was giving his daughter a
good night kiss you know he was that
video he just said how important his
daughter is to him we see the cats in
the back so uh you know for our temio I
think he needs to put all that aside No
More Mr Nice Guy he's gotta go for the
kill
yeah dressed to impress her blood is
love about him can he match that on the
board uh his lucky outfit bringing him
luck yesterday against Magnus in the
Armageddon if you could take down Magnus
he's got to believe he can take down
Fabi too that's uh yeah it will be a
race I'm expecting Knight F3 something
solid and like you said James it didn't
work out earlier but he needs uh to find
a way somehow passed about these
defenses they've also ready 903 C4 so
let's see if we get her ready are we
ready
okay could it be I was gonna say could
it be the Queen's Gambit declined no no
Theory
wow and Fabi forced to think early in
this game okay he brings his Knight to
the edge this is not the typical London
uh both sides have flicked in this
little pawn move on the C file which
maybe isn't great news for Fabi normally
you want to break early in the center
with black against uh the London system
but he's forced this bishop to retreat
you don't want to allow a trade Knight
for Bishop early in the game Bishops are
prized very highly by these top players
and artemio's choice to play C3 that
early that's not typical either the
problem with playing Fabiano he studies
all the lines so you may think oh I'm
gonna catch him here he quickly brought
his Knight to the rim to attack that
Bishop so he is unafraid of this
unorthodox London and for temieuv he had
a big time advantage to start that time
Advantage might lessen if he keeps
spending uh so many minutes in the early
stages yeah I'm really surprised what
he's doing with his Bishop because the
white Bishop is just going to get caught
on the edge of the board is going to get
attacked and uh later on black will be
able to NAB the bishop pair first Fabi
brings this own Bishop out very logical
stuff and let you say Robert he's just
so well prepared how do you catch Fabi
in the opening I want to know it's uh
difficult and yeah so far looking good
for black and is that the reason that
he's chosen this slightly off-beat
opening that he doesn't usually play are
Tammy have just to avoid any theoretical
battles against Fabi
that is the logic but unfortunately uh
if you don't play theoretical lines
you're unlikely to get an advantage with
white and you need to win that's the
problem I'm just wondering here and I
think James I'm curious what your
thoughts are because I feel like for
artemia we know how good he is a bullet
over 3 100 right but do you think he can
get into that mental gear where he's
like I'm ready to take it down and just
flag you right you know what absolutely
in fact especially as strong as he is in
the bullet if I need to flag you I'm
just going to do that right especially
it's a gear that you just go into that
gear when you're playing bullet chess
you just oh it's just you you have that
intuition
um that's that uh the mouse beat you
know and that experience from playing so
much online chess here so when he needs
to he'll kick it in the next gear here
especially I mean this time Edge he has
right now is starting to diminish a
little bit
considering that
bring up for something that our time you
have can start considering already it's
certainly something he was considering
that he should consider but okay the
Black Knight is retreated anyway and it
cost him around a minute that is too
much in Armageddon chess with no
increment the five minute Advantage he
started with is around three minutes now
so he's lost two of his extra minutes
that's a bad sign it's so early in the
game the game will not be decided now
it'll be decided far far in the future
you need those minutes in the banking
Armageddon especially he's definitely
not switched out of that increment mode
that we saw from him earlier and C4 he's
lost a move that pawns moved twice it's
a very standard position now yeah this
is what you call off the head chest he's
just like moving pieces around like
let's play London well no let's play
like an accelerated London now and
unless I guess put the bishop on E2 and
just he plays off the head and
unorthodox in a way which can definitely
help especially if you can get fobby
thinking here but I mean Fabi has no
problems he got all these almost all the
pieces developed here I'm gonna Castle
get the queen maybe the C7 or E7 I'm
fine it says Fabi he's probably also
confident he's hasn't even spent a
minute thus far and artemiv once again
spending early minutes early uh minutes
in the game and I feel like for Fabi he
must be coming he won game four he only
lost game three due to a blunder of time
scramble so I think that he should be
happy with his chest I'm just worried
about his mouth speed I know he was
flexing that wrist stretching out but
when it comes down to those final
seconds he isn't the fastest player
amongst the elite yeah worried about our
Tommy house clock you're worried about
fabi's wrist I mean our tummy have
throughout the rapid potion has been
playing on minutes and seconds with no
increment on the clock if he lets that
happen it is match over he cannot afford
to go down on the clock in this one he's
got to keep the pressure up
yeah and I'm just looking at the peace
formations white started with the London
system but black pretty much has a
London system here itself with this nice
Bishops out nice central control that
triangle of Pawns in the center for
black wow I'm really surprised you went
back in this direction I thought he was
going to go the other way with the black
bishop and uh now I'm expecting Vlad uh
to throw pawns forward on the queen side
as fast as possible white has committed
he's locked close the center and
normally you want to play in the
direction that your pawns are facing
White's pawns are facing and towards the
left in that direction so you play on
The Queen side and likewise on the flip
side black tries to play in the center
on the other side of the board still
early days but at least now it will be a
long battle and that tends to favor the
side with more time if Vlad can maintain
that time advantage
it's a big if though if you maintain
that time Advantage because Fabiano has
spent only a minute and change thus far
so I feel like our team has a nice
looking position and he can keep it
closed for a while but he needs to speed
up I just feel like it's not really in
his nature to just Blitz out the opening
but he needs to actually switch that
mentality yeah he's too nice to flag
people that is part of the game in
Armageddon chess uh No More Mr Nice Guy
he needs to move two minute Advantage
incoming he's lost three of those extra
minutes what's he doing what's he
thinking about throw pawns forward
Castle the white king or something yeah
James oh no I had nothing I was just
saying right like yeah you're correct I
completely agree with David here yeah it
just looks like that's the obvious plan
right you start advancing on the side
where you've got your space Advantage
the queen side pawns can start rolling
up the board get your king to safety
it's really fascinating how our temmiev
chooses these moments which look like so
obvious and then he makes the move
Knight to D2 Retreats with the Knight I
wasn't expecting that I wasn't either I
think he's expecting some peace
exchangers just to jump in and explain
this really mysterious move if he played
maybe the most natural move uh I was
assuming this Pawn would jump forward
you want to create what we call a porn
storm here throw pawns forward open up
lines on the side you're stronger then
maybe black would have jumped in with
his own Knight these Bishops might
disappear uh along this diagonal maybe
the knights will disappear too things
would start to get traded heading
towards a draw he needs to win so he
can't allow this instead he drops back
his Knight we see black castle and could
he be considering playing on the
opposite flank what do we think oh yeah
absolutely that's the first move I was
gonna say I was going to say G4
absolutely but of course it looks like
he moved the bishop back to G3 but G4 is
definitely there he Castle G4 G5 I got
to play for a win but okay Bishop G3 is
possible yeah and then I could go Bishop
G3 now I'm fine with Bishop G3 and maybe
Rook G1 now I mean it feels good but
Bishop G3 was played he doesn't take
these risks he doesn't play aggressive
like that no he's just playing the long
game and uh next we'll see him push
these pawns forward but how does Fabi
strike out normally black wants to play
for this break in the center but how do
you arrange it at this precise moment
that square is sufficiently covered so
not easy actually to create counterplay
as Fabi and for the first time in the
game he's really having a long thing and
now we better understand artemio's
previous move he brought his Knight that
was developed in F3 and brought back to
D2 that bishop and queen they're lined
up across the diagonal there they're
covering the key Square so I feel like
he has decided to strike forward with B4
to protect that pawn C5 and black gets
into trying to create Pawn tension but
the pawn tension will remain white has a
little bit more space and I just feel
like black needs a strike in the center
at some point yep strike in the center
first he strikes on the queen side
playing on the side where he's a bit
weaker but maybe just trying to trade
things off and I'll tell me if now will
he just push his own a pawn forward just
to keep the structure intact there we go
normally you don't want to break your
Pawn structure unless you're completely
ready I do worry that the white king is
in the center still meaning there might
be some tricks that Fabi can utilize
will we see the Rooks leave the board as
well the Hoover's out the vacuum's up
yeah it depends on what they obviously
keep the tension here so if Rook takes
Queen takes but I guess you have Queen
A8 but then I Castle so you have to be
careful and not allow something like
Queen A6 to happen or even Queen A7 is
just kind of annoying right the pieces
get over there you can even have a
knight B3 to A5 in some cases if you
allow the white to get very active there
whoa did he just play evil whoa I did
breaking in the center why not and if
Pawn takes Pawn the Black Knight will
happily move I'm not sure where but uh
it could use this Square it might even
Retreat the whole way and actually this
Pawn is indefensible now this Pawn will
fall Black's night or Bishop will snack
on it next move and change of structure
who's a favor I'm not sure but at least
Fabi is getting active but at least not
balance right we don't have a
symmetrical Pawn structure anymore for
our temmie if you need winning chances
if you lose it's the same as the draw
you need something to happen but look at
Fabi we often hear the best way to play
for a draws to play for a win he's not
just sitting relaxing trading pieces
because he would be worse in almost
every single end game because he has the
weakest Pawn in the position that pawn
on C6 would be a Target as James was
indicating before so I do like this move
E5 he lashes out he is playing
aggressive standard thematic chess and
not just sitting and saying let's just
make a draw he's like no this is the
best way let's be concrete yeah nice
move there and if he opens things up
then maybe the black pieces will start
to enjoy life more and also the time
Advantage is being eaten up one and a
half minutes in it now vladislav needs
to move just get that white king castled
or take the pawn you need to decide
either you go for chaos take that pawn
it gets really unbalanced maybe good for
a must win situation or you Castle the
king to safety it's a stylistic decision
here he can't look too far into the
future uh he's trying to calculate a bit
too much it feels like if Emma or Timmy
have here I'm lit I'm really trying to
pray aggressive honestly with uh with my
pawns but also with the pieces here I
mean I have to not allow black to get so
much counter play right this is my goal
here right I mean I have to do something
now because he will take and isolate my
Pawn on D4 in fact he can take on D4
then I get an isolated Pawn now who has
a weakness we both do right nose can be
you know very uh Dynamic both sides have
things to do I got a D4 Pawn Yeah of
course Knight F3 makes sense I can take
back maybe but I mean I now have an
isolated Pawn on D4 if he takes so we
both have ISO pawns C6 is weak but D4 is
weak but I do like it he just has to
play you know for uh for peace activity
I see yeah decent move trying to play
provocative chess he's asking black to
actually step forward and block it up in
the center again I think the white
knight will happily Retreat back where
it came from losing two whole mousse for
weight but at least clarifying the
central attention and I'm not sure
whether that was worth the time I would
have just casted the white king away but
at least he's paused uh Fabiano caruana
here Fabi difficult decision
stylistically what to go for Block it or
capture he answered it because he
thought it does fall back and I think
for many of us to understand is very
important that if all the major pieces
do get traded actually it does favor
white in these positions simply because
of the queen Side Pawn structure yeah
and the dark Square Bishop for white is
way better than its counterpart the
bishop on G3 stares through the line all
the way to the enemy territory the
bishop on E7 is blockaded it's blunted
by that pawn on C5 so that decision to
play E4 that was a game-changing
decision not that the evaluation bar is
completely out of hand but he could have
taken on D4 but he was worried about
tactics so that was a big moment it's
worth analysis but right now I think the
current state of affairs definitely
favors artemia and
Robert said he is taking advantage of
the open B file because black doesn't
have the option to bring the Rook slide
it down to that B8 Square because of
that Bishop on G3 that is the key piece
in White's position it's like a sniper
it's like an Archer from afar just
peering all over this diagonal cutting
the board in half and white has the
advantage look at that evaluation bar
it's all about Artemis right now uh
still with one extra minute on the clock
he's brought his Knight forward as well
I was just thinking of this Knight A4
and ab6 idea and literally just killing
the queen side every piece I own is
going to go to the queen side over here
Fabi definitely needs to do something
fast with this dark Square Bishop I mean
that Bishop is menacing I mean even Rook
A7 is coming we're over to C7 Queen A4
Knight B3 Knight A5 the Pawn's mine
right it's very very difficult now of
course if you get the Rook to C7 it may
be a bishop d8 so you have to be careful
but uh the C6 is very weak white has a
very clear plan yeah meanwhile Fabi
needs to check mate while the white
pieces are distracted over there on the
queen side he's got to go for the white
king hence his last move pushing that
black H Pawn forward Harry making an
appearance again Harry
but uh he's doing what he needs to do he
needs to Checkmate white I think that's
the only way it seemed it could seem
desperate you could read that as oh he's
getting in trouble on the queen side so
he's just throwing his possible it
actually is thematic right you attack in
the direction of your Pawn chain White's
Pawn chain all the way towards the queen
side blacks Pawn chain from C6 D5 E4
into the center over towards the king
side so Bobby's throwing his pieces
forward and he's creating some chaos and
if you look at the clock it's about even
so white has an advantage according to
the evaluation bar but when you sit and
play at this high level you're not
thinking oh I'm you know 1.2 better
you're looking at this and you're saying
this looks complicated I may crash
through on the queen side over here or I
may get checkmate on the king side yeah
and in those terms Robert the stakes are
higher for white White's King is much
more valuable than those black pawns on
the queen side so White's play is
designed in a materialistic fashion you
want to pick off pawns you want to
slowly Advance you want to trade off
pieces but for black it's one-way
traffic you just checked me there's one
goal and that's actually easier to play
when you're short of time like this in
Blitz it's easier to attack than defend
right and uh that's why I'll tell me if
it's tanking 100 because I mean after
Ace three I mean I don't know if I'm a
psyched out or not but I definitely okay
so you play H4 because he was like I
mean he might sack it so it is possible
we play H4 here I'm also looking at
believe it or not white playing Knight
A8 just whoa it's such a stupid move
because but it's so funny I mean I
actually played a game OCB where I put a
knight on H1 and when I put it I twisted
it because you never make a move like
that right so Knight A8 just going back
for a knight to C7 looks pretty fun it's
a fun move now Knight G4 blocks
everything I don't know what we got oh
he's hitting H4 that's what he wants
yeah so maybe 98 now but I mean the idea
here is I want to clear that I want to
clear the way of the Knight to get the
queen involved Queen B7 and and also um
Rook a you know Rook takes C6 whoa you
want to move this one five okay same
idea James but maybe an even better
route into that Square thank you what
are you doing taking this point somebody
says 64. yeah there's a pen and if you
take it Bishop C4 it's a skewer it's on
the board okay and mix up F7 as well wow
look at this double attack who's up on
material here it doesn't even matter
it's just pure Chaos on the board and uh
pieces everywhere white has a rook and
two pawns black has two minor pieces
White's one point ahead but and can
happen here and I like the minor pieces
because as you were saying Checkmate
ends the game white king not to save us
but Black's King also is in a bit iffy
territory there are not many pawns
shielding it but H4 is loose the bishop
the Dark Sword bishop and the Knight for
black team up on that pawn I think that
this is a crazy position and I'm looking
at the clock artemium is the one down on
time and there is no increment in this
game he's lived on the increment he
can't live on increment because it
doesn't exist that's a race to the
finishing line now and okay Fabi has
snatched upon White's lone defender of
his King is that Bishop White's Bishop
if it's traded off suddenly you start to
be worried that for a time yeah as I saw
in the chat there Fabio about to enter
god mode he's at least trying to uh big
attack incoming
stem the flow can he maybe launch an
attack of his own bring the white Rook
up to the seventh rank threaten the
Checkmate of his own against the black
king that's nice I think you have to
take it first you just just to have your
your uh the Knight you have to make a
few moves before you actually are mating
me you do have to get on this dark
Square diagonal and be Queen H2 that's
going to be difficult it's not actually
that easy yet and I do have some threats
of my own in fact your queen is a little
short on spaces there but if I let you
know you have to do something because
Bishop takes G3 is very it's ugly I mean
your structured ugly E3 is going to fall
at some point right so it's very
annoying so you may have to take and
then maybe Queen C6 or Rook A7 now you
may have to take but you definitely have
to move look at this one and a half
minutes down now I'll tell me if he's
Frozen this too much in an Armageddon
you can't burn the clock so much make a
move what's going on there Robert and
let's not forget that Fabiano caruana is
the only player who has not lost a match
either in the air things Masters or The
Trestle Masters he came through division
two but he won every single match he
played he won yesterday right now he's
in Armageddon so he has not lost and we
see a trade of Bishops and G3 what a
calm move from Martinez kicking the
night out of there but he didn't take
the potency six just yet and I guess a
big question is is that Knight actually
under attack sometimes you can't take a
piece if it opens up your king
but three and a half minutes for our
time we have this is a panic time he
needs to start building an attack
against the black king should he be
looking at ideas of capturing the C6
spawner doubling up on the seventh rank
yeah he's definitely angling towards
that if the Black Knight Retreats if
black steps back white will happily have
the time to start grabbing pawns but I
think the question is as uh you're both
alluding to that do you have to move
that black knight can you somehow bring
that black queen into the game if you
could pick her up just drop her anywhere
near the white king it's a Checkmate but
how do you get there what's the route
into White's position that's what Fabian
is trying to work out right now he's
thinking about Queen G6 and just
sacrificing the night just uh pinning
that King on G1 but then you probably
pick up the C6 Pawn Robert but I see
what you're saying you're looking for a
draw because black wins with the draw
result card he does sacrifice oh my gosh
that Bishop hits the queen and the rook
in a row but also it goes through the F2
Pawn so it's kind of a double threat
what a move from Fabiano fabul with them
calculations over everything look at him
that's a big boy move from a big fella
no matter what you do in fact Rook a a
bishop C8 any move you make bishop C8
right so you have to be very careful
that is a sick move from Queen f8
world-class move from fabianos that
would not be on most players radar just
x-ray vision through the through the
bishop through its own piece and
vladislavartame brings his Queen to the
side he's ready to drop back with Bishop
after this is just over yeah but we're
treating moves are the easiest to miss
but this is a game-ending move double
attack if he finds it he wins on the
spot look at that the engine says plus
seven for black
and leans back he knows this is a big
moment has missed it and our Tamia
realizes this is busted for white takes
his head it's over Fabi Oh My Fabulous
Fabi clutch move queen of Fate that is
genius just that double attack was too
sneaky vladislav didn't have enough time
to deal with it just the shock of that
move Queen takes poor now would end in
Chapman or the white Rook will drop one
or the other no exaggeration but with
the speed with how little time he has
with the tension of the moment that's
early candidate for move of the year
that was a nasty move yeah I think Queen
effort more than the bishop
insane stuff right oh my gosh now it's
up a piece yeah yep gonna win and he's
just a draw
this is just over F5 Fighters got no
compensation the F5 Pawn Falls as well
the only hope that our Tamia has got is
to pick up the C pawn and start marching
down with the center pawns how dangerous
is that
um
protected and uh yeah clear piece up wow
you don't even have one Pawn to
compensate for that extra Bishop now and
look at that black knight beautiful
blockader in the center of the board
this one as long as Fabi doesn't Mouse
slip or lose on time it is over
Fabiano the human calculator Coe
beautiful yeah it's why they call them
that that was insane like that truly
deserves as many instant replays as you
can give it and five minutes maybe down
on the clock that's the thing normally
white has this big time Advantage but
right now Fabiano head in the clock he
found that Queen f8 moves so quickly
that was nasty that was yeah most
beautiful moves their sacrifices you
sack your queen you sack your Rook you
break through you Checkmate that was
just subtle it was just kind of the
Hidden Beauty behind it that's another
level another time you have collapsed
right the plundering into Bishop C8 and
that's what happens when you make moves
like Queen f8 with no obvious idea and
they're so difficult to find because
it's not a forward move it's just a
slight shift of the queen leaving the
Knight hanging and this end game though
artemiev is playing there are no chances
at all he's doing the right thing why
resign and go
Han as well play a few more moves at
least Force Fabi to show the uh the
final touches
yeah Fabi has got nervous in the past so
some track record there but yeah I agree
Tanya I think 99.99 of the time Fabi uh
will win this one and uh okay the king's
coming in but the Black Knight can come
in with a check now stop picking off
pawns or the black king can just slide
back play it safe why not thank you just
not allowing any checks any Fork picking
up the C6 Pawn there is a check from D6
but it doesn't matter black can just
slide over with the King to E7 now yeah
because you make a draw I I honestly
keep forgetting about that that black
I'm like oh it's easily winning but he
can just repeat the moves and of course
vladislav does it at best a draw is good
for him in a normal game but this is a
normal time again wow that's
professional yeah that's professional
yeah wow
he knows he was trailing the match he
won the fourth game making a comeback
forces it into the Armageddon an amazing
play with the black pieces there yeah
you know he kept steady on the clock he
of course played a great game but
credits of vladison rotemian that Knight
takes D5 move happened at a thin air he
took it to Fabiano he gave him all he
could handle but Fabiana was just on his
rarest best form yeah he did our time we
have did create his chances with the
white pieces in a win on demand but we
all know what was the moment and let's
do a deep dive at this stunning position
David take it away yeah
yeah what a move what a moment it was it
clinched the match for Fabiano caruana
and none of us saw her coming here in
the studio and I'll tell me if most
importantly didn't see it coming either
here Black's Knight is attacked White's
just pushed to pawn forward most of us
would Retreat this night what could be
more natural but Fabiano had a counter
attack obviously if he shifted the queen
across using an x-ray to actually
threaten some checkmating ideas more
importantly the bishop is about to move
out the way with Tempo and uh Fabiano
missed this of course the only defense
was so difficult to spot you needed to
bring your Rook up to the top of the
board with the idea that if the bishop
Dives back with a double attack hitting
the queen hitting this Pawn as well you
can actually ignore the threat to your
queen you can play Knight takes Pawn so
difficult to spot because this bishop is
actually pinned it is uh pinned to the
queen if you take the White Queen now
white emerges with the material
advantage of course this was missed the
White Queen moved out the way the black
Bishop dropped back and Fabiano caruana
moved to the next round Queen takes F2
threatened and Bishop takes A6
threatened this was too for the time we
have to handle
stunning stuff that by Fabiano caruana
and with that he stays in the Winner's
bracket let's take a look at our results
from the semi-finals what a day of
action we've had let's take our Nakamura
wrapping up his match against Wesley so
in the rapid portion with two and a half
points and then Fabi making a comeback
in his match winning the fourth rapid
game taking it to the Armageddon and
then this moment that David showed us
just a complete collapse there by
artemiah Fabiano caruana stays in the
Winner's bracketime and Wesley so move
to the elimination bracket we've got
Tabby with us let's bring him on Fabi
congratulations
wow that was a really dramatic match a
roller coaster one sum it up for us Fabi
yeah I guess the first game already
showed how uh how messy this match was
likely to be I was much much better
probably winning than I was dead like
completely dead
um I was almost ready to like mentally
resigning uh but somehow I drew that
first game
um
and oh I mean the well sorry the the
first the first game was just like a
boring draw so I almost forgot about it
but like the the second game where I had
the white pieces is what I mean
um so that was a crazy one and then
I lost like a complete uh idiot I mean I
I don't know what I was thinking like I
was better the whole game and then
suddenly I okay I should take a draw but
somehow I decided
um to play on and immediately give him a
much much better and probably winning
position
so that was a terrible game uh to
recovering from a mentally was already
um was already difficult but luckily I
got a very nice position from the
opening in the fourth game
and I don't know if it was smooth like
at some point
I was considering for a long time do I
play 91 because I was sure that he would
sacrifice uh the palm of Knight F4 and
so basically I I wasn't sure about it I
saw this line up to like my takes of
seven it looked like a mess
um but then I decided I'll go for it and
and count on his time trouble and
hopefully he won't be able to find the
best way
and yeah that was super important and
the Armageddon also was a mess I mean I
might have been much worse at some point
it was I was very happy when I saw this
queen f8 because at first I Knight F3
was like the first instinct but it
didn't seem entirely uh convincing and
then I suddenly noticed that like I saw
Bishop C8 and then
um and then there's like some Queen
update ideas so first I was looking at
Bishop C8 and and then suddenly I
noticed that I can start with queen f8
and it's probably a more promising
version
so yeah it was a very tough day very
top-notch
I mean it was a
proportion we saw
we saw so many times that our time have
played amazing chess with just seconds
on the clock was that frustrating at any
point that you were not able to make the
most of the clock situation
yeah it felt a little bit like the the
match against uh the Quan Liam in that
when when we're both in time trouble
then he's uh he's playing better than me
much much better
so um that was a bit frustrating there
were some positive sides to it that I I
was always keeping an advantage on the
clock but I sort of thought that would
happen because I noticed from his match
against Magnus that he's very often uh
playing very deliberately at the start
of the game
I actually like I I don't know if it's
just his style or if it's uh
maybe because they've worked together
but he he does remind me in as a player
in some ways of uh who also is very
deliberate at the start of the game very
careful methodical again gets into time
trouble but then doesn't seem to
negatively affect him as much as it
might another player so I kind of
expected that I I knew that I would
struggle if we were both down to seconds
and that's what happened
but uh luckily in the fourth game I
managed to keep a very healthy buffer on
the clock
and Fabiano of the players who have
played in both the air things Masters
and the chesso Masters you're the only
player who has not lost a match what is
about this four matter what's gotten
into you how are you getting this done
well I think that's a little bit too
generous I did I did lose a match to
Alexei Serrano
um which is the reason why I was
relegated to division two
uh in the in the previous tournament but
besides that I haven't lost a match yet
I mean uh I hope it stays that way it's
it's definitely very difficult I mean
the match yesterday was difficult the
match today was even more difficult
um and I imagine the next match will
will not be any easier at the very least
so it's really tough but
luckily I'm fighting well like if I'm in
different difficult situation then I I
am fighting back well
my play isn't perfect but at least my
fighting spirit is there
it's amazing player there uh Fabi
especially in the Armageddon we really
loved that moment with queen f8 and now
just looking ahead to tomorrow's match
you will be playing against Hikaru
give us your thoughts on what that's
going to be like
yeah well we've had a lot of experience
against each other we've played so many
games not so many matches but definitely
definitely many many games
um we played over the board matches
stretching back from 2015.
and I also remember a crazy match we
played in the first uh it was like the
first chess 24 Tour event I forget about
the name of it but it was like the first
event organized in 2020 after uh covet
hit and and chess moved online for uh
for a while it was like the first event
I played after the candidates and I
played hikar in a match and I lost why
didn't I had to win in black on demand
and I won that but then I lost this tie
break
uh so yeah he I mean he's so good
um that's obviously not a revelation to
anyone especially in faster time
controls I mean of course also in
classical but in in these matches he's
um he's self-efficient
and I think it already shows that he got
to the final last time and here he
already won two matches including
against Wesley that in this format he's
really really tough yeah it's gonna be a
big fight Bobby and we are so excited to
watch the action tomorrow
congratulations one more time and good
luck for tomorrow
thank you
stays in the Winner's bracket and let's
take a look at the bracket going forward
this is where we are we're gonna see a
big match there with Fabiano taking on
Hikaru James your thoughts on that one
yeah of course uh that's gonna be a
heavyweight matchup as everybody know
all American heavyweight matchup but uh
Bobby's in and run for his money here I
mean Nakamura is definitely on a tear
here he does this in all the short time
controls he wins everything he streams
eight hours on a Tuesday cleaning up
title Tuesdays is like a bully in a way
now of course this is rapid now and it's
a little bit more time here and Carolina
is definitely capable of doing it but I
don't think he should get in any type of
time trouble against Nakamura here yeah
yeah both players have nerves of Steel
just the way they managed it today
neither really at their best but they
came when it mattered with those
incredible moves Queen f8 I think move
of the tournament move of the years
Robert says I still think nakamura's
slight favorite in this format but uh
yeah Bobby capable of anything I would
agree yeah hikara is playing excellent
chess but my focus is down below look at
Wesley so and Magnus Carlsen one of them
is going to get eliminated in fifth
place these were top three finishers
from the air things Masters but one of
them is going home after tomorrow yeah
one of them will be relegated to play
the play-ins for the next event imagine
Wesley so against Magnus Carlsen that
could be a final in its own right so
tomorrow is for elimination yeah that's
a really big one as well Wesley against
Carson and both of them facing
elimination what are we expecting from
that David
it's going to go to Armageddon I'll
predict who wins who knows I love it we
always enjoy an Armageddon and that's
what we were treated to today we're at
Fabiano caruana eventually winning his
match against vladislav or tamiab let's
take a look at also what happened in
division two bracket today some huge
matchups and huge results there not a
bag abductor of the former World rapid
Champion took down archon aragasi that
was a fun fight yeah no deerback is
playing excellent chess he took down a
niche gear yesterday in Arjun era guys
today Dennis lazwick he is a standout
he's a teenager people underestimate him
they don't know about him but he is
taking down duboff and Vincent kheimer
back to back Maxine Russell three nil
that's a clean sweep he did benefit from
a mouse slip from Prague Nanda in the
third game it was already you know going
to be a win for him in the match but
probably on the blunters queen yeah and
Maxim and Vladimir kramnik winning their
matches so experience did win against
youth in that one division three was
also on with some big names the biggest
shocker that Robert Shakira Muhammad
yarov in division three to start with
but he did win the losers bracket yeah
he got a win in the losers bracket but
the day continued it's long you know
really long days in division three uh he
took down Alvar Alonso the Spanish
Grandmaster and then he went on and lost
to Wei Yi so Matthias bluebaum where he
they make it through the lose weight
round five of the losers bracket they
played so many games at this point
so much action division one two three
packed with big names big drama David
what was your biggest takeaway awesome
Italian but the biggest one is that
these players they're Geniuses but
they're also human some mistakes but
also those beautiful moves so I'm going
to go back and study some of those Queen
I think what a blue and uh yeah I'm
hoping for more of the same tomorrow
this is so much fun and that move Queen
f8 I think that's going to be in our
minds for a long time James what did you
enjoy the most well two things here time
management make sure you guys are
managing your time correctly and they
try to work on it as much as you can and
the second thing is do your tactics
queen f8 that was gross that was a nasty
move from Fabi that means that boy does
Tactics every single day hopefully
you're doing yours at home
oh wow some good advice there by James a
so much fun and the drama of course
continues we've got a big winner final
coming up and All American clash as
Fabiano caruana takes on Hikaru Nakamura
and big matches in the losers bracket as
well once again a big shout out to our
chat thank you so much for joining us
it's been a fun ride calling the action
today for day two of the chessable
Masters we will be back with more
tomorrow same time same place see you
then
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]